GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN --
DAVID CHIU IS --
ON HIS WAY AND AS A COURTESY WE
WOULD LIKE TO WAIT FOR HIS
ARRIVAL HE SHOULD BE HERE
SHORTLY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
.
THE MORNING ONE WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING --
THAT IS BEING HELD WITH THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
ALMOND COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK OUR CO
CHAIR SIMPLY WOMAN.
COME AS REYES FOR HELPING TO
COLLABORATE ON THIS HEARING WITH
ME AND I WANT TO JUST APOLOGIZE
AT THE OUTSET --
ALMOST TWO HOURS AGO I DROP MY
SON OFF A NURSERY SCHOOL AND GOT
CAUGHT IN TRAFFIC IN THREE
PLACES BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
HERE SO APOLOGIES FOR STARTING
LATE --
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT.
THE MORE CRISIS OF THE DAY WHICH
IS THE PLIGHT OF HOMELESSNESS ON
THE STREETS OF CALIFORNIA --
I KNOW THAT EVERY MEMBER.
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THIS ROOM
AS WELL AS MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS KNOW THE STRUGGLE
OF SO MANY CALIFORNIANS ON OUR
STREETS IN EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OVER THE
YEARS --
BETWEEN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STATE
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THROUGH MANY MANY
DIFFERENT POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
AND YET HOMELESSNESS NOT ONLY
CONTINUES --
BUT IT IS INTENSIFYING.
AND SO WE WANTED TO HOLD TODAY'S
HEARING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
ON THIS TOPIC BECAUSE WE WANT TO
KNOW FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
THE STATE LEVEL TO THE LOCAL
LEVELS WHAT PROGRAMS WHAT
POLICIES ARE WE WORKING ON THAT
WORK.
WHAT GAPS IN COVERAGE DO WE HAVE
WHAT MORE OR SHOULD WE BE DOING?
WE KNOW THAT HOMELESSNESS CUTS
ACROSS MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
PROGRAMS.
ARE AND IN ORDER FOR US TO
SUCCESSFULLY TACKLING WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO HAVE A COORDINATED
APPROACH.
IT IS OUR HOPE THAT THIS HEARING
HELPS TO HIGHLIGHT SUCCESSES IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AS WELL
AS THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE MAY
HAVE TO IMPROVE RESPONSE --
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AS A CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND OUR COMMITTEE.
WE ALL KNOW WE NEED SAFE STABLE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO MOVE
PEOPLE OUT OF HOMELESSNESS AND
TO PREVENT THEM FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE A VERY
DELIBERATE AND THOUGHTFUL
RESPONSE --
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY FELLOW
CULTURE AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON THIS WITH US.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU CHAIRMAN.
TO IT'S SUCH AN HONOR TO BE HERE
WITH ALL OF YOU --
AND I THINK THE CHAIRMAN HAS
DESCRIBED THIS APPROPRIATELY
IT'S A MORAL IT'S THE MORAL
CRISIS OF THE DAY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AND THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE --
HAVING OUR COMMITTEES HOLD THIS
DISCUSSION TOGETHER REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE WIDESPREAD REACH
AND IMPACTS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE EQUALLY WIDESPREAD
RESPONSIBILITY WE ALL HAVE TO
SEEK SOLUTIONS TO THIS CRISIS.
WE KNOW THAT ACHIEVING PERMANENT
HOUSING WITH NO BARRIERS. TO
ENTRY HELPS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ACHIEVE HOUSING
STABILITY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
NEED ACCESS TO KEY SERVICES
INCLUDING SERVICES TO REMOVE
BARRIERS RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT.
HEALTH.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
FACTORS THAT CAN HINDER HOUSING
STABILITY.
I'M EXCITED THAT TODAY WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES ACROSS
THE STATE AND ACROSS THE NATION
THE PROVIDE ACCESS TO HOUSING
AND SERVICES.
WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT GAPS AND AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
AS WE WORK TO IDENTIFY NEXT
STEPS FOR CAL FREE HAND SIMPLY.
ADDRESS THE CRISIS THAT IS
HOMELESSNESS.
I DO WANT TO APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE THAT I WILL BE LEAVING
BRIEFLY FOR PRIVATE PRIOR
COMMITMENT BUT I WILL RETURN.
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING AND
LEARNING FROM THE WITNESSES AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY TO ADDRESS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT
AFFECTS ALL OF US AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LET ME
ASK BEFORE THE FIRST PANEL TO
ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUE SEVEN
INITIAL STATEMENTS YOU LIKE TO
MAKE.
WITH THAT ONE A WE MOVED TO OUR
FIRST PANEL WE HAD ASKED A
NUMBER OF EXPERTS IN VARIOUS
FEDERAL AND STATE RESPONSES TO
HOMELESSNESS TO JOIN US TODAY --
AND IF I COULD ASK THE FOUR
WITNESSES TO PLEASE --
SIT AT THE DíAS.
I COULD ASK EACH OF YOU TO MAYBE
GRAB YOUR NAME CARD SO THAT --
TELEVISION COVERAGE CAN KNOW WHO
YOU ARE.
AND TODAY WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
FOR INDIVIDUALS ON THIS PANEL MS
CYNTHIA NECK INJURY --
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR CAPACITY BUILDING AT
THE NATIONAL LINES TO END
HOMELESSNESS?
MISS JENNIE PUT A FOOT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
SECOND STEAD THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR HOUSING POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THEN
ALLEY SUDDEN --
WHO IS THE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
WANT TO WELCOME EACH OF YOU?
AND WANT WE PROCEED IN THE ORDER
LISTED IN OUR AGENDA TODAY
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR THE THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEES ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE TO END HOMELESSNESS I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU TO
DISCUSS HOW CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE
TRUE PROGRESS.
ON THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS IS A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
TO PREVENTING AN ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE U. S..
AT THE ALLIANCE WE KNOW THAT A
GREAT DEAL OF HARD WORK AND
STRATEGIC THINKING HAVE BEEN
GOING ON HERE IN MANY LOCALITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ABOUT WHAT TO DO ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AND WE WANT TO
COMMEND AND THANK THESE
COMMUNITIES MANY OF WHICH ARE
HERE TODAY. FOR WORKING TO END
THIS COMPLEX PROBLEM IN A
GROWING WE DIFFICULT DIFFICULT
HOUSING ENVIRONMENT.
FEDERAL PROGRAMS PRIMARILY HIDE
THE VA AND THE U. S. INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS AMONGST
OTHERS.
HAVE COME TO RECOGNIZE THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS A HOUSING ISSUE
THAT HAS PROVEN SOLUTIONS THAT
CAN EN PEOPLE'S HOMELESSNESS
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
EVEN IN A VERY EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKET AND TRIES TO FIND THOSE
SOLUTIONS.
THE STATE ALSO HAS A KEY ROLE TO
PLAY IN IMPLEMENTING THE
SOLUTIONS AND ENSURING THAT
THESE VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE HOMES.
AND THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
STAY THERE THE STATE SENATE'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN CRITICAL AND IS APPRECIATED.
WE KNOW THE LIVES IT WILL SAVE
AND THE FAMILIES IT WILL MAKE
HOLE WE KNOW THE TAX PAYERS
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE FREED UP.
AND WE KNOW THE HEALTH IT WILL
BRING BACK TO CAL TODAY I'M
GOING TO BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE
NATIONAL TRENDS AND HOMELESSNESS
WERE CALIFORNIA STANDS IN REGARD
TO THE NATION.
AND KEY SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN WHICH I WILL
DISCUSS TO CRUCIAL AREAS OF
ACTIVITIES HOUSING AND A LOCAL
SYSTEMIC HOMES CRISIS RESPONSE
SYSTEM.
SO FIRST WHERE DO WE STAND ON
HOMELESSNESS NATIONALLY.
HOMELESSNESS IS A COMMON
PHENOMENON IN THE NATION AS IT
IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA OUR MOST
RECENT NUMBERS ARE FROM.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NATIONALLY FIVE
AND 520-008-0030 PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS ON A GIVEN NIGHT A
POINT IN TIME.
HOW'S THAT BROKEN DOWN.
A THIRD OR ABOUT 35% OF PEOPLE
ARE ON SHELTER NATIONALLY AND
MOST TWO THIRDS OR INDIVIDUAL
HOMELESS ADULTS. 33% OF HOMES
PEOPLE ARE IN FAMILIES AND 16%
ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS NATIONALLY.
THE MOST DRAMATIC DECREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS HAVE BEEN AMONG
VETERANS AND CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
VETERANS HAS DECREASED BY 38%
AND CHRONICALLY HOMES
INDIVIDUALS BY 26%.
THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN DECREASES
AND ALMOST EVERY SUBPOPULATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SIZEABLE FEDERAL INVESTMENT IN
THOSE PARTICULAR POPULATIONS
OTHER REASON FOR THOSE MAJOR TO
CLIENTS AS WELL AS INCREASINGLY
SMART COORDINATED APPROACHES.
FOR THIS AND OTHER REASONS THE
ALLIANCE HAS RECENTLY TURNED
MUCH OF ITS FOCUS TO CREATING A
FRAMEWORK TO TARGET MORE
RESOURCES TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONGST OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
ADULTS.
AS THIS IS THE LARGEST PERCENT
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION AND
HAS THE SMALLEST AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES DEVOTED TO THEM.
WE ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA TO LOOK
CLOSELY AT THIS RESPONDING
RESOURCES AS WELL SINCE THERE IS
A SIMILAR PICTURE HERE.
WELL HOMELESSNESS IS STILL A
CRISIS THE OVERALL HOMES
POPULATION HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
DECREASING STEADILY OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS NATIONALLY.
HAS DECREASED THIRTEEN POINT 6%
IN THE LAST DECADE.
THOUGH THERE WAS A SLIGHT UPTICK
ABOUT LESS THAN 1% IN THE LAST
YEAR LOT OF THAT COMES FROM
CALIFORNIA.
SO WHY HAS HOMES HAS GENERALLY
BEEN GOING DOWN NATIONALLY.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE FIELD HAS
GOTTEN SMARTER ABOUT HOW TO HELP
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
FEDERAL PROGRAMS HAVE FOCUSED ON
INVESTING IN PROVEN AND
PERMANENT HOUSING ORIENTED
SOLUTIONS.
CORD NEEDED CRISIS RESPONSE
SYSTEMS USING DATA BETTER AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET PEOPLE
BACK INTO HOUSING FASTER.
AND AS WE'VE BEEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE ATTRACTED MORE
FEDERAL INVESTMENT UNLIKE MOST
SOCIAL ISSUES.
AS THE PROBLEM HOMES HAS HAS
GOTTEN SMALLER THE FEDERAL MONEY
FOR HOMES IS ACTUALLY GENERALLY
GOTTEN BIGGER AND THE GOVERNMENT
HAS INVESTED IN THE STRATEGIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IS THE
MAJOR DRIVER OF HOMELESSNESS
ACROSS THE NATION AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE
SPEND FAR TOO MUCH OF THEIR
INCOME ON RENT.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS AREAS
WITH GROWING NUMBERS OF COST
BURDEN HOUSEHOLDS CAN EXPECT
INCREASES AND HOMELESSNESS.
THESE PLACES ARE OFTEN CITIES.
SO HOW DOES CALIFORNIA COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES AND TO THE
NATIONAL TRENDS.
CALIFORNIA AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
HAS MORE PEOPLE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE AND THE
NATION.
AND OF VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
THEM ARE ON SHELTERED MAINLY
LIVE OUTSIDE IN PLACE IS NOT
MEANT FOR HUMAN HABITATION. 20%
OF THE NATION'S HOMELESS PEOPLE
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
PEOPLE AT A POINT IN TIME.
AMONG THE SUBPOPULATIONS OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE MOST ON CHILDREN HOMELESS
PEOPLE OF ANY STATE NEARLY
NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE 69%
OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S HOMES POPULATION IS
ON SHELTER THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
OVERALL HOMELESSNESS DECREASE
NATIONALLY BY ABOUT 6% INCREASE
IN CALIFORNIA BY ABOUT 9%.
HOWEVER IN THAT SAME FIVE YEARS
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS DECREASED
NATIONALLY BY 21% AND IN
CALIFORNIA FAMILY HOMES IS
ACTUALLY ALSO DECREASED BY 19% --
AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT LATER
ABOUT HOW THAT SEEMS TO REALLY
COINCIDE WITH THE INCREASED
INVESTMENT AND RAPID RE HOUSING
ESPECIALLY AT THE HSP PROGRAM.
SO CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
BECOMES POPULATION IN MAKING A
DENT HERE WILL MAKE A BIG DENT
OVERALL IN THE NATION.
NOW ON TO DISCUSSING THE
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS THAT
WE KNOW ARE WORKING NATIONALLY
AS WELL AS IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW
FEDERAL AND STATE PROGRAMS
RESPOND.
FROM CAREFUL RESEARCH THE
EXPERIENCE OF LEADING
COMMUNITIES AND GROWING AND A
GROWING POOL OF NATIONAL DATA.
THE KEY ELEMENTS OF A SUCCESSFUL
APPROACH TO ENDING HOMES AS HAVE
BECOME CLEAR.
THERE ARE TWO CRUCIAL AREAS OF
ACTIVITIES AND BOTH ARE
ESSENTIAL TO MAKING A LASTING
IMPACT ON HOMELESSNESS AND
CREATING GOOD SYSTEM FLOW.
WHICH MEANS MOVING PEOPLE
QUICKLY FROM HOMELESSNESS TO
HOUSING.
NUMBER ONE HAVING LOCAL
COORDINATED DATA DRIVEN HOMELESS
CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEMS THAT USE
A SYSTEMIC RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS THAT IS ENTIRELY
FOCUSED ON RE HOUSING PEOPLE.
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND
DIVERTING PEOPLE FROM
HOMELESSNESS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A HOMELESS CRISIS RESPONSE
SYSTEM IN PLACE THAT IF YOU ARE
ABOUT TO BECOME HOMELESS OR YOU
BECOME HOMELESS YOU CAN BE
IDENTIFIED.
KEPT SAFE AND THEN QUICKLY MOVED
BACK INTO HOUSING.
AND SECOND HAVING HOUSING
RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT MAKES
HOUSING MORE FOR AFFORDABLE OVER
ALL SEE PEOPLE HAVE HOUSING TO
GO TO AND CAN MAINTAIN THAT
HOUSING.
WILL START THE SECOND AREA
HOUSING. THREE BASIC THINGS WE
NEED FOR HOUSING ARE.
RENT SUBSIDIES TO THE PEOPLE
WITH VERY LOW RENT.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FUNDING SO
THAT MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE
AVAILABLE.
AND REASONABLE POLICIES
REGARDING LAND USE AND ZONING
THAT ALLOW FOR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
FEDERALLY SECTION EIGHT PUBLIC
HOUSING OTHER HAD HOUSING
PROGRAMS FUN THESE ACTIVITIES
HOWEVER THEY ARE NOT FUNDED
ANYWHERE NEAR THE LEVELS THAT
ARE NEEDED.
ONLY ABOUT 25% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS TYPE OF
PERMANENT RENT SUBSIDY.
EVER RECEIVE A VOUCHER.
THAT INVESTMENT HAS BEEN
DECREASING OVER TIME AT THE
FEDERAL LEVELS.
NEXT I'LL SPEND THE REST OF MY
TIME DISCUSSING THE SECOND AREA
OF ACTIVITIES THE COORDINATED
HOMELESS CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEM.
THIS AREA OF ACTIVITIES
FEDERALLY FUNDED BY THE HARD
CONTINUUM OF CARE PROGRAM BUT
ALSO LEAVES GAPS THAT LOCALITIES
HAVE TO FILL.
WHY IS A SYSTEMIC APPROACH
CRUCIAL THE APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFTED OVER THE PAST TWO
DECADES?
WHERE EFFORTS OF THE PREVIOUS
TWENTY YEARS WERE MARKED BY
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS WORKING TO
MANAGE THE PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS THE SYSTEMIC
COORDINATED APPROACH SEEKS TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM PERMANENTLY?
AND TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF
THE SYSTEMIC APPROACH ARE USING
HOUSING FIRST INTERVENTIONS AND
HAVING A STRATEGIC SYSTEMIC
RESPONSE THAT INVOLVES
PARTNERSHIP AT ALL LEVELS CITY
COUNTY STATE AND FEDERAL.
NOT MISSING THE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMES IS HAVE LOTS
OF PROBLEMS AND HAVE SERVICE
NEEDS HOMES THIS IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST HOUSING CRISIS.
THIS THE FEDERALRESPONSE
INVESTS IN THE SOLUTIONS THAT
WORK TO HOUSE PEOPLE QUICKLY
WERE DIVERT PEOPLE FROM IMMINENT
HOMELESSNESS.
WHY COMMUNITIES WITH THE BEST
RESULTS HAVE AN INTENSE FOCUS ON
HOUSING PEOPLE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WE SEE THAT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WE SEE THAT AND
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL?
THE HOUSING FIRST APPROACHED.
HELPING A HOMELESS PERSON MOVING
TO HOUSE OTHER HELP ONCE THE
PERSON IS HOUSED.
HAS PROVEN TO GET BETTER RESULTS
AT LESS COST WE'VE SEEN TONS OF
RESEARCH ON THIS OVER THE YEARS
SO WHAT IS HOUSING FIRST MEAN
OPERATIONALLY.
WE RECOMMEND TO PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT MODELS THAT USE THIS
APPROACH.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
RAPID RE HOUSING I WILL TOTAL
ABOUT THESE INTERVENTIONS AND
HOW TO EFFECTIVELY TARGET THESE
RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE THAT
NEED THEM --
AND I SEE THAT IN THE IN YOUR
PAPER YOU ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
DETAIL ABOUT THAT SOME HAPPENING
ANSWER QUESTIONS. FOR
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT
MARCH SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN HOMES FOR A LONG TIME
IT'S A SMALLER PERCENT OF OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION HERE.
PERMANENT HOUSING PARENTS WERE
OF HOUSING IS THE RIGHT SOLUTION.
WHEN IT IS AVAILABLE THAT IS A
PERMANENT HOUSING SUBSIDY
COUPLED WITH INTENSIVE SERVICES
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON KEEPING
PEOPLE HOUSED --
AND THEN CONNECTING WITH THEM
WITH ANY TREATMENT SERVICES THEY
MAY NEED TO STAY HOUSE FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T NEED PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THAT'S
MOST OTHER FOLKS.
YOU STILL NEED OTHER HOUSING
STRATEGIES AND THOSE HOUSING
STRATEGY SHOULD BE A COMBINATION
OF CRISIS AND EMERGENCY BEDS
RAPID RE HOUSING AND OTHER
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING.
WITH RESPECT TO CRISIS BEDS OR
SHELTERS OR NAVIGATION CENTERS
WE DO NEED SHELTER WE NEED
CHILDREN CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT LIVE ON THE STREETS
INTENSE OR IN CARS.
SHELTER ALONE IS NOT THE SOLE
SOLUTION.
TO BUT SHELTER IS NEEDED AS A
PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO STAY BRIEFLY
WHILE THAT SOLUTION HOUSING IS
BEING ARRANGED TO BE EFFECTIVE
SHELTER MUST BE LOW BARRIER AND
HOUSING FOCUSED AND ACCESSIBLE
TO ANYONE.
EXPERIENCING HOUSING CRISIS WITH
LITTLE TO NO PRECONDITIONS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT A
RIGHT TO SHELTER DOES NOT EQUATE
WITH THE RIGHT TO EXIT SHELTER
TO HOUSING.
HAVING THE HOUSING RESOURCES TO
EXIT PEOPLE TO ARE CRUCIAL TO
EFFECTIVE SHELTER DESIGN SO
HOUSING SHELTER REALLY NEED TO
GO TOGETHER.
YOU CAN BILL MORE SOLDIER
WITHOUT A HOUSING EXIT STRATEGY
PEOPLE GET STUCK IN SHELTER FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME AND YOU'LL
JUST HAVE TO KEEP BUILDING MORE
SOLDIERS BECAUSE I'LL JUST KEEP
GETTING FALL.
IF PEOPLE CAN GET OUT OF HOMES
IS ON THEIR OWN AND DON'T NEED
PERMITS PART OF HOUSING THEY
SHOULD HAVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
RAPIDLY HOUSING.
RAPIDLY HOUSING IS ANOTHER
HOUSING FOR A STRATEGY THAT ENDS
A PERSON'S HOMES AS QUICKLY.
BY USING IT IN LOOKS PENSIVE AND
SHORTER ASSISTANCE AND SERVICES.
THESE SORT OF SUBSIDIES RAPPER
HOUSING WORK WELL EVEN IN VERY
EXPENSIVE HOUSING MARKETS THE
DATA SHOWS IS THAT AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE PROGRAM SUCCEEDING QUICKLY
HOUSING HOMELESS PEOPLE AND
KEEPING THEM HOUSED AND THAT THE
SUBSTANTIAL MAJORITY DO NOT
RETURN TO HOMELESSNESS IN THE
NEAR TERM.
WE ALSO SEE THAT RAPIDLY HOUSING
IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND WORKS
BETTER THAN OTHER CRISIS
INTERVENTIONS LIKE LONG SHELTER
STAYS OR TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT RAPIDLY
HOUSING IS ABSOLUTELY GETTING
HARDER TO DO EFFECTIVELY BECAUSE
OF THE EXPENSE OF HOUSING
MARKETS IN CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T WANT TO PRETEND THAT
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY HARD WORK.
HOWEVER THIS IS STILL THE BEST
OPTION FOR MOST PEOPLE TO EXIT
HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE TO HELP
PEOPLE GET TO GET BACK INTO THE
HOUSING MARKET THAT IS.
NOT THE ONE WE WISH EXISTED
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
CHOICE WE MUST CONTINUE TO FIND
WAYS TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE TOOLS
TO NAVIGATE THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING.
PERHAPS INNOVATING BY OFFERING
SURE HOUSING MODELS AN ON GOING
CHAU SUBSIDIES.
THE HOME SYSTEM CANNOT SOLVE
EVERYTHING IT ALONE DOESN'T HAVE
THE POWER TO CHANGE THESE LARGER
ECONOMIC FORCES AT PLAY SO WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE CURRENT
HOUSING MARKET AND THESE
SOLUTIONS ARE IN FACT WORKING IN
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THE DECREASE IN FAMILY HOMES AS
APPEARS TO CORRELATE STRONGLY
WITH A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
INVESTMENT AND RAPIDLY HOUSING
FOR FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
FINALLY I'LL BRIEFLY MENTION
PREVENTION THE FEDERAL PARTNERS
ON HOMELESSNESS RECOMMEND A VERY
TARGETED FORMA PREVENTION CALL
DIVERSION WHICH HELPS TO DIVERT
PEOPLE WHO WERE LITERALLY
KNOCKING ON THE SHELTER DOOR
THEY NEED SHELTER TONIGHT.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND IMPROVING
DISCHARGE PLANNING FROM
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN FOSTER CARE
SYSTEMS BY REQUIRING THEM THOSE
SYSTEMS.
DIFFICULT THERE AFTER EFFORTS ON
HOUSING PEOPLE.
BY TARGETING PROBLEM SOLVING
HOUSING SUPPORT WE FROM THE
HOMELESS SYSTEM LOCALITIES CAN
REDUCE THE IN FLOW INTO
HOMELESSNESS REALLY KIND OF
TURNED DOWN THAT AUCET THAT IS --
CITING THE SYSTEM THAT'S WHY IS
ALSO INFORMED TO ALSO HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND LIVING
WAGE JOBS OF PEOPLE CAN MAINTAIN
THEIR CURRENT HOUSING.
STATE SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES
BY PUTTING IN STATE MONEY IN
LOOKING AT FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT
GO TO THE STATE THAT HAVE
GENERAL PURPOSES AND CAN BE
TARGETED.
TOWARDS THE ACTIVITIES I'VE
DISCUSSED AND FILL THE GAPS
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE NATION
BY USING TEN F. AND CHILD
WELFARE DOLLARS. TO STABILIZE
PEOPLE AND HOUSING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
AND FOR THE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION --
ONE THING I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
ALL THE PANEL SAYS IT BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE TO SEND YOUR TESTIMONY
TO US EITHER AT THIS MOMENT OR
OR IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT WE
VERY HELPFUL I'VE ALREADY
RECEIVED REQUESTS.
FOR AS PART OF A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
I'M TO ANY FOOT THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL.
MY REMARKS THIS MORNING WILL
ADDRESS THE ROLE AND SCOPE OF
THE COUNCIL.
THE ACTIONS AND DELIVERABLES WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON AND THE
STATUS OF THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY
A KEEP.
TURNING FIRST TO THE ROLE AND
SCOPE OF THE COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
HOUSING FIRST GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS.
AND AMONG OTHER THINGS TO
IDENTIFY AND COORDINATE STATE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS INITIALLY HOUSED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND GOT
OFF TO A VERY GOOD START THERE
FOR ITS FIRST YEAR.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
THE COUNCIL WAS TRANSFERRED TO
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY.
AND THE SECRETARY OF B. C. S. H.
THE AGENCY WAS DESIGNATED AS THE
CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL.
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ALSO PROVIDED
RESOURCES TO HIRE FULL TIME
STAFF FOR THE COUNCIL ONE OF
WHICH IS MYSELF.
AND THAT HAS ALLOWED THE ROLE IN
SCOPE OF THE COUNCIL TO EXPAND --
BEYOND WHAT AS POSSIBLE WHEN IT
WAS HOUSE H. T. T..
IT'S ALSO ELEVATED IT TO A LEVEL
THAT IS A CROSS MORE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS WHICH I
THINK HAS BEEN HELPFUL.
THE COUNCIL IS COMPRISED OF UP
TO NINETEEN MEMBERS REPRESENTING
THE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE
HOMELESSNESS RELATED PROGRAMS
AND HOUSING PROGRAMS.
ALONG WITH REPRESENTATIVES OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY
STAKE HOLDERS.
THE COUNCIL MEETS QUARTERLY.
AND THE COUNCIL MEMBERS PROVIDE
INPUT AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
CHAIR AND COUNCIL STAFF ON A
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES AND
PRIORITIES FOR THE COUNCIL.
THERE IS AN INTERAGENCY WORKING
GROUP THAT MEETS EVERY OTHER
WEEK THAT IS COMPRISED OF STAFF
FROM THE STATE MEMBERS OF THE
COUNCIL.
AND THAT'S THE GROUP THAT DOES A
LOT OF THE HANDS ON WORK TO
SUPPORT THE COUNCIL IN
IMPLEMENTING HOUSING FIRST.
AND TOUGH TACKLING SOME OF THE
OUT IT IS IN COORDINATING --
EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDER WAY.
I BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE HAS A
COPY OF THE COUNCIL'S GOVERNANCE
CHARTER WHICH WAS ADOPTED AT
LAST WEEK'S COUNCIL MEETING.
AND THAT HAS MORE OF THE DETAILS
ABOUT THE GOALS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE COUNCIL.
TURNING NEXT TO THE COUNCIL'S
CURRENT WORK I FIRST WANT TO SAY
THAT WERE OF SOME VERY SMALL
TEAM BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
ASPIRATIONS TO DO SOME OF THE
HARDENED PORTENT WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE --
AND ALSO OUR CURRENT WORK THAT
WE'RE UNDERTAKING EITHER
CURRENTLY OR HAVE PLANNED IN THE
UP COMING YEAR.
WE WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE%
SURE THAT OUR PRIORITIES ARE
ALIGNED WITH THOSE OF THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS TEAM.
IN ADDITION TO IMPLEMENTING HEAP
WHICH I WILL TALK ABOUT IN MORE
DETAIL IN A FEW MOMENTS.
ON THE COUNCIL IS IMPLEMENTING
SEVERAL OTHER KEY INITIATIVES.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO IMPLEMENT
HOUSING FIRST --
THERE HAS BEEN A CHECKLIST THAT
WAS DEVELOPED BY EACH C. D. AND
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
THAT PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO
DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES AS THEY
LOOK AT THEIR HOUSING AND
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES
PROGRAMS. TO ASSESS WHETHER
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
HOUSING FIRST REQUIREMENTS.
AND WHAT MODIFICATIONS TO
REGULATIONS OR GUIDELINES MIGHT
BE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
HOUSING FIRST IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
ALL INITIAL ASSESSMENTS IN
CHANGES TO STATE PROGRAMS NEED
TO BE IDENTIFIED AND WE APPLY ON
COURSE TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
THOSE BY JULY FIRST JULY JULY
FIRST -- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WERE SECONDLY
WERE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A POTENTIAL STATE
LEVEL HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH THE DATA NECESSARY TO MAKE
INFORMED POLICY DECISIONS.
AND TO BETTER ALIGN RESOURCES
IT'S OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IMMEDIATE PRIORITY PHASE.
ONE IS ESTABLISHING A STATE
HOMELESS DATA SYSTEM THAT GIVES
THE STATE ACCESS TO DATA THAT IS
ALREADY BEING COLLECTED AT TE
LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS.
THE SECOND PHASE WOULD BE TO
BUILD A PLATFORM THAT CAN ALSO
INTEGRATE AND ANALYZE DATA
COLLECTED FROM STATE AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENT PROGRAMS.
GIVING US A MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF WHO S HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE NECESSARY AND WHERE
SOME OF THOSE THE GAPS IN THOSE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS OUR IF
FUNDING IS MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THIS PROJECT.
WE ANTICIPATE PROCUREMENT FOR
PHASE ONE WHICH IS GIVING THE
STATE ACCESS TO DATA ALREADY
BEING COLLECTED.
THAT THAT PROCUREMENT COULD TAKE
PLACE LATE SUMMER.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'RE ALSO
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
WORK PLAN TO IMPLEMENT SB NINE
EIGHTEEN THE HOMELESS YOUTH ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE WILL
BE WORKING TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES AND TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE MANY
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS EXPERTS --
PROVIDERS AND PARTNERS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT STATE AND LOCAL
ENTITIES PROVIDING SERVICES TO
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
ARE IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES
WHICH CAN BE VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THOSE FOR ADULT POPULATIONS.
WE'RE ALSO EMBARKING ON AN
INITIATIVE TO DEVELOP A DATA
DRIVEN EVIDENCE BASED HIGH LEVEL
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR THE STATE.
THIS WORK WILL FOCUS ON
IDENTIFYING STATE STRATEGIES TO
DEVELOP TO STOP THE GROWTH IN
HOMELESSNESS TO SHELTER THE UN
SHELTERED.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
OVERALL HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A FIRST STEP IN THIS WORK WE
WILL BE ISSUING AN INVITATION TO
THE RESEARCH POLICY AND PROGRAM
EXPERTS IN THE STATE. TO PROVIDE
US WITH BRIEF WHITE PAPERS ON
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON THEIR
EVIDENCE BASED RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR PRIORITY ACTIONS THE STATE
SHOULD TAKE.
AND THERE ISN'T AN AMAZING
ABUNDANCE OF EXPERTISE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN DRAW ON
AND SO THE GOAL HERE IS TO
REALLY SYNTHESIZE.
A LOT OF THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE INTO A HIGH LEVEL PLAN THAT
CAN REALLY MOVE US FORWARD AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
DEVELOP AND COLLABORATE IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEER TO
PEER LEARNING.
ACROSS A NUMBER OF KEY TOPICS
INCLUDING IMPLEMENTING THE
HOMELESS MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS.
IMPLEMENTING BE COURTED ENTRY
SYSTEMS AND OTHER TOPICS THAT
REALLY FACILITATE EXACTLY WHAT
CYNTHIA JUST SPOKE ABOUT AN
EFFECTIVE.
LOCAL RAPID EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAM.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING FOR WAYS THAT
WE CAN ALIGN PROGRAM GOALS
APPLICATIONS REQUIREMENTS
REPORTING ACROSS STATE PROGRAMS
AND WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO EASE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS THEY
ARE APPLYING FOR AND MANAGING
FUNDS FROM A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING THROUGH THE
INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP.
TO SUPPORT THOSE OF OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS WHO HAVE DIRECT OUR
ROLES AND FIRE RECOVERY EFFORTS.
AND PARTICULARLY IN RESPONDING
TO THE HOMELESS AND HOUSING
CHALLENGES THAT ARE EXACERBATED
IN AREAS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
NATURAL DISASTER.
IN ADDITION TO ACTIVELY ENGAGING
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES TO
EXPEDITE THEIR RECEIPT OF HE
FUNDS WE CONTINUE TO FACILITATE
AND COORDINATE WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COUNCIL THROUGH
THE INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP.
TO SUPPORT THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR FIRE RECOVERY.
WE'VE ALSO JUST ISSUED A BRIEF
REPORT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
POINT IN TIME COUNTER THE PITCH
COUNT WHICH IS COMING UP WELL IS
ACTUALLY IN PROGRESS ACROSS THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
THIS WEEK AND NEXT WEEK.
ON THE INFORMATION IS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE AND INCLUDES CONTACT
INFORMATION.
FOR EACH OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE AGING WITHIN THAT CAN TO
MOVE CARE THE POINT TIME COUNT.
WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH SACRAMENTO STEPS FORWARD TO
PROVIDE --
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT STAFF ACROSS THE
COUNCIL TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
YEAR'S POINT IN TIME COUNT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
ALL OF OUR COUNCIL STAFF WILL BE
PARTICIPATING.
NEXT WEEK FOR TWO NIGHTS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND I BELIEVE THE THE ACCOUNT
THE COMMITTEE WAS PROVIDED OUR
ACTION PLAN ARE PROPOSED ACTION
PLAN FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND COUNSEL UPDATES IN THOSE
PROVIDE MORE DETAIL ABOUT.
OUR PROPOSED EFFORTS AND OUR
CURRENT ACTIVITIES. TO TURNING
LASTLY TO AN UPDATE ON KEEP.
HE WAS ESTABLISHED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
IT IS A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FOR ONE TIME FLEXIBLE
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE DIRECT EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE TO CITIES COUNTIES
AND CONTINUES OF CARE. TO
ADDRESS THEIR HOMELESSNESS NEEDS.
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS ARE THE
ELEVEN LARGEST CITIES IN THE
STATE THOSE WITH A POPULATION OF
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND OR MORE AS OF JANUARY
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THE
FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED USING A
FORMULA THAT IS LARGELY BASED ON
THE PROPORTION IN EACH C. O. C.
ARC OR CITY LARGE WELL C. O. C.
PRIMARILY --
OF THE STATE'S HOMELESS
POPULATION.
THE PROGRAM GUIDANCE WHICH
MAPPED OUT APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS IN ALLOWABLE
ACTIVITIES WAS ISSUED IN AUGUST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THE
NOTICE FOR OF AVAILABLE FUNDING --
WAS ISSUED ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH
AND WE RECEIVED OUR FIRST TWO
APPLICATIONS FROM OAKLAND AND
SAN DIEGO ON SEPTEMBER.
SIX AND I THINK THAT'S A RESULT
OF THE EFFORTS MAKING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE.
ON VERY STREAMLINED WITHIN AN
EMPHASIS ON GETTING FUNDS OUT
THE DOOR AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
KNOWING THE CRISIS IN MOST OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE NOW RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS FROM ALL FORTY
THREE CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND
ELEVEN LARGE CITIES.
AND WE RECEIVED THOSE BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS THE
DEADLINE FOR APPLICATIONS FOR
ROUND ONE OF FUNDING.
pOF US FIRSTLY BECAUSE IT IT
MEANS THE FUNDING WILL GO OUT
MORE QUICKLY.
AND ALSO BECAUSE IT MEANS WE
DON'T HAVE TO DO A SECOND ROUND
OF FUNDING AND THE KEEP TEAM CAN
INSTEAD TURNED ITS EFFORTS TO
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO ENSURE THE
FUNDS ARE BEING USED EFFECTIVELY
I BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
GIVEN A CHART THAT SUMMARIZES
THE STATUS OF HEAT FUNDING FOR
EACH OF THE A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AND I JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON A
FEW HIGH POINTS.
AS OF JANUARY SIXTEENTH.
ALL OF THE ELEVEN LARGE CITIES
AND THIRTY FIVE CONTINUES OF
CARE HAVE BEEN AWARDED THEIR
FUNDS THAT MEANS WE GOT THEIR
APPLICATION WE TURNED IT AROUND
WE WE DEVELOP THE CONTRACT.
WE SENT IT BACK OUT TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN AND ISSUED THE
AWARD.
THESE AWARDS TOTAL OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR MILLION
AND REPRESENT ALMOST 93% OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN
AVAILABLE FUNDING.
WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY MATT OUR
INTERNAL GOAL.
OF AWARDING HE FUNDS WITHIN
FIFTEEN DAYS OF RECEIPT OF A
COMPLETED APPLICATION.
ALSO AS OF JANUARY SIXTEENTH WE
HAVE DISPERSED THE FUNDS TO
EIGHT LARGE CITIES AND TWELVE OF
THE CEO SEES.
THESE DISBURSEMENTS TOTAL ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
MILLION AND REPRESENT OVER 50%
OF THE TOTAL FUNDING AVAILABLE.
FOR A 100% OF THESE GRANTS WE
HAVE MET OUR COMITMENT TO
ACTUALLY DISPERSE THE FUNDS
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF THE DATE
THE APPLICATION IS COMPLETE.
IN RESPONSE TO THE RECENT FIRES
IN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE FURTHER EXPEDITED
THIS PROCESS.
AND WAVED A COUPLE OF THE
CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO GET ACCESS
TO THOSE FUNDS AND BEGIN USING
THEM.
IMMEDIATELY TO ADDRESS THEIR
NEEDS.
SO FAR THE CEO SEES AND CITIES
CONTINUES OF CARE APOLOGIZE FOR
USING THE SHORTHAND.
I HAVE COMMITTED TO ALLOCATING
THE FUNDS RECEIVED IN THE
FOLLOWING GENERAL CATEGORIES
[inaudible]
SERVICES ARE PROPOSED TO
RECEIVER TO BE A TOO YOU THE
FUNDING TO BE USED AS 38% OF
TOTAL FUNDS AWARDED. HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION THAT'S THE
TOP CATEGORY OF PROPOSED USES
FOR COMMITTED USES.
SECOND IS CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
ALMOST IN OR ABOUT 34% OF TOTAL
FUNDS AWARDED ARE GOING IN THAT
CATEGORY.
NEXT IS RENTAL ASSISTANCE SIXTY
MILLION ABOUT 14% OF TOTAL FUNDS
AWARDED.
FOLLOWED BY YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
AND THIS CATEGORY HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED ALMOST 7% OF FUNDS
THERE WAS A 5% SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENT.
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO NOTE THAT
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE CHOSEN
TO ALLOCATE MORE THAN THE
REQUIRED 5% ON TO YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS FOR A TOTAL OF
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION.
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS COMMENTED
ABOUT 4% OF TOTAL FUNDS AWARDED
AND THAT'S BELOW THE THRESHOLD
OF 5% SO AGAIN WE'RE PLEASED TO
SEE SOME --
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE BEING
ABSORBED BY THE CONTINUES OF
KAREN CITIES SO THAT MORE FUNDS
CAN GO TO DIRECT SERVICES.
AND FINALLY ABOUT THIRTEEN
MILLION OR ABOUT 3% OF THE FUNDS
ARE IN THE OTHER CATEGORY.
WHICH IS THINGS LIKE RESTAURANT
RESTROOMS AND HAND WASHING
STATIONS AND ANY OTHER KIND OF
SUPPORT AND SERVICE.
IT'S NEEDED IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU ALL.
LECTURE PRESENTATION LET'S MOVE
NOW TO MISTER AUSTIN.
THANKS I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE RESOURCES
WE HAVE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT --
ESPECIALLY THE ONES FOCUSING ON
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DEPLOYING THE FIRST
ALL START WITH IS NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROGRAM.
AS YOU KNOW IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS
APPROVED PROPOSITION TWO WHICH
AUTHORIZED THE USE OF MENTAL
SERVICES ACT FUNDING TO FUND THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM.
NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROVIDES
LOANS TO COUNTIES TO ACQUIRE
BUILD OR REHABILITATE PERMIT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
WITH A FOCUS ON PERSONS
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND EXPERIENCING
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
IN ORDER TO BE READY FOR
PROPERTIES PASSAGE EACH CD
RELEASED NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY IN AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OF A HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION.
IN NON COMPETITIVE FUNDS FOR
COUNTY APPLICATION DEADLINE IS
AUGUST FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN THOSE FUNDS CAN
THEN BE USED TO LEVERAGE ANY
COMPETITIVE FUNDS IN OUR FUTURE
COMPETITIVE ROUNDS IF THEY'RE
SUBMITTED BY FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN OCTOBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOLLOWING THAT
NON COMPETITIVE NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY WE RELEASED
OUR FIRST COMPETITIVE NOTE
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY.
I MIGHT SAY NO FOR FROM HERE ON
OUT IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME --
IN THAT FOR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
IN COMPETITIVE FUNDS. TO
COUNTIES MUST SUBMIT THAT
APPLICATION FOR COMPETITIVE
FUNDS BY JANUARY THIRTIETH.
AND WE ANTICIPATE AWARDING THOSE
FUNDS IN JUNE OF TWENTY NINETEEN
NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM ALSO
ALLOWS FOR COUNTIES WITH OR 5%
OF THE STATE'S HOMELESS
POPULATION TO ELECT TO MINISTER
THEIR OWN ALLOCATION FUNDS. TO
THOSE COUNTIES ARE LOS ANGELES
SAN DIEGO SANTA CLARA AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
WINTERS BEAT THOSE COUNTIES WILL
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THEIR FUNDS
NEXT MONTH IN FEBRUARY.
WELL THEN RELEASE A SECOND NO
FOR A FORK OF COMPETITIVE FUNDS
IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACTIONS ALSO
PROVIDED FOR THE DIRECTION HOW
WE AT THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
EXPAND THE SHARE FIRST YEAR
REVENUES FROM SENATE BILL TO
PASS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
DESIGNATED HALF OF THOSE FUNDS
TO BE USED FOR HOMELESSNESS
PURPOSES.
ARE THE FINAL RESULT WAS AN
ALLOCATION OF 20% 5% OF THE
OVERALL SB TWO FUNDS --
GOING TO CONTINUES OF CARE TO
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS AND HOUSING PROGRAM
WHICH I'LL CALL CASH FROM HERE
ON OUT.
IN ANOTHER 25% GOING TO THE
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM.
SO THE CASH PROGRAM OZ NEXT
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING
TO CONTINUES OF CARE FOR HOUSING
RELOCATION AND CIVILIZATION
SERVICES OPERATING SUBSIDIES FOR
PERMANENT HOUSING.
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDIES
SHELTER OPERATIONS AND CAPACITY
BUILDING.
IN AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RELEASE THAT FIRST CASH NOVA.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THOSE REMAINING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
TO SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM
DOLLARS THAT WE HAD WITH THE SB
FIRST HALF OF THE SB TWO DOLLARS.
FOR A TOTAL I KNOW FOR A FIFTY
THREE MILLION.
ALL THIS UC'S APPLIED FOR AND
MORE WATER IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
CASH FUNDS.
WITH THOSE AWARDS BEING
ANNOUNCED IN JANUARY ELEVENTH.
OF THIS YEAR THIS COUPLE WEEKS
AGO.
WHICH IS THE REASON THE SECOND
AND FINAL KNOW FOR FOR THAT
PROGRAM IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ONCE ALL THOSE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REVENUES FROM SB TO
HAVE BEEN REMITTED. TO THE STATE.
AND THAT NOTICE OF FUND
AVAILABILITY WILL MAKE AVAILABLE
THE REMAINING FUNDS WHICH WE
THINK WILL BE A LITTLE BIT OVER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE HOUSING FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM RECEIVED THAT
REMAINDER OF THAT FIRST YEAR
ALLOCATION.
AND CREATED TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THREE BE SEVENTY FOR THE CLOSER --
TO HOUSING FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA IS DESIGNATED TO
REDUCE THE OVERALL FINANCIAL
BURDEN AND LOCAL STATE RESOURCES
DUE TO THEIR OVER REALIZATION OF
MERCY DEPARTMENTS.
IN PATIENT CARE NURSING HOME
STAYS AT AND OTHER RESOURCES AS
THE POINT OF HEALTH CARE
PROVISION FOR PEOPLE WHO.
ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS OR
HOMELESS AND RELEASED THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES FOR THIS PROGRAM IN
DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
ONCE ALL THOSE REVENUES ARE
REMITTED ANTICIPATE RELEASING
THE NOTICE OF FUND AVAILABILITY
THIS MARCH.
WE ALSO CURRENTLY IN OCTOBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I SHOULD SAY
RELEASED A NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY FOR OUR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING SAYS THE
PROGRAM THAT WE FIND IT MANY
TIMES OVER THE PAST AND RELEASED
A SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF FUND AVAILABILITY.
IN OCTOBER OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR
AND THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
FINANCING FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THE APPLICATION
DEADLINE FOR THIS PROGRAM IS
FEBRUARY EIGHTH. TWENTY NINETEEN
AND WE ANTICIPATE ANNOUNCING HIS
AWARDS THE SPRING.
AND THAT THOSE THOSE FUNDS WERE
CAN'T CAME FROM THIS INCOME
RINSES FOR MORRELL R. PREVIOUS
HOUSING BONDS PROPOSITION FORTY
SIX PROBLEMS.
SO THAT'S A LOT OF FUNDING --
ONE OF THE MOST RECENT AND NEW
THINGS I LOVE TO TALK ABOUT IS --
WE JUST ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK THE
ABILITY PROVIDE OFFER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OUT TO CONDITIONS OF
KERR'S AND COUNTIES TO HELP THEM
DEAL WITH NOT ONLY ARE FUNDING.
BUT THE FUNDING THE FOR ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY --
SO LAST THURSDAY WE ANNOUNCE
THIS AVAILABILITY THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO OFFER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OUT TO CONTINUES OF
CARING COUNTIES. TO ENHANCE
DEVELOP OR BUILD LOCAL CAPACITY --
TO MANAGE MANAGE HOMELESSNESS
AND REDUCE ALMOST AS SO THAT
WHAT WE'VE THE POINT IS AN ON
DEMAND RESPONSE MODEL.
A CONSULTANT WILL BE DEPLOYED TO
VERY SKINNY STATEWIDE FOR PRETTY
BROAD ASSISTANCE IN THE AREAS A
BUILDING LOCAL CAPACITY FOCUSING
ON HOUSING STABILITY OR DRESSING
HOUSING FIRST POLICIES.
AND WE'VE HAVE THREE OPERA
PROVIDERS UNDER CONTRACT THE
TACKLE SYSTEMS COLLABORATIVE.
THEY'LL HELP JURISDICTIONS BILL
CAPACITY TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
ASSIST PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING HAS A CONTRACT ON
HOUSING STABILITY.
AND THE CENTER FOR COMIC
CONCERNS FOR HOME BASE WILL HELP
JURISDICTION ADVANCE HOUSING
FIRST PRINCIPLES.
WE EXPECT --
THESE RESOURCES WILL ALLOW US TO
THE POINT PROVIDE OVER. THIRTEEN
THOUSAND HOURS OF ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES.
AND IF YOU COME IN MANY FORMS
DEPENDING UPON THEIR NEED WILL
TRY TO BE AS FLEXIBLE AS
POSSIBLE.
WE EXPECT TO OFFER BOTH IN DEPTH
REMOTE OR ONSITE ASSISTANCE AS
WELL AS HOW TO GUIDES THROUGH
ONLINE RESOURCES TOOL KITS
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS --
WE'RE ABLE TO OFFER THIS TACKLE
SYSTEMS BY COMBINING THE SMALL
AMOUNTS OF TACKLE SYSTEMS
RESOURCES FROM THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROGRAM IN THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC WERE TO SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM THAT REMAINS WE COMBINE
THOSE IN ORDER.
TO DEPLOY A LITTLE BIT.
MORE CONFERENCE ASSISTANCE.
IS THAT THE ON DEMAND MODEL THAT
WERE OFFERING ALASKA STRETCH
THOSE RESOURCES MORE BROADLY --
US PROBABLY AS POSSIBLE AS WELL --
COUNTIES AN SEE UC'S ARE
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS WE HAVE A
UNTIL THE REQUEST ASSISTANCE
VERY SIMPLY AUTHOR ARE A WEB
PORTAL ON OUR WEBSITE.
ABA COMPLETING REQUEST FORMS
UNDER WHATEVER TYPE OF ACTIVITY
THEY WANT TO ASK FOR WILL THEN
ENGAGE WITH THEM AND AND BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY ASSISTANCE THERE WHAT.
IN IN A THEM ALSO I THINK
IMPORTANT MENTION OF TALK A LOT
ABOUT KIND OF THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES WE HAVE GOING ON BUT
IN ADDITION ALL THAT.
WE'RE STILL OPENING FIGHTING
GUIDANCE TO LOOK GOVERNMENT'S
BASED ON THE NUMEROUS LAWS WE
PASSED OVER LAST YEAR.
LAST COUPLE YEARS ONE IN
PARTICULAR AB --
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO STREAMLINED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
INCLUDE SUPPORT HOUSING IT'S AN
ONSITE SUPPORT SERVICES.
OUGHT TO DATE OBVIOUS THE
LARGEST OFFICIALLY IT'S BEEN
DIRECTLY WITH LOCALITIES HELPING
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
BUT WE DO HOPE TO HAVE --
FOR THE WRITTEN GUIDANCE ON HOW
TO OFFER THE HOW TO HOW THAT HOW
THAT AFFECTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THEIR AND THEIR JOB MOVING
FORWARD VERY SOON.
WITHOUT A STOP THEIR HAPPEN
ANSWER QUESTIONS THANKS THANKS
VERY MUCH AND OUR FINAL SPEAK ON
THIS PANEL MISS SUDDEN.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THE GREAT WORK THAT CDSS
IS DOING AROUND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TODAY AND WE ARE
VERY EXCITED THAT THIS JOINT
HEARING IS HAPPENING TODAY.
BEFORE I DIVE INTO OUR SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS I WANT TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON CSS
AND WHY WE BELIEVE IT'S
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT TO BE.
A PART OF OUR STATES EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS --
AS YOU KNOW CSS IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE OVERSIGHT AND
ADMINISTRATION OF PROGRAMS
SERVING CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
OUR MISSION IS TO SERVE AID AND
PROTECT NEEDY AND VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND ADULTS IN WAYS THAT
STRENGTHEN AND PRESERVE FAMILIES
ENCOURAGE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND FOSTER
INDEPENDENCE.
SO WHY CA SS INVOLVED IN HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS POLICY WE
BELIEVE THAT HUMAN SERVICES AND
HOUSING PROVIDER SHARE.
SOME OF THE SAME GOALS AND THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT WE THAT WE MOUNT
MUST WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
EACH OTHER. TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT CDSS SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS CURRENTLY HELP MANY
FOLKS AVOID HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO ACHIEVE
HOUSING STABILITY IN OUR STATE.
AND WHILE SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES CAN AND YOU MAKE
HOUSING REFERRALS TO THEIR LOCAL
HOMELESS SERVICES SYSTEMS WE'VE
LEARNED THAT ONCE THESE
REFERRALS ARE MADE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS ARE OFTEN LEFT TO
NAVIGATE TO NAVIGATE TO
DESPERATE AND POTENTIALLY
CONFUSING SYSTEMS --
OUR CSS FUNDED PROGRAMS WE ARE
TRYING TO DIRECTLY REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR CLIENTS
WILL ALSO INCENTIVIZING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HOMELESS SERVICES
SYSTEMS LOCALLY.
WE TRULY SEE OUR CSS HOUSING
PROGRAMS AS A PIECE OF THE
BROADER STRATEGY TO END
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
SO HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH THIS.
THE HOUSING AND ALMOST AS BUREAU
AT CDSS OVERSEAS FIVE FUNDED
PROGRAMS --
WITH A COMBINED FINDING TOTALING
AROUND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
THESE PROGRAMS ASSIST
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR HOUSING
INSTABILITY WHO ARE BEING SERVED
BY VARIOUS PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES.
THE CHART IN OUR BUREAU FACT
SHEET WHICH I BELIEVE YOU ALL
HAVE SUMMARIZES THESE PROGRAMS
ALLOCATIONS AND THE COUNTIES
THAT PARTICIPATE IN THEM.
SOMETHING OUR TEAM REALLY PRIDE
OURSELVES IN HIS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT WE
PROVIDE TO PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES WE HOST WEBINARS WE DO
MONTHLY CONFERENCE CALLS FOR ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS.
AND WE HOUSE MULTIPLE LEARNING
FORMS TO BRING OUR CAR COUNTIES
TOGETHER TO PAY YOUR SHARE.
THE THAT OPPORTUNITIES ALLOW FOR
A LIVE TIME LEARNING AND
TARGETED SUPPORT FROM CSS AS
WELL AS TRAINING FROM NATIONAL
STATE AND LOCAL EXPERTS AND
HOMELESSNESS FIELD.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION IT'S INDIA HAS COME TO
SOME OF THESE HURTING FORUMS TO
PROVIDE HER EXPERTISE --
AND WE PRIDE OURSELVES IN
IMPLEMENTING OUR PROGRAMS WITH
AN EYE TOWARDS CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THE WORK
WE ARE DOING MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE PILOTS --
IS QUITE INNOVATIVE BOTH FOR THE
STATE THE NATION AND WE FEEL A
SINCERE RESPONSIBILITY TO ADD
KNOWLEDGE TO THE FIELD ABOUT
WHAT WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T.
SO THAT SORT OF THE BROAD
FRAMING --
OF OUR PROGRAMS --
OUR BRO BUT I WANT TO BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE OUR FIVE PROGRAMS AND
ACTUALLY THINK YOU OFFER THE
REALLY GREAT BACKGROUND PAPER --
THAT DESCRIBE THEM REALLY WELL I
THINK IT'S A ON PAGES EIGHT TO
TEN SO IF YOU.
NEED MORE INFORMATION I THINK
THAT FACT SHEETS AS WELL --
SO THE FIRST PROGRAM WE HAVE IS
OUR CAL WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
ALSO KNOWN AS AJ --
AJ IS OUR BRANCHES ONLY
ENTITLEMENT BENEFIT PROGRAM.
SERVING AROUND FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES LAST YEAR FOR
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DIRECT BENEFITS. TO BE ELIGIBLE
A FAMILY NEEDS TO BE AN
APPLICANT OR RECIPIENT OF CAL
WORKS.
AND HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF AJ THAT
WE ADMINISTER THE FIRST IS
TEMPORARY HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
WHICH PROVIDE THE PAYMENT OF
EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
A TEMPORARY SHELTER. FOR UP TO
SIXTEEN CONDUCT CONSECUTIVE DAYS
THEIR FORM OF HA WHICH HELPS THE
FAMILY SECURE HOUSING BY
PROVIDING SECURITY DEPOSITS OR
HELPING A FAMILY MAINTAIN
HOUSING BY PROVIDING UP TO TWO
MONTHS A RENTAL EVERY REGIS.
BOTH TYPES OF AJ ARE AVAILABLE
ONCE IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS THAT ARE
LAID OUT IN THE FACT YOU ALL
HAVE --
THERE ARE ALSO HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE CHANGES IN
THE IN THE PROGRAM IN RECENT
YEARS THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDED ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM
SO I WANT TO CALL THAT OUT --
AND THOSE THOSE CHANGES ARE
LISTED IN THE FACT SHEET AS WELL.
THAT'S PROGRAM IS OUR CAL WORKS
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM --
AGES P. IS NOW IN ITS FIFTH YEAR --
AND HAS GROWN DRAMATICALLY YEAR
AFTER YEAR IT CURRENTLY IS A
SEVENTY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM WITH FIFTY TWO
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES IT IS A
COMPETITIVE ALLOCATION --
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES AN INCREASE OF THAT
PROGRAM TO NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS PROGRAM YOU MUST BE A
HOMELESS CAL WORKS FAMILY.
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT SINCE
AGES P. IS NOT AN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM LIKE MANY OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
MOST COUNTIES THAT ARE RECEIVING
FUNDING ARE CURRENTLY NOT
SERVING THE FULL ELIGIBLE
POPULATION --
AS YOU HEARD FROM JENNY A LITTLE
BAD AGES P. DOES FOLLOW HOUSING
FIRST MODEL IT HAS BEEN DESIGNED
TO ASSIST FAMILIES WITHOUT
PRECONDITIONS --
AND TO SECURE PERMIT HOUSING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND ALSO USES EVIDENCE BASED
HOMELESS INTERVENTIONS MAINLY
RAPIDLY HOUSING WHICH ISN'T THE
ASCRIBED IS AN INTERVENTION THAT
PROVIDES ANYWHERE FROM A MONTH
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ALONG WITH VERY
INTENSIVE HOUSING CASE
MANAGEMENT --
THERE IS MORE DATA ON THE
PROGRAM IN THE FACT SHE BUT I DO
THINK IT'S WORTH FLAGGING THAT
SINCE AGES P. --
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED FIVE EARS
AGO WE HAVE AND FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE INCREDIBLY PROUD OF THIS
PROGRAM AND HOW COUNTIES
CONTINUE TO RAISE THE BAR AND
INNOVATE AS IT GROWS.
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME IS OUR IS
OUR NEXT PROGRAM THE FH IS A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
WITH TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE FUNDS AND A ONE TO ONE
COUNTY MATCH WITH TWELVE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE
PARTICIPATING.
THIS PROGRAM IS SET TO SUNSET AT
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR. TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR BE FH YOU MUST
BE A CHILD WELFARE INVOLVES
FAMILY EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS.
HOWEVER BE A FATE IS ALSO NOT AN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM SO NOT ALL
THOSE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE
CAN BE SERVED AND GIVEN NOT CDSS
HAS PRIORITIZE.
BASED ON VULNERABILITY EXPECTING
COUNTIES TO SERVE LITERALLY
HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
IN OUT OF HOME CARE FIRST.
WE HAVE AGE ALSO FOLLOW THE
HOUSING FIRST MODEL AND USES
EVIDENCE BASED HOMELESS
INTERVENTIONS --
FAMILIES RECEIVE RAPIDLY HOUSING
SERVICES OR FOR THOSE MORE
VULNERABLE FAMILIES A CONNECTION
TO A FAMILY REUNIFICATION
PROGRAM VOUCHER THROUGH HAD ARE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
THE A SIZE HAS ALSO HAS A PRO
BONO RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE UC BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
POLICY LAB IN THE CHILDREN'S
DATA NETWORK OUT OF USC TO
FORMALLY EVALUATE THIS PROGRAM
WE APPRECIATE THAT IT IS A PILOT --
THIS EVALUATION INCLUDES A
LINKING THIS HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM DATA THAT
JENNY WAS MENTIONING FROM ALL
TWELVE COUNTIES WHICH IS NO
SMALL FEAT AND WE BELIEVE THE
FIRST TIME IN THE STATE THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS TAKEN
CLASS PLACE.
WITH THE RESULT OF THE FORMAL
EVALUATION WON'T BE REALLY
AVAILABLE UNTIL EARLY NEXT YEAR.
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY ATTRIBUTE THE FH
WITH HELPING FAMILIES REUNIFY
FAT FASTER AND WITH GREATER
SUCCESS.
ALSO GREAT PARTNERSHIPS HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED BETWEEN LOCAL
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEMS AND LOCAL
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS SYSTEMS
PARTICULARLY AROUND FINDING
THOSE DEEPER LONGER TERM HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
DIFFICULT WITH A PILOT PROGRAM.
OF THE FAMILY'S HOUSE ABOUT ONE
THIRD HAVE BEEN REPORTED AS
RECEIVING EITHER PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING VOUCHER.
AND COUNTIES ARE DEVELOPING MUCH
STRONGER RELATIONSHIP HE WE WERE
ACTUALLY REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT HAD AWARDED ADDITIONAL
FAMILY UNIFICATION PROGRAM
VOUCHERS THIS YEAR AND SIX OF
OUR TOLL PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
RECEIVED SO IT'S ACTORS.
OUR NEXT PROGRAM IS OUR HOUSING
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
H. DEATH --
FOR SHORT IS A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM AS WELL WITH A FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR AND STATE
FIND COUNTY ONE TO ONE MATCH MAY
BE SENSING A TREND HERE.
IT SUCH THAT WAS SET TO SUNSET
NEXT FISCAL YEAR HOWEVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET DOES
HAS A HAS DOES HAVE THE PROGRAM
FUNDED AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY ON GOING --
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM.
STEP SERVES INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISABLED OR LIKELY DISABLED AND
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
GIVING HIGHEST PRIORITY TO THOSE
THAT ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
AND THOSE RELY MOST HEAVILY ON
STATE AND COUNTY FUNDED SERVICES.
THE PROGRAM CONSISTS OF FOUR
CORE ELEMENTS.
OUT REACH INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT DISABILITY BENEFIT
ADVOCACY AND HOUSING SUPPORTS
FOR ALL CLIENTS THAT ARE BEING
SERVED TO PROGRAM.
IT HAS REQUIRED A LOT OF
COORDINATION AN EFFORT LOCALLY
TO GET ALL PROGRAM COMPONENTS UP
AND RUNNING BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
SI SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED
IN THE PROGRAM.
THE NUMBER OF DISABILITY BENEFIT
APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED AND THE
RATE AT WHICH WE ARE ABLE TO
HELP CLIENTS FIND PERMANENT HIGH
HOUSING ALL OF THOSE NUMBERS ARE
ALSO IN YOUR FACT SHEET.
AND OUR LAST AND FINAL CDS
THAT'S HOUSING PROGRAM IS HOME
SAFE.
HOME SAFE IS A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM AS WELL.
FIND IT AT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ALSO WITH THE COUNTY ONE
TO ONE MATCH AND IT WAS JUST
FUNDED THIS PAST FISCAL YEAR SO
WE ARE JUST THE BEGINNING PHASES
OF IMPLEMENTATION BUT WE ARE --
QUITE PLEASE THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO GET THE R. P. OUT TO COUNTIES
IN TRIBES APPLICATIONS RETURNED
AND FUNDING FULLY ALLOCATED TO
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES AS OF
DECEMBER.
SO WE POSTED INITIAL CONFERENCE
CALL FOR THE BRING THOSE
COUNTIES IN FOR THEIR FIRST
LEARNING FORM IN MARCH.
THE PROGRAM WILL FOCUS ON ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES CLIENTS HIS
WHO ARE EXPERIENCE AND ARE AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS DUE TO
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
NEGLECT.
SOUTH NEGLECT OR FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION WE EXPECT MANY
COUNTIES USES FUNDING TO TARGET
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION WHICH
WILL BE A FIRST FOR CSS FUNDING
IN THIS WAY SAYS SOMETHING WE
ARE EAGER TO TEST OUT --
THE STATUTE I WOULD POINT OUT
DOES REQUIRE US TO EVALUATE THE
PROGRAMS AND WE ARE IN THE
PROGRESS OF FINALIZING
EVALUATION DESIGN AND CONTRACT
HE DETAILS WITH MARGOT WHO SHALL
OUT OF UCSF WHO IS JUST A A
REMARKABLE EXPERT IN ELDER
HOMELESSNESS POPULATIONS AND
RESEARCH.
SO MORE TO COME ON THIS PROGRAM
AS WE IMPLEMENT BUT WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING IT UP
AND RUNNING QUITE QUICKLY.
AND THAT'S ALL.
FOR VERY MUCH LET'S --
OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ONE FOR MISS UP PUT A
FOOT -- YOU
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF DATA.
AND IT LAST YEAR I HAD --
A BILL MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS --
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE --
TO TO COLLECT DATA FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE STATE
AND AND PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
TO LOCALITIES --
IN THE LAST YEAR H. U. D. AS
MADE A LOT OF STRIVE TO MOVING
IN THIS DIRECTION SO --
WE DECIDED THAT.
YOU MENTIONED --
THAT THERE STILL IS A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL COORDINATION BETWEEN
LOCALS AND THE STATE IS SECOND
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES I
JUST WONDERED --
WHETHER THAT CAN HAPPEN IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET.
IT ABSOLUTELY WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES --
WHAT WE WERE TASKED WITH WAS
DOING ALL OF THE?
DEVELOPMENT WORK --
INCLUDING ISSUING A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION TO VENDORS.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO GATHER
THE INFORMATION ON WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE -- BOTH
PROGRAMMATIC LEE AND FISCALLY TO
FIRST GET ACCESS AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO THE LOCAL DATA THAT IS
BEING COLLECTED SO MUCH ALONG
THE LINES OF YOUR BILL LAST YEAR --
AS ALLEY MENTIONED SOME OF THAT
WORK IS BEING DONE ON A PILOT
BASIS -- OUR
GOAL IN PHASE ONE WOULD BE TO
EXPAND THAT SO THAT THAT ALL OF
THE LOCAL CO SEES CONTINUES OF
CARE WHO ARE GATHERING THAT.
DATA -- THAT
IS THAT'S THE DATA WOULD BE WERE
CURRENTLY IT BYPASSES THE STATE
AND GOES STRAIGHT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THEIR PROGRAMS.
ONE OF THE COMPONENTS THAT WE
ARE EXCITED ABOUT WOULD BE THE
OPTION THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
COULD.
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE LEVEL
HMIS ARE HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS SO THAT
THOSE JURISDICTIONS THAT FIND IT
CHALLENGING TO ADMINISTER THEIR
OWN AGE MY US COULD INSTEAD
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE STATE LEVEL --
APPROACH HOWEVER WE WOULD NOT
REQUIRE THAT MANY JURISDICTIONS
HAVE THEIR OWN DATA MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS THAT ARE DOING X.
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS ALREADY.
THE GOAL REALLY IS TO DEVELOP
THE ANALYTIC CAPACITY AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
AND BUT IT IS DEFINITELY FUNDING
RIP BUDGET RELATED FUNDING
RELATED AND I'D LIKE TO JUST NOT
A CONVERSATION WE NEED TO HAVE
TODAY BUT LOVE TO HEAR MORE ON
WHAT THAT FUNNY NEED IS AND
ENGAGE WITH A C. D. ABOUT THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING --
WITH THEM I ASKED TO SEE IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO TO
RESOLVE THIS --
IN THE COMING MONTHS ONE FINAL
QUESTION --
TO MS -- NOT.
THE GENDER.
OF YOUR THE ONE PERSON HERE
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE AND IF I HAD TO ASK
YOU IF THERE IS ONE MAJOR THING
CALIFORNIA.
COULD FOCUS ON TO ADDRESS ARE
HOMELESS CRISIS OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU MENTIONED WHAT
WOULD BE THAT THING.
SORT OF PUT YOU ON THE SPOT BUT
YOU HAVE A PERSPECTIVE THAT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM ALL OF
OURS.
I THINK THE I'M PROBABLY GONNA.
COMBINE A LOT OF THINGS I SIDE
INTO THE IDEA THAT A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES HAVE A LOT OF THE
RIGHT PIECES IN PLACE.
BUT DON'T KIND OF HAVE THE RIGHT
FLOW THROUGH THE SYSTEM IN OTHER
WORDS YOU HAVE A LOT OF SEPARATE
PROGRAMS THAT SOME OPERATING
VERY WELL --
AND SOME NOT PERFORMING AS WELL
BUT THERE ISN'T AS AS ENOUGH
ALIGNMENT IN EACH COMMUNITY --
IN TERMS OF GETTING PEOPLE
IDENTIFIED QUICKLY INTO SHELTER
OR QUICKLY IN TO HOUSING AND
THEN QUICKLY OUT OF SHELTER AND
TO HOUSING SO IT'S THERE'S AN
ALIGNMENT THAT'S MISSING IN A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES --
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE SEPARATE
PROGRAMS IT'S SOMETIMES HAVE ALL
OF THOSE PROGRAMS IN ONE AGENCY --
THE THE PIECES THAT I THINK ARE --
MISSING ARE THAT SORT OF
COORDINATION ALL PROGRAMS KIND
OF A LINE WITH THE SINGLE MINDED
FOCUS A LASER FOCUS ON GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE SYSTEM INTO
HOUSING AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND SO THERE'S A PROGRAMS
RUNNING IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS --
A LOT OF PROGRAM TO SAY THERE
HOUSING FIRST BUT ACTUALLY HAVE
A LOT OF BARRIERS OR HAVE
DIFFICULTY AND A LOT OF SHELTERS
THAT ARE UNDERFUNDED AND AND
PROBABLY NEED MORE SUPPORT.
OUT TO GET PEOPLE IN THE HOUSING
AND TO HAVE THAT BACK IN SUPPORT
SO THAT IT'S SORT OF GOOD SYSTEM
SO ONCE THE IN IN MANY
COMMUNITIES WE SEE WITH ALL
THOSE PIECES THERE WHERE YOU
HAVE A CRISIS RESPONSE ON
HOUSING RESPONSE.
PUT TOGETHER YOU CAN SEE PEOPLE
KIND OF AT EXITING THE SYSTEM
MUCH MORE QUICKLY AND SO PEOPLE
ARE HOUSE AS QUICKLY AS THEY
BECOME IT MAY BECOME HOMELESS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I'M GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO OTHER
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AS WELL
AS I NEED TO STEP OUT FOR A FEW
MINUTES SOME GUY IT GIVE THE
GAVEL TO MY CULTURE.
AND I THINK MADAM CHAIRMAN HAS A
FEW QUESTIONS HERSELF.
THANK YOU.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AND THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE SHOWS THAT WE
NEED MORE COLLABORATION --
HOUSE COLLABORATION --
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS WITH THE
THE COUNCIL OF AND HOW DO YOU
SEE IT AND DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT AT
THE TABLE THAT SHOULD TO BE.
WELL WE HAVE ONE OF OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS HERE WITH US --
ALLEY SUDDEN --
AND WE DO HAVE PRESENTATION I
THINK OF MOST OF THE MAJOR
PROGRAMS.
THERE THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
MISSING.
PARTNERS I THINK AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY EXTENDED AND INVITED IN
INCLUDED THOSE PARTNERS IN THE
INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP --
AND THOSE ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THEN THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT --
PROGRAMS AND AND THAT'S REALLY A
FOCUS ON AND A RECOGNITION OF
THE NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
INCLUDING STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS SERVE AT RISK --
IN TERMS OF HOW COORDINATION IS
GOING.
EAT IT'S A BIG CHALLENGE --
COORDINATION IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS TO BE DONE IN ADDITION TO
ALL OF THE PROGRAMMATIC
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT.
THAT ARE DEPARTMENTS ARE ENGAGE
IN EVERY DAY --
I'VE SEEN IN THE TEN YEAR THAT
I'VE HAD WITH THE COUNCIL VERY
ENGAGED COUNCIL --
VERY ACTIVELY INVOLVED WANTING
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE COUNCIL
WORK ITSELF BUT ALSO MAKE THOSE
CROSS DEPARTMENTS.
DEPARTMENT CONNECTIONS.
ON THE INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP
IS REALLY WHERE THE THE THE WORK
CAN GET DONE IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE COLLABORATING
AND ACTIVELY ENGAGED ACROSS.
THOSE SILOS AND I THINK THE
RECENT FIRE RECOVERY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD WERE A
GOOD EXAMPLE. THREE OF THE
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE STATE
DEPARTMENTS ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED.
THAT'S SOCIAL SERVICES MY AGE CD
AND THEN ALSO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO SORT OF
FACILITATE SOME CONVERSATIONS IN
THOSE MEETINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL ALIGNED. TO HELP GIVE
INPUT ON HOW --
HOMELESSNESS A CRITICALLY
HOMELESSNESS.
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
EITHER HOMELESS OR PRECARIOUSLY
HOUSE PRIOR TO THE FIRE'S.
HOW THOSE THE NEEDS OF THAT
POPULATION COULD BE RECOGNIZED
IN ADDRESSED IN THE OVERALL
RESPONSES TO THE FIRES --
WE HOSTED ONE CONVERSATION WHICH
WE HAD A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
FEMA ALONG WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM VENTURA WHO
GAVE US SOME LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THEIR FIRES.
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FROM THE
BUTTE COUNTY CONTINUUM OF CARE
SAID REALLY FACILITATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
THE ACTION OF COURSE TAKES PLACE
IN THE DEPARTMENTS APART FROM
HEAP.
OF THE COUNCIL IS REALLY IN
MOSTLY AN ADVISORY CAPACITY
EXCEPT WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF HOUSING FIRST AND SO A LOT OF
OUR JOB REALLY IS TO TRY AND
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE LINKAGES
ARE MADE.
ON IT'S AN ONGOING EFFORT AND
ONE THAT WE'RE ALL REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT [inaudible]
HERE.
DR INSTEAD YOU TALKED ABOUT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SAID DR
OWNS THE DOCTOR BUT TAKE
[inaudible]
THANK.
YOU TALKED ABOUT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE --
AND THE THE MONEY THAT IS BEING
SET ASIDE SPECIFICALLY FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT'S ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO APPLY THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
WHAT IS AVAIL OF WHAT IS THERE.
AT DO YOU FIND.
THAT THE VERY PEOPLE THAT NEED
THE TECHNICAL SYSTEMS ARE
REQUESTING IT OR IS IT THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE.
YEAH WE JUST ANNOUNCES ON
THURSDAY SO WE HAVEN'T IN CORY'S
JUST YET BUT WE DID A BIG PUSH
IT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL
UNIVERSAL WHO ARE WILLING TO
OFFER TO WRITE TO THE CONTINUES
OF CARING COUNTY SO.
WE'RE DOING VERY INTENSE
PROACTIVE ENGAGEMENT ESPECIALLY
TO THE UNDER RESOURCE AREAS SO --
I SHOULD ADD YOU KNOW WE WE WE
CONVENE REGULAR DISCUSSIONS
ALTHOUGH THEIR LITTLE ON HOLD
WITH THE SHUT DOWN WITH HUD AND
WITH SOME OTHER TECHNO SYSTEMS
PROVIDERS BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO DUPLICATE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING SOME INTENSE EFFORTS AND
SOME OF OUR BIGGER URBAN AREAS
THAT ARE.
MOST OUR BIGGEST --
HAVES AND HAVE SOME REALLY BIG
NEED SO WE'RE TRYING NOT TO
DUPLICATE WHERE WE CAN AND SO WE
ALSO THE MODEL THAT WE HAVE SET
UP.
IS WE USE THOSE RESOURCES TO
PROCURE CONSULTANTS OURSELVES
AND WE'LL SEND THOSE CONSULTANTS
AND EXPERTS TO THEM SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT STEPS
IT'LL BE ENGAGEMENT WHEN THEY
ASK -- FOR
ASSISTANCE RIGHT WILL SAY OKAY
THIS IS THE BEST PROVIDER FOR
YOU BASED ON THAT NEED MAYBE TO
SYSTEMS FLOW NEEDED.
RIGHT AND SO THE ARM THIS
PROVIDER CAN REALLY HELP YOU
HERE MAYBE IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
REALLY HAVING TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HOUSING FIRST
MEANS ON THE GROUNDS OF THIS
PROVIDER SO --
AND THEN EXTEND THAT ASSISTANCE
AS AS NEEDED --
AND IF WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
REQUESTS.
ON THE SAME TOPIC FOR EXAMPLE WE
MAY DO SOME MORE KIND OF PEER TO
PEER OR GROUP FOR REGIONAL TYPE
OF ASSISTANCE RIGHT CROSSING
OKAY THIS IS A NEED THAT
EVERYONE HAS AND SOLD WILL FROM
TOOLS THERE SO.
IT IS A NEW WAY IN WHICH WE'VE.
PROVIDED TACKLE SO SINCE THE
PAST TYPICALLY WE HAVE HEY
HERE'S THE MONEY YOU GUYS
FIGURED OUT SO.
TRUTHFULLY THERE'S PROBABLY A
LOT OF LOSS OF A LAWSUIT ALONG
THOSE WAYS RIGHT BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEN TURN FULL THAT THIS MODEL
IS ACTUALLY THE SAME MODEL THAT
A LOT OF FEDERAL AGENCIES
PROVIDE TO STATES --
WE HOPE WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL
GET SOME SOME GOOD RESULTS FROM
THIS -- LIKE
I SAID WE'RE DOING CORRECTIVE
PROACTIVE OUT RICHARD ARE YOU
TALK TO EXAMPLE BUTTE COUNTY
EVEN IN ADVANCE OF THIS OUT
REACH LIKE HEY WHATEVER YOU NEED.
TELL US AND WE'LL IT'S THEIR
THEY WILL DO THE SAME I THINK
FOR FOR AS FAR AS ALL THE COUNTY
THAT ARE ALL THE COUNTIES IF
YOUR SEATS THEY'RE INTERESTED SO.
I HOPE YOU WILL REPORT BACK YOU
KNOW AND IF IT. TOO MUCH TIME OR
WHATEVER IT IS --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THESE RESOURCES
UNTIL.
MERE FOR THE COUPLE YEARS OR
UNTIL THEY'RE EXHAUSTED AND SO --
I THINK I BILL REPORT BACK LIKE
HERE'S PEOPLE ASKING.
FOR ASSISTANCE WERE TRYING TO
PROVIDE WILL BUILD COURSE GET
REPORTS RECKON SOLD SO MAYBE NOT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WE CAN
PROVIDE THOSE WONDERFUL.
LET ME BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS YES SOME
REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING TO
ALL THE PANELISTS OF THREE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE INTERRELATED
SO I WILL GO AHEAD AND I THINK
I'M GONNA BE ASKING --
I THINK --
MRS POWELL HOW THE FACT THAT --
IS THEIR DATA THAT SHOWS WHAT
TOTAL AMOUNT OF HOUSING DOLLARS
EACH COUNTY HAS RECIEVED --
JUST ON ALL.
TYPES OF FUNDING SO NOT BECAUSE
I SEE A LOT OF CHARTS THAT SAY.
HOW MANY COUNTIES HAVE RECEIVED
FUNDING BUT A TOTAL AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS?
SO THAT'S ONE QUESTION.
AND THEN SECONDLY --
IS THERE A COMPARISON OF NOT
ONLY WHAT MONEY IS AVAILABLE BUT
WHAT AT THE COUNTIES HAVE
APPLIED FOR SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF WE ONLY SEE ON NINE COUNTIES
RECEIVING FUNDS DOES THAT MEAN A
COUNTY JUST DIDN'T PARTICIPATE.
OR THEY WERE NOT CHOSEN --
SO HOW DO WE KNOW IF THEY JUST
HAVE AN IMPLIED.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE HEAR
THERE'S NO MONEY OR WE'RE NOT
GETTING AT AND MAYBE THEY
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN APPLIED --
AND THEN.
ALSO THERE WAS OF OF OF
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR TO LOOK AT
COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
USING SOME OF THEIR HOUSING
FUNDS THAT COME TO THE STATE TO
THE COUNTY --
AND I KNOW IT THE SAN DIEGO AND
ORANGE COUNTY AND AN LOS ANGELES
WERE PART OF THAT LIST THAT HAD
ACCUMULATED QUITE A LOT OF FUNDS.
AND MAYBE THEY HAVE PLANS FROM
BUT THEY HAD IT BEEN USED SO
THERE WAS --
LEGISLATION TO TRY TO MOVE THAT
BACK INTO --
KIND OF A CENTRAL DOLLARS AND
HAVE A MARIE APPLY --
KIND OF THE USE IT OR LOSE IT
MODEL -- DO
WE HAVE RECORD OF HOW THAT'S
BEING HANDLED SO THAT'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS SOMEONE SAW JUST THROW
THOSE ALL OUT. TO WHOEVER FILLED
I'LL START AND THEN HANDED OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES IF I MAY UM.
THE SHORT ANSWER TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT IS CURRENTLY
GOING OUT TO OR THE COUNTIES
HAVE ACCESS.
TO WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA
COLLECTED.
ACTIVELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TO IDENTIFY TO GET A
REALLY CLEAR PICTURE OF OF THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT'S GOING
TO THE VARIOUS STATE DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON HOMELESSNESS.
AND THEN THOSE THE WHAT'S WHAT
WHAT'S FOCUSED ON HOUSING OR
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES.
IT CAN BE MORE CHALLENGING THAN
IT MIGHT APPEAR TO DEVELOP THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS.
ARE NOT.
REALLY BLACK AND WHITE EITHER
THEY'RE IN ARE THERE OUT THERE
PERHAPS IT'S AN OPTION TO
PROVIDE HOUSING AND HOUSING
SUPPORTS OR PART OF THE
POPULATION THAT THE SERVICE IS
HOMELESS OR AT RISK.
SO WE'RE REALLY WANTING TO BE
SURE THAT WE CAN BE ACCURATE IN
WHATEVER INFORMATION WE GATHER
AND AND THEN PUBLICIZE.
THE FIRST STEP WAS IN IN DOING
THE TWO BROCHURES WHICH ACTUALLY --
H. C. D. INITIATED TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THE PROGRAMS ARE AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND WHAT KINDS OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE FROM
THE FUND --
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MORE ON I MEAN
NOBODY ELSE HE WAS --
FOR OUR PATH BOND PROGRAMS WE DO
HAVE THE PROPER SIX PROP ONE SEE
WE HAVE EXPENDED ANYTHING FROM
PROP ONE OF COURSE YET WE DO
HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF WHAT HAS
GONE TEACH COUNTY FROM THIS
PROGRAMS.
NOW THAT CAPITAL SAY IS MOST OF
OUR PROGRAMS GO DIRECTLY TO
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD HOUSING
WITHINTHOSE KINDS OF DON'T.
FUNDS GOING TO COUNTIES --
IT'S IT'S SO IT'S DEVELOPMENT OR
RESOURCES THAT HAVE OCCURRED AND
SO WE DO HAVE SOME PROGRAMS THAT
DO FLOATED CONTINUES OF CARING
COUNTIES THAT I MENTIONED --
AND I THINK YOU KNOW IF YOU TO
WE SEE EVERY.
TEAM OF CARE OR COUNTY ACCESS
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE HAD
THAT PROBLEM WITH THE LEAST THE
PROGRAMS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE
TODAY -- AND
LACK OF ACCESS --
I THINK IT'S THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE MAYBE MORE LIMITED IN FUNDS
THAT ARE COMPETITIVE THAT --
THAT HAVE THAT HAVE SOME OF
THOSE CHALLENGES RIGHT BECAUSE
THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE BASING POLICY
PRIORITIES AND WHATEVER
WHICHEVER APPLICATIONS YOUR BEST
SUITED FOR ME HAVE THE MOST
LEVERAGE FROM LOCAL RESOURCE
STANDPOINT OF SORTS OF THINGS.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
LEGISLATION YOU TALKED ABOUT SO --
I'D LOVE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT WAS --
BILL THAT WAS ACTUALLY HE
STEPPED OUT OF THE ROOM ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA BROUGHT
LAST JUNE.
AND IT WAS --
THE LAST DAY OF SESSION IN JUNE
AND IT WAS.
TO TAKE.
A LOOK AT THE COUNTIES THAT WERE
NOT USING THEIR HOUSING DOLLARS
THAT THEY'VE HAD FOR THREE OH AT
LEAST THREE YEARS AND MARK BEING
USED AND TO PUT THEM --
IN ESSENCE INTO ONE TYPE OF
MAYBE THE MIDDLE SERVICES ACT
DOLLARS YES OF THE HOUSING
DOLLARS OKAY SO MAYBE MAYBE THIS
FUNDS YES SO WE ARE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WERE PROBABLY THE BEST
SUITED ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
YEAH AND JUST ON ON ARE PROGRAMS
AROUND THAT --
IMPLYING AND AND THOSE PIECES SO --
MOST OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE
COMPETITIVE THEY ARE NOT --
SORT OF IS THAT THE FUNDING
CANNOT BE SPREAD ACROSS THE
STATE FOR THE MOST PART THEY'RE
THEY'RE YOU KNOW I AGES P. AS
ARE ONLY PROGRAM THAT I THINK IN
THEORY IS IS PRETTY MUCH
STATEWIDE AT THIS POINT --
I WOULD MENTION I MEAN WE DO
HAVE MANY MORE APPLICANTS THAN I
MEAN AT FOR FOR H. STAFF --
WE'D WE HAD THE THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES FOR FOR ARE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM WE HAD
ALMOST DOUBLE THE TWELVE THAT
GOT FUNDED BUT WITH TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS.
THAT CAN ONLY GO SO FAR --
I ALSO WOULD MENTION I THINK
JUST [inaudible]
FOR YOU KNOW. TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION THAT THE COUNTY ONE
TO ONE MATCH --
IT CAN BE A BARRIER FOR UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND
SO WE HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME I
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TRYING TO
HELP COUNTIES THINK THROUGH
WHERE THEY COULD GET THOSE MATCH
DOLLARS FROM.
THANK YOU KEPT.
SO JUST TO FOLLOW UP THEN AT
THIS POINT THERE ISN'T TO KIND
OF A ONE DATABASE THAT WOULD
SHOW HOW MANY DOLLARS --
EACH COUNTY IS RECEIVING OR
APPLYING.
FOR NOT CURRENTLY ALTHOUGH IT IS
ON OUR LIST OF THINGS THAT WE
WOULD.
IDEALLY LIKE TO TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO SO HOPEFULLY IN THE
FUTURE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION THANK
YOU BUTTON NOT ANY TIME REALLY
SAFE AND THANK YOU.
UNLESS THERE'S LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRES IT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AUTUMN WILL.
SO FIRST AB ONE ACTUALLY THINK
THE STAFF WHO HELPED PUT THIS
TOGETHER ON ONE OF THE RARE
PEOPLE WHO DOES ENJOY READING IT
AND PROCESSING IT AND ONE OF THE
LINES I REALLY LIKED WAS THAT.
HOMELESS PEOPLE HAVE HIGHER
RATES OF CHRONIC DISEASE AND
ACUTE ILLNESSES.
WHICH IS OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
WERE EXACERBATED BY THEIR LIVING
SITUATIONS.
WORKING IN AN E. R. FOR TEN
YEARS MICHAEL WHERE PEOPLE CYCLE
THROUGH EMERGENCY ROOMS JAILS TO
BEING HOMELESS.
AND IT SPEAKS TO THE STYLING OF
THIS INFORMATION.
I WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE AREAS I
WORK WITH AND THAT'S WITH YOU
ALLEY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND HOME OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND WHAT WE CAN DO --
I WAS IMPRESSED THAT LAST YEAR
WE INCREASED HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
WE WERE ABLE TO FINALLY INCREASE
THE RATES TO MEET THE CURRENT
DEMANDS.
AND THAT WE ARE WORKING ON THE
H. TAPPED TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN.
BETTER.
WORK WITH A PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
SHOWN TO BE SO SUCCESSFUL.
I WANTED TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
AND WE'LL FOLLOW UP IF I CAN
WITH THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM.
AS FRESNO COUNTY WAS NOT ONE OF
THE TWELVE COUNTIES WHICH WAS
INCLUDED AND HOW MANY OF OUR
RURAL COUNTIES TO STRUGGLE.
WHEN IT SEEMS THAT THE PROGRAMS
ARE MORE DESIGNED --
FOR OUR URBAN AREAS --
AND I AM QUITE IMPRESSED WITH
THE HOME SAFE PROGRAM THAT WE
PASSED LAST YEAR AND FINALLY ARE
STARTING TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT IT IS THE SILO BRING UP
INFORMATION.
THERE'S A RAND REPORT THAT COMES
IN THIS STUDY THAT AT SOME POINT
I WISH WE WOULD LOOK AT A LARGER
FISCAL ANALYSIS.
WHICH SAID THAT THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR INVESTING IN
HOMELESS PROGRAMS HELPS US TO
SAVE HEALTHCARE DOLLARS.
THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR YOU SPEND
IT'S A DOLLAR AND TOTAL SPENDING
THAT THEY COULD FOLLOW.
I BET IF YOU DUG A BIT FURTHER
YOU WOULD ACTUALLY REALIZE THAT
HELPING TO DO HOUSING FIRST HELP
US AS A STATE TO HELP SAVE MONEY.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS THROUGH OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND THROUGH
HUMAN SERVICES. TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN BETTER MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I COULDN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEMS IN
MY FOUR WALLS OF OUR E. ARTS
PART THE REASON WHY I'M HERE
TODAY --
THIS TO HELP TO TRY TO BREAK
SOME OF THOSE SILOS AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR OUR HERO
PRESENTATIONS.
I A HIM FOR A FRUSTRATED THE
ABOUT THIS --
HOMELESSNESS --
CONDITION IN CALIFORNIA.
IS -- NOT
IMPROVING SO 20% OF THE NATION'S
SO HOMELESSNESS --
SITUATION IS SO.
LOCATED HERE IN OUR STATE
[inaudible]
AND NO IN FACT IT HAS GROWN THE
JUST SAY AT 109%.
AND YET THOUGH OUR WERE BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR AS A BUDGET THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OF FROM. SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS UP FOR
NEXT YEAR AREAS SO.
ABOUT THE SAME SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
STONE ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WHY
LOOK WAS A HOW MUCH WAS SO
[inaudible]
EXPENDED --
OF THE BUDGET WAS A SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SO SO WHAT THAT
THE US ALL EXPENDED THAT WA.
SOMEBODY'S A KEEPING UNLESS YOU
WERE.
AND THE AMONG THAT AMOUNT.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS A BEING?
SPENT.
BY THE BUREAUCRACY.
UP OR DIFFERENT AGENCIES --
THAT.
WE HAVE.
AND THAT ACTUALLY HOW MUCH MONEY
HAS SO CALLED IN [inaudible]
TO THE HOUSING.
A YES PROVIDING THE HOUSING.
FOR THE ACTUAL ORDER NEEDY
PEOPLE TO HAS ALSO TWO DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS SO.
SUPPORTER BUDGET THE STATE
BUDGET THE WAS A SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
IF WE TAKE --
THAT ISSUE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA SERIOUSLY WHICH HE IS
A SERIOUS.
ALL RIGHT NOW LAW SEND IN A CITY
IS A DISASTER.
IN A PEOPLE WERE IN ATTENDANCE
SO.
ON THE SIDEWALK AS AS NOT ONLY
THEIR INDIVIDUAL OR UP PEOPLE
SLEEPING IN THAT KIND OF
CONDITION IS SO --
BUT THE ALL.
ALL THE PUBLIC.
TO KNOW [inaudible]
A SO THIS IS A SERIOUS SO ISSUE
IN OUR STATE.
IT HAS NOT BEEN LAST A TWO ONE
THREE YEARS OF ISSUE HAS BEEN.
IN THAT CASE OF A ISSUE.
WHY THE STATE --
I WISH WE HAVE A A HOUSING
CHAIRPERSON BEEN COMMITTED TO A
PERSON.
CHAIRPERSON WAS HERE SO WE CAN
HAVE A SOME HONEST --
DISCUSSION HOW WE CAN.
IMPROVE THE SITUATION.
RATHER THAN JUST AND DOING THE
WORK.
AND THE SITUATION CASTS A WORSE
AND EVERY YEAR.
ARE WE TAKING IT SERIOUSLY --
I JUST ON ALL THE AGENCIES TO
BROCK RECEIVED THEY TO THE A JOB
BY [inaudible]
AND I DON'T CARE ABOUT IT.
SO IS SO REALLY FRUSTRATING TO
ME.
S. -- MEMBER
OF DISA.
COMMITTEE HOW WE CAN TACKLE.
AND THEN ALSO --
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA ONE LOCAL
MENTIONED THAT THE IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY.
SHE DIDN'T MENTION THE COUNTY
WHERE JOHNNY --
AGENCY.
KEPT THAT MONEY.
AND I'M NOT SPENDING.
UNTIL THE LAST OF CRISIS --
THAT THE THE PEOPLE RURAL FROM
THE RIVER BED WERE CHECKED ON ME
AND TOOK OUT THE AND THE THERE'S
KNOWN.
MONITORING CHECK AND BALANCE OF
WHAT IS BEING DONE THE MONEY IS
A BEING SPENT THE BUT THE WHERE
THE MONEY IN ARE ACTUALLY GOALS.
YEAH.
THERE'S A KNOLL.
I WISH I WAS THE GOVERNOR.
I CAN HAVE A MY YET TASK FORCE.
AND THE FOCUS ON AND TRIED
IMPROVE THE SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
IS THERE OF ARE JUST TAKING IT
AS SELF JUST A FACT OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY DON'T.
KNOW THEY ARE THEY ARE WILL DO
AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS THE
APPROACH WE SHOULD TAKE.
WE SHOULD REALLY FOCUS UPON HOW
WE SOLVE THAT THE PROBLEM.
IT IS SO SHAME MATTER YOU
MENTIONED THE IT HERE
[inaudible]
SACRAMENTO.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS --
ALMOST DAILY WHEN WE MEET THE IN
THE COMMITTEES SO HOMELESSNESS --
SITUATION AND YOU KNOW HOUSING
SITUATION AFFORDABLE HOMES
ETCETERA ETCETERA JUST ACROSS
THE STREET [inaudible]
RIGHT THERE.
WE CANNOT EVEN SOLVE.
THE CAPITAL CITY OF HOMELESSNESS --
SITUATION.
WHY CAN'T WE JUST TO CREATE A?
TRIED DIFFERENT METHODS TO HOWL.
AT THE STATE LOCAL COUNTY ALL
AGENCIES SO.
THE ARE WORKING TO GET THE WHAT
METHOD --
WORKER AND THEN CREATE THE THE
SYSTEM THAT WOULD WORK FROM OUR
VERY CITY HERE IN THE CAPITAL
CITY.
AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT CHOICE
I THINK THAT THAT IS.
WHY WE'RE HERE YEAH THE AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE THE STATE RESPONSE AND
THE NEXT PANEL WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE LOCAL RESPONSE IT IS
AN ISSUE THAT CLEARLY?
HAS AFFECTED ALL OF US.
AND I THINK THAT HAVING TASK
HAVING SO MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE TRYING TO COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THE FACT THAT THE
HOUSING.
COMMITTEE AND THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE HAS SAID THIS IS
BIGGER THAN JUST HOUSING WE HAVE
TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO HELP SOLVE
THIS.
WE WANT TO BRING IN THE EXPERTS
BECAUSE WE HAVE EXPERT TO HAVE
BEEN ON THE GROUND THE OF THE DO
WORKING ON THIS AND HAVE HAD
GREAT SUCCESSES.
WE HAVE MUCH WORK TO BE DONE AND
I THINK YOUR POINT IS VERY WELL
TAKEN THAT WE STILL HAVE SO MUCH
MORE WORK I THINK AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA HAS.
INDICATED THAT WE NEED TO KNOW
HOW THE MONEY IS BEING SPENT
GOES TO YOUR POINT AS WELL.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT.
WHAT OUR EXPERTS ARE SHARING
WITH US SO THAT WE CAN THEN?
DETERMINE WHAT LEGISLATION NEEDS
TO BE INTRODUCED OR WHAT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A SERIOUS ISSUE I JUST.
JUST AS CHAIRMAN --
AND DAVID CHIU SAID IT'S A MORAL
CRISIS THE MORE KIND OF CRISIS
OF THE DAY.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TO
TAKE THE WE ARE NOT TAKING IT AS
A CRISIS WE NORTH OF FACTORS SO
IT IS SO SITUATION WE CAN CALL
IT THAT SO CRISIS ABOUT THE LACK
OF A BUDGET REFLECTION IN THE
POLICY AND ON ACTIONS ARE WE
TAKING YOU TACKLE IT.
THAT'S A CRISIS I THINK THAT'S A
FAIR COMMENT AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HEAR
FROM OUR FROM OUR EXPERTS BUT I
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATION THAT
IS INTRODUCED.
YOU KNOW FROM OUR VARIOUS EVEN
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL --
AT THE CITY LEVEL --
SO IMPORTANT SO IMPORTANT AND IT
CAN'T BE SOMETHING THAT WE
SIMPLY THROW MONEY AT IT'S GOT
TO BE SOMETHING THAT HAS RESULTS.
AND MANY OF YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE RESULTS BUT WHAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT THE MONEY JUST FLOWING AND
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT.
IT THAT WE COORDINATE SO THAT
WE'RE NOT ALL.
EVERYBODY RECEIVES MONEY GOES TO
THE SAME GROUP IT HAS TO BE
TAKEN IF WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THE ENTIRE
SITUATION --
BUT WHICH AGENCY WILL HAVE US TO
TO DATE ON THAT OUT OF A SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SELF
LAST YEAR --
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT
THE FOR ADMINISTRATION?
AGENCIES SO WORKING IN ALL.
PEOPLE LIKE YOU.
WELL AND THAT'S ACTUALLY HOW
MUCH MONEY HAS GONE INTO THE
HOUSING ITSELF AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE SEE.
OUR BONUS --
A SITUATION TO ACTUALLY HOUSING
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT THE CYNTHIA.
THAT THOUGH FROM MOSHE'S DURING.
TO HOSTING.
I'M INTERPRETING AS LIKE A GROUP
OF SHELTERING I WISH WE CAN HAVE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING ON
THE STREET?
YOU KNOW THOUSANDS.
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE IN THE IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LOW A SWEEPING
INDUSTRY SAID NASH EVEN CHECK.
TO AND THOSE ARE THE STATISTICS
WERE HEARD FOR ABOUT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE AND EVEN THOSE
NUMBERS ARE INACCURATE WE KNOW
THERE ARE MANY MORE THAT ARE.
ON SHELTERED AND SHELTERED
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE AND I THINK YOU'VE
BEEN LOOKING AHEAD AT OUR AGENDA
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT.
IS THAT GAP WE HAVEN'T RESOLVED
THIS WE HAVEN'T SOLVED THE ISSUE
SO I IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE PANEL THAT HAS PRESENTED.
AND I'D LIKE TO CALL UP THE NEXT
PANEL. FOR THE LOCAL RESPONSE
[inaudible]
ONE THANK
YOUR ALL RIGHT I'M A MOM A TO A
LOT [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL VERY GOOD WE'D LIKE TO
WELCOME MICHELLE.
SMITH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
KINGS TULARE HOMELESS ALLIANCE
CONTINUE OF CARE.
AND CHRISTINA MILLER DEPUTY
MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES
THANK YOU BOTH AND ELS CHAIR. TO
REQUESTED OF THE PRIOR PANEL
WILL LAST THAT WE GO IN THE
ORDER THAT THEY ARE THAT YOU ARE
LISTED.
MICHELLE SMITH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON GOMEZ
REYES AND IT WOULD SAY THAT
CHAIR PERSON TOO BUT IT'S NOT.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF RURAL AND SMALLER CAN
COMMUNITY HOMELESSNESS AND
CALIFORNIA --
MICHELLE SMITH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE AND WE
SERVE AS THE LOCAL CONTINUUM OF
CARE FOR KINGS AND TULARE
COUNTIES.
WE ARE A STANDALONE NONPROFIT
THAT STARTED AS A GRASS ROOTS
ORGANIZATION IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WE ARE
SIMILAR TO A 25% OF CIOS HE'S
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHICH ARE
STANDALONE NONPROFITS.
KINGS THE TELLER COUNTIES COVER
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED SQUARE MILES
INCLUDING TO NATIONAL PARKS
SIXTY SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TWELVE CITIES AND LARGE SWATHS
OF UNINCORPORATED AREAS THAT
INCLUDE SOMETIMES BREAKING FOR
CHICKENS WERE ROOSTERS AS YOU'RE
DRIVING TO WORK.
DIFFERENT KIND OF TRAFFIC JAM.
SURPRISINGLY NEITHER COUNTY FIT
WITHIN THEIR WORLD DEFINITION
FOR MOST PURPOSES.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN POINT IN TIME COUNT
THERE ARE NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
IN THE BY COUNTY REGION.
WHILE THE BY COUNTY REGION HAS A
COMBINED AND SHELTER RATE OF 67%
THERE ARE A FEW CITIES THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER AND
SHELTERED.
RATE 99% OF PEOPLE IN THE CITY
OF TULARE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE ON SHELTERED
ONLY 1% ARE SHELTERED. 78% ON
SHELTERED IN THE CITY OF
PORTERFIELD AND 74% IN THE CITY
OF HANFORD THIS IS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN AND FIVE THE REST OF
THE STATE AVERAGE.
SINCE EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESS IN KINGS IN TO LARRY
SPEND AN AVERAGE OF FOUR AND A
HALF YEARS HOMELESS.
WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT THE
HIGHEST NEED HOUSEHOLDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COORDINATED
ENTRY.
NOW PEOPLE WITH THE HIGHEST
NEEDS ARE BEING TRIAGE FOR
HOUSING OR OTHER RESOURCES.
PEOPLE WE ENCOUNTER OFTEN
DISCONNECTED FROM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS WITH SOME TOO SICK FOR
MANY.
OF OUR HOUSING PROJECTS.
LAST FALL THREE PEOPLE WITH
HOUSING VOUCHERS DIED WHILE
WAITING TO GET INTO HOUSING.
AND ONE WAS BEAT TO DEATH IN
JAIL.
ANOTHER HADN'T RECEIVED MEDICAL
SERVICES FOR THIRTY YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NO
ALTERNATE OFF FOLKS THE HOMELESS
SYSTEM HAS BECOME THE FAIL SAFE
WHEN ALL OTHER SYSTEMS HAVE
FAILED THESE PEOPLE. FOR THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN ASSESSED FOR HOUSING
THE BY COUNTY AVERAGES THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR DAYS TO HOUSE
STE.
THIS SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT IS DUE
TO THE LACK OF HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE IN OUR REGION ON
AVERAGE WE HAVE FOUR POINT FIVE
VOUCHERS AVAILABLE PER MONTH.
WELL WE HAVE MANY CHALLENGES WE
ALSO HAVE EXPERIENCE TREMENDOUS
SUCCESSES SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN WE HAVE INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING BATON OUR REGION BY 85%.
ARE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SYSTEM HAS A 94% SUCCESS RATE IN
RETENTION AND EXITS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
RAPID RE HOUSING ON THE OTHER
HAND IS MORE OF A STRUGGLE WITH
ONLY 31% EXITING TO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
WHILE RAPIDLY HOUSING IS A GREAT
INTERVENTION FOR SOME HOUSEHOLDS
IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE POVERTY
ISSUES FACED BY SO MANY IN OUR
REACH AND WE CAN GET A HOUSEHOLD
CONNECTED TO BENEFITS WHICH
EQUATE TO APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH.
AND THEY STILL CAN'T AFFORD OR
SUSTAIN HOUSING WITH THE
ASSISTANCE ENDS.
AS WITH MOST COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST GAP WE
EXPERIENCE IS AFFORDABLE
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE TO SECURE ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
INCLUDING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
MANY OF THE REGULATIONS FAVOR
URBAN PROJECTS NGUYEN SMALLER
COMMUNITY SIMPLY CANNOT COMPETE.
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
PROJECTS AND HANFORD A COMMUNITY
WITH A POPULATION OF ROUGHLY
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND WOULD
COMPETE AGAINST PROJECTS IN LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
IN THE INTEGRATED CONNECTIVE
ITTY PROJECT TERRY AT THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME REGULATIONS THEN
CAN ONLY ASSIST 49% OF THE UNITS.
SMALLER COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
SECTION EIGHT WERE SUBSTANTIAL
LOCAL MONEY CANNOT MAKE 4%
PROJECTS WORK WHICH FORCES THEM
INTO THE 9% PROGRAM AND MAKES
THEM INHERENTLY LESS COMPETITIVE
FOR NO PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDING.
REMOVING THE LIMITATION ON
WEARING MULTIPLE SOURCES OF H.
CD FUNDS ON THE SAME UNIT WOULD
IMPROVE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
ADDITIONAL 4% TAX CREDITS IN THE
VALLEY.
KINGS UNTIL LARRY COUNTIES ARE
NON ENTITLEMENT AREAS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF FEDERAL EMERGENCY
GRANT.
FUNDING EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
GRANT FUNDING THOSE FUNDS GO
FROM THE FROM HYDE TO THE STATE
WHERE A LOCAL NO FOR COMPETITION
TAKES PLACE.
CEO SEES HAVE TO COMPETE FOR THE
MONEY ALLOCATED TO THEIR REGION
AND THE STATE PUTS A LIMIT OF
TWO PROJECTS PER CO SEE THAT CAN
BE SUBMITTED.
THE LACK OF LOCAL CONTROL OF
THESE FUNDS CREATE UNSTABLE
PROJECTS THAT OFTEN CLOSE WITHIN
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS HAVE
BEEN OPENED.
OUR REGION IS GREATLY IMPACTED
BY THIS PROCESS WHICH CAN BE
CORRECTED BY A SIMPLE REDESIGN
OF THE PROCESS AND MIGHT I ADD
NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE
STATE.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE WE EXPERIENCE
IS THE COST IN EXCESS ABILITY OF
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
IN SMALLER COMMUNITIES IT IS
OFTEN A LARGE BARRIER FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
KINGS COUNTY IT CAN TAKE AN
ENTIRE DAY TO GET TO THE COUNTY
SEAT USING PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
AND CAN COST NEARLY TEN DOLLARS
TO TRAVEL BETWEEN CITIES TO
ACCESS CERTAIN SERVICES.
WE ALSO HAVE A LACK OF
MEANINGFUL MEANINGFUL SUPPORTS
FOR PEOPLE ADDICTED TO METH
AMPHETAMINES I KNOW THAT'S OT A
SEXY WERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BUZZ
IS OPIOIDS RIGHT NOW.
BUT IN OUR REGION --
WE PRODUCE OVER 90% OF THE
COUNTRY'S METHAMPHETAMINE GET
THERE A FEW SUPPORTS FOR THE
PEOPLE AFFLICTED WITH THE
IMPACTS OF THE STRONG.
THE HEAT FUNDING HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS FOR OUR
REGION SO THANK YOU.
HAVING THE FUNDING GO THROUGH
THE C. O. C. PROCESS WHO HAS
BEEN A GAME CHANGER FOR OUR
REGION.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN MY
ELEVEN THE CEO SEE THAT OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE LOOKING
TO SUPPORT THE CREATION OF LOW
BARRIER EMERGENCY HOUSING.
AND BRIDGE PROJECTS THEY'RE
BEGINNING TO EMBRACE HOUSING
FIRST PRINCIPLES.
I JUST LIKE TO PAUSE THERE
BECAUSE I FIND THAT TO BE
AMERICAL.
THESE REGIONS ARE COMING TO THE
TABLEWITH THEIR OWN FUNDS WHICH
WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
THIS INNOVATIVE FUNDING.
LAST NIGHT HE FUNDING KEPT
EIGHTY FIVE ADULTS AND FOR
CHILDREN SAFE.
IN A LOW BARRIER FORMING CENTER
IN VICE CELAYA.
THESE FOLKS WOULD HAVE HAD NO
WHERE ELSE TO GO.
THE WARMING CENTER IS AN INTERIM
SOLUTION WHILE PLANNING IS UNDER
WAY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
LOW BARRIER EMERGENCY SHELTER.
THIS PROJECT CREATED THE FORUM
FOR THE LOCAL HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY DOES TO DISPATCH PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS WORKERS AND YOUTH SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO CONNECT WITH PEOPLE
THAT DON'T KNOW HOW OFTEN HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS SERVICES.
THE FLEXIBILITY IF HE AND THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
HOUSING PROGRAM CASH HAVE
PROVIDED OUR REGION WITH
RESOURCES THAT ENABLE US TO
LEVERAGE NEW.
AND EXISTING PROGRAMS WHO ARE SO
FOR SOCIAL SERVICES PROVIDERS
EXAMPLES INCLUDE OUR FIRST EVER
LOCAL COLLABORATIVE NO FOR
PROCESS.
THIS NO FOR INCLUDES HE CASH AND
THE HOMELESS AND MENTALLY ILL
OUTREACH AND TREATMENT PROGRAM
WITH THEIR LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
THIS COLLABORATION IS SET THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE ISSUANCE OF
FUTURE COMBINED OFFICE WHICH WE
HAVE A LOVINGLY NAMED PHIL.
YOU CAN ASK ME ABOUT THAT LATER.
WE RECENTLY PARTNERED WITH THE
HOUSING IS IN HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY TO LEVERAGE TO PROGRAMS
THE MAINSTREAM VOUCHER PROGRAM
FUNDED THROUGH HIDE AND THE
HOMELESS DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM H. DOT.
THIS PARTNERSHIP COMBINES FORTY
FIVE PERMANENT HOUSING VOUCHERS
FOR NON ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THE EXPERTISE
OF THE HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TEAM TO CONNECT THESE CLIENTS TO
MAINSTREAM BENEFITS INCLUDING
SOCIAL SECURITY ASSISTANCE.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE MANY
EXAMPLES OF THE STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS AND COMMUNITY WELL
TO LEVERAGE EVERY RESOURCE
AVAILABLE TO OUR REGION.
WE HOPE THAT YOU CONSIDER
CONTINUED FUNDING THROUGH THE C.
O. C. PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THE MOMENTUM OF THESE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA MILLER AND THE DEPUTY
MAYOR OF CITY HOMELESSNESS
INITIATIVES FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
IT WAS LESS THAN ONE MONTH AGO
THAT MAYOR GARCETTI CREATED THE
OFFICE OF HOMELESSNESS
INITIATIVES AN ACTION THAT MEANS
TO FURTHER UNDERSCORE.
HOW IMPORTANT ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IS AND HOW IS THE
TOP PRIORITY OF HIS OFFICE AND
OF THE CITY?
OUR POLICY TEAM IS TASK OF
DRIVING THE CITY'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH INCREASED
FOCUS CREATIVITY.
AND ACCELERATION OF OF AFFECTED
PROGRAMMING.
NOTHING DESERVES MORE URGENCY
AND SOLVING THIS CRISIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF ANGELS.
I AM PROUD TO SHARE WHAT HAD
OCCURRED ON THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
WELL AS OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE HAS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE CRITICAL.
THE CITY HAS COME A VERY LONG
WAY AND IT'S COMMITMENT AND
INVESTMENT TO SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS.
THIS FISCAL YEAR ALONE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY TWO MILLION%
DOLLARS WAS DEDICATED FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
COMPARED TO EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE ARE
ALLOCATING RESOURCES NEARLY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TIMES
THE SIZE AS BEFORE.
AND 7070% OF WHICH IS FOR
PERMANENT HOUSING PROJECTS.
THE COUNTY AND CITY TOGETHER
HAVE PASSED HISTORIC BALLOT
MEASURES THAT TOGETHER WILL
BRING UP FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION THAT IS BILLION WITH A
B..
OF RESOURCES TO THE REGION OVER
TEN YEAR.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THESE ARE
EARLY SIGNS THAT ARE SOLUTIONS
WERE WORKING.
THE CITY SOUGHT A 6% DECREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND THAT WAS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN NINE YEARS.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND HAVE CREATED IN
NEEDED PIPELINE FOR DIVERSE
SOLUTIONS.
BUT AS ONE CONSTITUENT POINTED
OUT TO US A PERSON CANNOT LIVE
IN A PIPELINE.
IN MY TEN YEARS OF WORKING ON
HOMELESSNESS FIRST AS A DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER I'VE WATCHED
THE EVOLUTION OF THE CRISIS AND
SUBSEQUENT SOLUTIONS UNFOLD.
AS A CASE MANAGER I REMEMBER
SITTING ACROSS THE TABLE FROM A
MOTHER WITH SEVEN CHILDREN.
I'M IN A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROJECT AND AFTER SEVERAL
DENIALS FROM DISABILITY BENEFITS
THIS IS DESPITE CLEAR AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS BEING
PRESENT --
AND INSUFFICIENT INCOME TO
SUPPORT FAIR MARKET RENT BUT NO
RENTAL SUBSIDY INSIGHT I JUST
HAD TO TELL HER TO WAIT.
MAYBE SHE WOULD GET LUCKY AND
RECEIVE A SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER
IN THE FUTURE.
HER LIFE AND THE LIVES OF HER
CHILDREN HINGED ON LOCK.
THE LOS ANGELES CAN TEAM OF CARE
SO HOMELESSNESS RISE AN ALARMING
RATE.
COUNTY Y. TOTALS HOVERED AROUND.
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND THEN
ROSE TO FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE THOUGHT
HOMELESSNESS RISE FOR KEY
VULNERABLE GROUPS.
WOMEN OLDER ADULTS TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH.
AND YEAR AFTER YEAR BLACK AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN ANGELENOS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AT A
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE.
THAN OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE MAIN
CAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS ATTRIBUTED
TO ECONOMIC DRIVERS AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY OR IN
AFFORDABILITY I SHOULD SAY.
BUT REALIZE THAT THE LONGER
SOMEONE LIVED ON THE STREETS AND
BECAME CHRONICALLY HOMELESS THE
HARDER IT WAS TO RESOLVE THEIR
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THERE WAS VERY VERY VERY FEW
EMERGENCY HOUSING RESOURCES TO
SEND PEOPLE TO AND THERE STILL
ARE TODAY.
BUT A RESPONSE TO THE GROWING
CRISIS WAS EMERGING ALTHOUGH
IT'S STRUGGLE TO KEEP PACE WITH
THE GROWING NUMBERS.
AT THE END OF TWO THOUSAND TEN
AT INITIATIVE LED BY UNITED WAY
LA CALL HOME FOR GOOD.
LATEST STRONG FOUNDATION FOR
COORDINATED EFFORTS TO COME
AROUND CHRONIC AND VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS SPECIFICALLY.
HOME FOR GOOD CREATED THE
FUNDERS COLLABORATIVE WHICH
BECAME A CLEARING HOUSE FOR A
LINE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS.
AND WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SEED
FUNDING FOR LA'S COORDINATED
ENTRY SYSTEM OR SI ES.
WHICH LAUNCHED IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN GARCETTI ADOPTED
THE GOALS OF HOME FOR GOOD AND
ACCEPTED THE MAY ORAL CHALLENGED
AND VETERANS HOMELESSNESS THAT
AT NATIONAL CHALLENGE.
IN LATE TWENTY FIFTEEN WHILE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF SI ESTAS BEING
FORTIFIED AND EXISTING RESOURCES
STITCH TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT
THEY HAD NEVER BEEN COORDINATED
BEFORE.
THE CITY APPROVED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INFUSION OF
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
FOR TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET.
IT ALSO ADOPTED THE
COMPREHENSIVE HOMELESSNESS
STRATEGIES A SET OF SIXTY TWO
STRATEGIES GROUNDED IN THE
PRINCIPLES OF NO WRONG DOOR.
HOUSING FIRST PREVENTION AND
COORDINATED CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES.
THE COUNTY ALSO ADOPTED A SET OF
STRATEGIES IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN THIS CREATED THE BASE
PLAN FOR HOW WE WOULD REGIONALLY
TACKLE THE CRISIS.
I EMPHASIZE REGIONAL.
I'M IN A PLANE IS GREAT AND SO
IS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
EMERGENCY FUNDS BUT WE NEEDED
LOCAL SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
STREAMS FOR BOTH HOUSING AND
SERVICES IF WE WERE TRULY GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN LA.
SO IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE CITY'S HOMELESSNESS
AND POVERTY COMMITTEE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO FINALIZE PROPOSAL
OF PROPOSITION HHH WHICH WAS
PASSED WITH OVER 70% VOTER
APPROVAL.
IN NOVEMBER.
HHH IS A ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR BOND AUTHORITY AIMED AT
CREATING TEN THOUSAND UNITS OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OVER THE
COURSE OF TEN YEARS.
IT WAS NOT MEANT TO FUND THE
ENTIRETY OF THESE UNITS BUT AIM
TO MORE THAN TRIPLE THE PACE AT
WHICH LA CITY WAS CURRENTLY
BUILDING.
SINCE NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE CITY'S PIPELINE OF PROJECTS
THAT INCLUDE PSH HAS GROWN TO
SEVENTY EIGHT DEVELOPMENTS WITH
A TOTAL OF FIVE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FOUR UNITS.
OF WHICH THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED NINETEEN ARE SUPPORTIVE.
WE'VE BROKEN GROUND ON EIGHT
PROJECTS WITH MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS ON THE WAY TO
COMPLETION. TO BUILD THE
PIPELINE AND EXPEDITE THE
PRODUCTION OF PSH IN LOS ANGELES
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THREE NEW
LAND USE INITIATIVES THAT REMOVE
MAJOR REGULATORY BARRIERS FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
LIKE REMOVING MINIMUM PARKING
STANDARDS.
AND REQUIREMENTS AND STRICT
DENSITY ON AND AT THEY ARE
LIMITS ALLOWING MANY PROJECTS TO
BE PERMITTED BY RIGHT.
WE'VE ALSO PUT OUT A BID TO
DOZENS OF CITY OWNED PARCELS FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND
PARTNERED WITH PHILANTHROPY TO
DOUBLE OUR FREE DEVELOPMENT AND
ACQUISITION LOAN FUND. TO HELP
MISSION DRIVEN DEVELOPERS
COMPETE IN THE PRIVATE MARKET
FOR LIMITED LAND.
IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE COUNTY PASSED
MEASURE AGE THE QUARTER CENT
SALES TAX AIMED TO RAISE THREE A
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX REVENUE FOR HOMELESS
SERVICES EXCLUSIVELY.
SO WE HAD A PLAN AND WE HAVE A
RESORT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
FUND THE PLAN.
WILL REMAIN ON THE STREETS.
AND WE CANNOT IN GOOD CONSCIENCE
TELL PEOPLE THEY SIMPLY HAVE TO
WAIT ON THE SIDEWALK FOR OUR
PLANS TO COME INTO FRUITION.
SO NINE MONTHS AGO GARCETTI
ANNOUNCED A BRIDGE HOME IT'S
INITIATIVE TO ERECT FIFTEEN NEW
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY HOUSING
PROJECTS ONE IN EACH COUNCIL
DISTRICT.
THAT WOULD CREATE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED NEW SHELTER BRIDGE
HOUSING BEDS LOCATED NEAR PEOPLE
AND HEAVILY CONCENTRATED
ENCAMPMENTS.
THE CITY HAS DECLARED A SHELTER
CRISIS PURSUANT TO EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY TWO WHICH HAS ALLOWED US
TO PASS EMERGENCY BUILDING AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS.
THAT ALLOW SHELTERS TO BE BUILT
MORE QUICKLY OUR LOCAL ZONING
CODE TO MAKE SHELTERS ON CITY
OWNED OR CITY LEASE LAND BY
RIGHT.
ANYWHERE IN OUR CITY.
WE PASSED LOCAL ORDINANCES TO
STREAMLINED APPROVALS OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROJECTS AND MOTEL CONVERSIONS.
AND HOPE TO UTILIZE LEGISLATION
PASSED BY SHERMAN ISSUE I AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH WILL
WHICH CREATED A STATEWIDE
STREAMLINING FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS WELL.
THE BRIDGE HOME PROGRAM HAS
SINCE EVOLVED TO INCLUDE THE
REHAB OF EXISTING BUILDINGS
PAYMENT OF LEASES TO PRIVATE
OWNERS.
AND FUNDING OF SERVICE PROVISION
WHERE THE IDENTIFIED CAP WHERE
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED COUNTY GAPS.
STATE KEEP DOLLARS HAVE
AUGMENTED THE PROGRAM BUDGET TO
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BRIDGE HARLEM. TWENTY TWO
PROJECTS HAVE EITHER BEEN
APPROVED FOR FUNDING OR HAVE
DOLLARS SET ASIDE TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION ACROSS THE CITY
WHICH EQUATES TO ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND BEDS OF INTERIM HOUSING.
WE HAVE TO PROJECTS OPEN THUS
FAR TOTALING A HUNDRED NINE BEDS
FOR THOSE LIVING ON THE STREETS.
ABRIDGE HOME IS ANOTHER
TESTAMENT TO OUR STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY AS
WE LEVERAGE MEASURE H. FUNDED
SERVICES ON AN A BRIDGE HOME
SITES.
WE APPLAUD THE STATE FOR
RESPONDING TO THE CALL FOR
ACTION FROM THE BIG CITY MAYORS.
TO BECOME A MEANINGFUL PARTNER
IN OUR FIGHT TO END HOMELESSNESS
AND FOR THE CREATION OF THE HEAT
BLOCK GRANT.
JUST YESTERDAY COUNCIL ALLOCATED
THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OR 44% OF THE EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION CITY KEEP AWARD
WITH AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY NINE
MILLION RESERVE FOR PENDING
PROJECTS.
TAKING THE TOTAL PROGRAMMING IN
THE PIPELINE TO UP TO SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OR 80%
NEARLY 80% OF THE TOTAL BLOCK
GRANT.
THIS IS JUST IN MONTHS WITHIN
MONTHS OF LA RECEIVING THE HEAT
GRANT.
THESE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANT ARE
TALKING TO PEOPLE LIKE JOHN AND
MARIE --
LIVE NEAR OUR FIRST A BRIDGE
HOME PROJECT ON THE STREETS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
THEY HAVE LOST ALL HOPE THAT
THEIR LIVES WOULD CHANGE.
THEY WERE TO MOVE THERE WERE
SOME OF THE FIRST TO MOVE INTO
OUR FIRST A BRIDGE HOME PROJECT
DUBBED APPOINT DAY WHICH MEANS
THE BRIDGE.
AND WHO WERE ASSESSED AS BEING
HIGHLY VULNERABLE AND PRIORITIZE
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING AT A
BUILDING THAT WAS RECENTLY OPENS
NEARBY.
AND THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE TODAY
AND THEIR OWN SAFE WARM THRIVING
HOME.
AND LA WE WILL PERSIST UNTIL
EVERY ANGELINO ON THE STREETS
TODAY HAS A SAFE WARM PLACE TO
CALL HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
OPEN UP TO OUR COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS I HAVE I'LL KICK IT
OFF WITH ONE QUESTION I'VE HAD.
IN MY MIND THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AROUND THE POLITICAL CHALLENGES
SET LOCALITIES HAVE SO WE'VE
HEARD FROM VIRTUALLY EVERY CITY
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE OF HOW
MUCH.
YOU NEED HELP IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND AS YOU'VE HEARD
AND AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SPEND OR SEND SOME
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING BACK DOWN TO
JURISDICTIONS.
THE CHALLENGE WE SEE IS ON THE
FRONT PAGE PAPERS AND I WOULD
SAY THAT'S THIS IS TRUE FOR MY
CITY FOR LOS ANGELES FORAGE
COUNTY.
FOR SO MANY JURISDICTIONS OF THE
YOU HAVE JURISDICTIONS SAY WE
NEED HELP BUT THEN LOCAL
OPPOSITION TO THE SHELTER AROUND
THE CORNER THE NAVIGATION CENTER
THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECT.
COMES UP AND I KNOW THIS IS
PARTICULARLY INTENSE IN LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY.
DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO ADDRESSES
CHALLENGES ARE HOW HAVE YOU
GRAPPLE WITH THIS I KNOW MEREKA
CITY HAS TO VERY STRONG AND
INSISTING.
THAT LA NEED TO DELIVER
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS BUT WE
WOULD LOVE SOME GUIDANCE AND HOW
WE CAN BE HELPFUL PARTNERS TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THESE POLITICAL
CHALLENGES.
YES THANK YOU IT IS CERTAINLY
BEEN A CHALLENGE --
WE HAVE YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED --
BE OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS APPROVED FOR THE HHH
BOND AUTHORITY I'M AND THEN WE
GO OUT TO COMMUNITIES AND LOOK
AT TO CITE THESE PROJECTS AND
RUN INTO.
ENORMOUS --
COMMUNITY OPPOSITION AND AND I
THINK SOME OF THAT IS OBVIOUSLY --
GROUNDED AND JUST MISCONCEPTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THE FACE OF
HOMELESSNESS IS AND WHO PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE --
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF WHAT WE
FOUND TO BE EFFECTIVE A LOT OF
GRASSROOTS DOOR KNOCKING AT
DIALOGUING TALKING WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO ADDRESS
WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE.
AND I CAN'T OVERSEE IT IS IT IS
IT INTERESTING BALANCE OF GOING
OUT TO COMMUNITIES --
TO ASK FOR THEIR FEET FEEDBACK
BUT NOT NECESSARILY --
ASK FOR THEIR PERMISSION AND IT
IS A DELICATE PLACE TO SAY THERE
IS A CRISIS AT THE SOLUTION TO
THE CRISIS IS HOUSING.
IF NOT HERE THEN WHERE --
I THINK WHAT WHAT IS ALSO BEEN
VERY IMPORTANT IS TO POINT OUT
THAT --
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TEND TO STAY IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE NOT
A QUOTE UNQUOTE OUTSIDERS
PARTICULARLY IN LA THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE CONSTANTLY
GENTLY EDUCATING OUR
CONSTITUENTS ON AND THAT THEY
REALLY ARE ARE HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS --
OUR DATA SHOWS THAT THREE OUT OF
pLOS ANGELES HAVE LIVED IN LOS
ANGELES FOR TEN YEARS OR LONGER --
IT SO AT THAT JUST SUPPORTS THE
ARGUMENT THAT HOUSING NEEDS TO
BE BILLS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS --
AND AT AS TO ANY DEGREE THAT THE
STATE CAN AMPLIFY THAT MESSAGE --
IT REALLY IT REALLY HAS BECOME
AN AWARENESS BUILDING CAMPAIGNS
AROUND ON DEMYSTIFYING THE ISSUE
OF HOMELESSNESS HUMANIZING WHO
IS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ALSO TALKING ABOUT.
OUT WHAT THE BENEFITS OF PERMITS
SUPPORT OF HOUSING CAN BRING TO
A NEIGHBORHOOD WE LIKE TO THINK
OF PSH AS AN ASSET TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSET IS NOT A BIRD
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE HOUSE
TO BEAR SMALL GROUPS.
ADD JUST A FACE TO FACE DIALOGUE --
AT THAT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
CAN MAKE THE MOST HAD WAY WITH
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY --
I DO AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
JUST SAID ABOUT IN ROLLING THE
COMMUNITY INTO WHATEVER TYPE OF
PROJECT IS WHETHER IT'S A MARKET
RATE.
WHETHER IT'S AN AFFORDABLE
WHETHER IT'S AN EMERGENCY
SHELTER ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AS
YOU KNOW IS NOW WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA YOU HAVE NEXT DOOR.
AND EVEN WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ENGAGEMENT ON THESE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND PEOPLE TRY TO
EDUCATE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PERMANENT HOUSING AND EMERGENCY
SHELTER.
THERE ARE SOME THAT JUST
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT WANT THE
INFORMATION AND CHARACTERIZE IT
AS IN OR BRING IN ALL THE
HOMELESS --
ADDICTED PEOPLE TO WHEREVER THE
COMMUNITY AS AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
LOCAL WHERE MOST OF THESE
DECISIONS ARE MADE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CITY COUNCIL--
LEVELS WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT
WHEN PEOPLE COME OUT TO
COUNSEL'S OF IT WHETHER IT'S A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OR TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE COUNCILS OF VEER TOWARDS
SAYING NO.
AND WHEN THEY SAY NO THESE
PROJECTS THEN --
GO BACK TO THE TABLE AND OFTEN
CAN TAKE ANOTHER TWO YEARS THREE
YEARS -- TO
TO MOVE FORWARD WE LOOK AT THE
FUNDING COMING IN FROM THE STATE
WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
TRYING TO DO TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES WERE STUCK.
IN MANY WAYS NOT ONLY WITH THE
NIMBIS BUT COUNCIL MEMBERS THAT
ARE REFUSING TO DO THEIR JOB
WHICH IS TO VOTE TO MOVE FORWARD
A PROJECT --
AND I KNOW --
THERE'S A LOT STATED ABOUT.
LOCAL CONTROL AND LOCAL COUNCILS
NEED TO HAVE THEIR AUTHORITY AND
THE STATE.
SHOULD STAY OUT OF IT AND COMING
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT MYSELF FOR
EIGHT YEARS IT'S ALMOST A NO WIN
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS IF THERE'S
SOMETHING.
THAT HAPPENS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT'S POSITIVE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T USUALLY GIVE
PRAISE TO THE STATE IF THEY'VE
PLAYED A ROLE BUT IF THERE'S
SOMETHING NEGATIVE THEN THE
STATE GETS BLAMED.
SO I'M DEFINITELY OF THE THE
MOOD THAT WE DO HAVE TO PLAY A A
MORE DELIBERATE ROLE.
AND IF THE LOCAL ONE GOVERNMENT
IS NOT GOING.
TO DO THEIR JOB.
AND ADDRESS THIS THAN THE STATE
AS THE GOVERNOR SAYING SAID IS
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK AT IT IN A
MORE SERIOUS WAY OF STEPPING END
BECAUSE WE CANNOT.
CONTINUE TO SAY NO WHEN EVERY
EXCUSES RUN OUT MEANING THERE
ARE NOW FUNDS COMING IN BECAUSE
BEFORE IT WAS THERE WERE NO
FUNDS WE CAN'T DO THIS OR WE
LOST REDEVELOPMENT.
AND ALL OF THESE THINGS AND
EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE WELL WE SEE
PEOPLE SITTING ON OUR STREETS SO --
I'M GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD --
A PACKAGE OF BILLS AND I'M
ASSUMING THEY'LL BE QUITE A BIT
OF CRITICISM BUT THE POINT IS WE
HAVE TO BUILD HOUSING WE DON'T
BUILD HOUSING --
WE ARE NOT CAN BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE A QUESTION
IN THERE I THINK THAT WAS A
REALLY BUT THANK YOU.
LOOKING FOR WORKING WITH YOU ON
THOSE BILLS MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE ON
ALSO WANNA THANK CONVENERS OP
POLISH AS WITH BEING A LITTLE
TARDY -- I
MAY BE THE ONLY ONE THAT'S THAT
MAY BE THE ONLY ONE WHO ACTUALLY
SPEND THE NIGHT WITH HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN LOS ANGELES I
HAVE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND COME
VERY ACQUAINTED WITH --
THAT THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS IN
MY DISTRICT WHICH IS ALWAYS THE
FIRST THURSDAY IN THE MONTH OF
MARCH MARCH BEING THE COLDEST
MONTH OF RECORD IN LOS ANGELES.
AND SO I DO THIS AND I DON'T DO
WHAT CAMERAS I DO IT WANT TO BE
ABLE -- TO
UNDERSTAND --
SOME OF THE PLIGHTS THE
INDIVIDUALS GO THROUGH.
NOT EVER IMAGINING --
MESSAGE YOU'LL MISS RAY AS THAT
ONE THAT MY GOD SON --
WOULD BE HOMELESS --
HE'S HOMELESS WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS --
YES I SAID IT AND YOU KNOW --
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GO THROUGH THE
SAME THING THAT OTHER PEOPLE GO
THROUGH AND I WANT TO DISPEL
THAT MYTH --
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN OUR FAMILY WHO
ARE DRUG DEPENDENCE AND AND
HOMELESS --
AND WHAT I HAVE SEEN --
IS GENERATIONS.
FAMILIES MOTHERS FATHERS WHO ARE
ON THE STREETS WHO ARE HOMELESS --
AND YOU KNOW THE OLD ADAGE THAT --
BUILD IT THEY WILL COME NOT IN
MY BACKYARD --
AS MY COLLEAGUE --
HAS INDICATED WE HAVE TO TAKE A
VERY AGGRESSIVE ROLE IN THIS IN
THIS PARTICULAR ERROR ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE FOUND OUT AND I NEED
YOUR ASSISTANCE --
A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WELL
AS MYSELF DON'T KNOW.
WHAT ORGANIZATIONS ARE FUNDED BY
FEDERAL OR STATE OR LOCAL?
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES TO OUR
DISTRICTS.
SO WE'RE SCRAMBLING. TO FIND
WHAT ORGANIZATION --
TO CONTACT THAT SPECIFICALLY
DEAL AND ADDRESS THE PARTICULAR
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACED WITH.
AND SO FOR ME I'LL BE HAVING A
MEETING.
WITH ALL MY ELECT ITS --
AND HAVE EVERYONE WHO I THINK
WITH THIS LAS --
WHERE THERE'S THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
BRINGING EVERYONE TO DO
PRESENTATIONS TO US SO WE KNOW
WHO'S ONE RECEIVING MONEY?
AND MAKE SURE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE DOING WITH TO DO THAT MONEY
AND AS PROVIDING SERVICES TO TRY
TO HELP PEOPLE GET OFF THE
STREETS AND PROVIDE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HOUSING IS
IS A TREMENDOUS ISSUE --
I KNOW THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
OF MARK WAYS --
COUNCILMAN DAWSON WEBER --
IS TRYING TO DO SOME BUILDING IN
IN OUR DISTRICT WE SHARE
TOGETHER --
WE'D MISTER GRANT WINDOW PERIOD
AND WE WILL BE TRYING AGAIN --
BUT WE NEED SOME ASSISTANCE IN
TERMS OF GUIDANCE TO TRY TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN TRY TO
DISPEL SOME OF THESE ISSUES --
BECAUSE EVERYONE SEES IT WHEN I
GET OFF THE FREEWAY WE'LL GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE WE PRETEND
THEY DON'T EXIST BUT THEY EXIST.
AND YOU KNOW --
IN MAYBE SOMEONE IN OUR FAMILY
THAT MAY BE OUT THERE ON THE
STREET SO IT'S ALL OF OUR
PROBLEMS ALL OF OUR ISSUE.
AND SO ONE OF THINGS THAT I
WOULD ASK AND MY QUESTION IS
WHERE DO YOU GUYS DOING TO TRY
TO GET THE WORD OUT AND TRY TO
DISPEL THE TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES --
THAT COMMUNITY HAVE HOUSE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE THE SERVICES IS THE
COMMUNITY WHOSE BECOMING THE
BARRIER.
IS THE BECOMING THE ONE WHO'S
ALLOWING --
ELECTED TO BE INTIMIDATED EVER
TO SPELL AND PULL SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS DOWN SO THAT IT'S
EASIER FOR US IN SACRAMENTO TO
MAKING SURE THAT.
RESOURCES FLOW TO THOSE AREAS
WITHOUT HAVING --
TO FEEL INTIMIDATED BECAUSE
THERE'S LOCAL JURISDICTION WITH
THE CITY COUNCIL OR SUPERVISORS
AS SAYING.
MY PEOPLE DON'T WANT THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU AND I'LL TO SAY WE WE
IN LA CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME
THE PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT --
OF ANY OF OUR ELECTED SO THANK
YOU -- FOR
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THAT.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN OVERSTATE
THE IMPORTANCE OF COORDINATION
COLLABORATION AND MY MANTRA IS I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN OVER
COMMUNICATE WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT THE RESOURCES ARE AND AND
WHAT IS OUT THERE --
THINK WE ARE IN A REALLY
IMPORTANT MOMENT AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT OUR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION CAMPAIGNS AND AT
EVERYONE IN LA A IS --
AT FUNDED BY UNITED WAY LA IT IS
A COMMUNITY AWARENESS AND ISSUED
OF OUT THAT GOES.
TO OUT REACH OUT TO COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE STANDING ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS.
EDUCATE PEOPLE --
CREEK VOLUNTEER PATHWAYS FOR
PEOPLE IF THEY'RE LOOKING FOR A
WAY TO GET INVOLVED AND AND A
MEANINGFUL WAY --
AS WELL AS HOLD INFORMATION
FAIRS AT ONE PROJECT IS GOING TO
BE STOOD UP AB TO PROVIDE AGAIN
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION TO
NEIGHBORS --
TO STAKEHOLDERS TO AT PARTNERING
ELECTED OFFICIAL OFFICES ADAM
AND I THINK THAT IS PROBABLY THE
LA IS SERVE CLEARING HOUSE NOW
FOR ON BUILDING COALITIONS TO
SUPPORT PROJECTS TO GET OFF THE
GROUND -- I
WILL SAY I AM I AM THOROUGHLY
IMPRESSED WITH AS THE LA THAT.
COUNCIL RIGHT NOW OUT FOURTEEN
OUT OF FIFTEEN COUNCIL MEMBERS
HAVE A PROPOSED A BRIDGE HOME
PROJECT IN THEIR DISTRICT --
WHICH DOES TAKE A LOT OF
POLITICAL COURAGE RIGHT TO GO
OUT THERE TO YOUR CONSTITUENCY
AND SAY WE NEED TO BILL THAT'S
WERE LOOKING TO BUILD THIS HERE --
AND AND I'M COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT AND I DEFINITELY THINK LOS
THE COMING OUT TO DO AT
PRESENTATIONS ON WHAT RESOURCES
EXIST OUT THERE IS IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE
SCALED UP SO THREE SIXTY THIS
DID TO WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I JUST
WANTED TO THE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WE ALSO HAVE --
A DIVERSITY OF OPINIONS ON THIS
PANEL ONE SO IF I CAN I WANTED
TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS TO MISS
MATH.
I SPENT SOMETIME WORKING IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND HANFORD
IN MY WIFE'S FAMILY COMES FROM
EXETER IN TO LARRY AND SO.
I KNOW THE AREA WELL --
IN ONE OF THE STRUGGLES THAT I
THINK YOU HIGHLIGHTED THAT.
HAS NOT BEEN BROUGHT UP BEFORE
AS TRANSPORTATION.
AND THE DIFFICULTIES THAT COME
WITH A RURAL COMMUNITY NEEDING
TO ACCESS SERVICES AND MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE AT AND SO.
WANTED TO PUT A PRIMARY IN IF I
COULD ON A BILL THAT I'LL BE
JOIN AUTHORING WITH YOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND A BILL THAT
WILL HELP PEER TO PEER PROVIDERS
IN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO HELP
NAVIGATION. TO HELP DIRECT
TOWARD SERVICES AKIN TO WHAT YOU
WERE REFERENCING IN YOUR
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY.
I ALSO --
JOINT ALTERING IT WITH MIGUEL
SANTIAGO FROM LOS ANGELES OF
HERS A BENEFIT. TO LARGE CITIES
AS WELL.
BUT SOMETIMES IT'S EVEN IN THE
WAY WE CITY MAYORS.
I'M NOT SURE HANFORD SMEAR LIKES
BEING CALLED THE LITTLE CITY
MAYOR.
AND YET WE STILL HAVE BIG CITY
PROBLEMS AND ADDRESSING ARE
HOMELESS CRISIS AS WELL.
LAST SUGGESTION IF I CAN IS YOU
HAVE A NEW STATE SENATOR SOMEONE
WHO I AM QUITE PROUD TO WELCOME
TO OUR RANKS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO PARTNER AND WORK WITH HER AS
SHE IS NOW THE CHAIR OF HUMAN
SERVICES ON THE SENATE SIDE. TO
SEE WHAT TYPE OF COLLABORATION
WE CAN DO TOGETHER --
THOSE OF US IN THE VALLEY HAVE
FIGURED OUT A LONG TIME AGO WE
HAVE TO HELP LIFT EACH OTHER UP
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO FIGURING
HOW WE CAN PARTNER TOGETHER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY THANK CHAIR --
THANK YOU DEPUTY MAYOR MILLER
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ON LOOKING AT YOUR DATA SHEET.
THAT I HAVE HERE.
IT IS SO GOOD NEWS THAT --
THE NUMBER OFF OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE.
INDUSTRY TO FROM --
LITERAL.
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND IT HAS A
DECREASE --
TO FIFTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED A SINUS SO --
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
PEOPLE WERE ARE OFF THE STREET
TO A WHICH WELL WOODS IS A FROM
THE THE GROWTH.
THAT I SEE ON THE CHART TO OVER --
TEN THOUSAND HOMELESS PEOPLE
GREW FROM 200-016-22000 --
SEVENTEEN SO --
A CURVING THAT THE TREND OF FROM
RISING TREND. TO TO A DECREASING
TREND --
THAT IN THE CASE SO YOUR AT FOR
THE IS --
WORKING.
MUCH THE FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED UP PEOPLE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
IS ALMOST OUR LACK OF THE
AVERAGE.
CITY'S POPULATION.
ALSO IN ITSELF FOR YOU CAN BE A
CITY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY UP PLAN WILL
PROJECTIONS HOW YOU WANNA.
TACKLE I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE FOR CONSIDERED --
DISTRICTS SO HALF THE PLAN TO
BUILD.
ONE AND YOU.
SOME SOME DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
GONE THROUGH A LOT OF A STRUGGLE
BECAUSE OF THE LOCATION.
HAS I KNOW THAT THE I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE KOREATOWN NO
SITUATION ON OUR PAPER.
IN ALL JACKED IT UP BUT AFTER
BECAUSE ABOUT WAS SAW --
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THAT THAT
WAS A NOT CONSULTED.
NOT ANNOUNCED.
AT KNOW PROCESS AND THE LEADERS
SECONDARY LOCATION --
WAS A COMPROMISE LOCATION AND
THAT THEY ARE HAPPY.
IS SO IF THAT TAKES SO LARGO F.
FOR THE A TO WORK WITH THE US --
THE RESIDENTS SO OF THE DISK.
DISTRICT.
BUT THE STILL NOT SO ON THE
AUTOBOT O'DONNELL AND TIE IT --
THAT WERE SOLVED A PROBLEM --
IF YOU DATE.
THAT YOU WERE --
BRING IT DOWN.
THE BILL --
MAKE TEN THOUSAND ONE ONE
THOUSAND OR WHATEVER DO YOU HAVE
THE SUCH A PLAN.
THAT WOULD BE MY FIRST QUESTION
I HAVE FOR SOME OF THE QUESTIONS.
YEAH THANK YOU I'M.
CERTAINLY HAVE WE KNOW IT IS A
VERY LARGE NUMBER EVEN A IN A
COUNTY OF TEN MILLION PEOPLE.
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE STREETS AND
CERTAINLY WE AIM TO GET TO A
FUNCTIONAL ZERO WHICH IS THE YOU
KNOW THE INFLOW MATCHES THE
OUTFLOW IN PEOPLE RESOLVE
HOMELESSNESS QUICKLY --
YOU KNOW.
YESTERDAY AND THE MAYOR HAS
SPECIFICALLY MADE A GOAL AROUND
ST HOMELESSNESS SO SPECIFICALLY
PEOPLE WERE LIVING.
LITERALLY ON THE STREETS THAT WE
WOULD AT CUT STREET ALMOST AS IN
THE CITY BY HALF I'M IN AND
STREET HOMELESSNESS OR GET TO
FUNCTIONAL LEVEL FUNCTIONAL ZERO
LEVEL.
AND IN TEN YEARS AND THIS IS
THIS IS NO EASY FEAT --
ONE BECAUSE THREE OUT OF FOUR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND LA
ARE AND SHELTERED THEY'RE LIVING
LITERALLY ON THE SIDEWALKS.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS SICK.
DESPITE OUTSIDE ON THIS IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INDOOR PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO GO
INTO ROUND PERMANENT OR
OTHERWISE I'M SO REALLY THAT
THAT IS THE SOLUTION AND SCALING
UP THAT SOLUTION QUICKLY --
IS IS A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR
RESPONSE AND I'D ALSO SAY THAT
WE HAVE --
WE'VE SPENT DECADES --
LETTING THE CRISIS GET TO THIS
LEVEL I'M AND IT IS JUST IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS THAT WE HAVE
STARTED TO FIND.
THE SOLUTIONS THAT ALMOST THE
RATE THAT THEY NEED TO BE FUNDED
THERE THERE IS STILL A BIT OF A
GAP IN TERMS OF OUR FUNDING AND
THAT IS WHERE HE DOLLARS HAVE
BECOME.
AN INCREDIBLY IMPACTFUL
ESPECIALLY --
IN THERE AND EXPEDITIOUS MANNER
OF GETTING TO THE CITY --
AS WELL AS THEIR FLEXIBILITY AND
BUT WE HAVE JUST STARTED TO DO
THE WORK THAT WE PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING ALL ALONG.
I'M AND THIS IS AGAIN I THINK
SOME DECIDED I THINK OTHERS HAVE
SAID IT WE NEED TO FIND A SYSTEM
THAT CREATES SYSTEM FLOW.
INPUT AND OUTPUT QUICKLY --
IF WE WERE TO FOCUS ON JUST ONE
PIECE OF THE SYSTEM I. E.
SHELTERS OR INTERIM SOLUTIONS WE
WOULDN'T GET THE OUT FLOW THAT
WE NEED A TO PERMANENTLY AND
SOMEONE'S HOMELESSNESS.
AND IF WE'RE NOT CREATING ENOUGH
AT PATHWAYS INTO THE SYSTEM --
I EAT OUTREACH WORKERS GOING
FIGURATIVELY WHERE THEY ARE --
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FIND OUT WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
AND TRIAGE THEM TO THE HOUSING
OF BEST FITS YOUR ROUGHLY SAYING
THAT IT'LL TAKE TEN YEARS TO
KHATAMI TOP HALF IS THE DUST
YOUR GENERAL GOLD.
THAT ISN'T COOL YEAH OKAYWHAT
WHAT WHAT IS --
YOU WERE BIGGEST A NUMBER ONE
TWO ONE THREE ARE THE ISSUES
THAT YOU CANNOT TO SPEED UP.
THE PROCESS OF THE TEN YEARS IS
A LONG TIME IN ALL THOSE STREETS
THAT THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT.
MAN IS SO WHAT THE THE BILL
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE WILL
BE STILL ON THE STREET THAT
THAT'S A LONG TIME FOR TEN YEARS
I HAVE TO PUT UP OF WHEN I PULL
Là.
IT IS NOT FOR THOSE PEOPLE TO
SUFFER.
SOLA -- CAN
YOU NAME WHO.
HOW WHAT IMPEDIMENT SORRY WHAT
THE PROBLEMS ARE WHY YOU CANNOT?
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
ON THE MORE RAPID.
YEAH I MEAN I I DO THINK AT AS
WE TALKED ABOUT CITING AS AN
ISSUE FINDING PLACES TO PUT --
INTERIM PERMANENT HOUSING --
IS IS A CHALLENGE --
SO IT DOES TAKE A LOT OF
COMMUNITY CONVERSATIONS IS AS
YOU REFERENCED KOREATOWN IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE AB THE
COMMUNITY WAS.
NOT HAPPY WITH THE LOCATION OF
THE SITE I'M AND YOU KNOW I'M
DOING MORE.
THOUGHT FULL DEEPER ENGAGEMENT
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IF NOT HERE
THEN WHERE AND I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PLACE WE ARE AT NOW AT
WE HAVE TO GET TO YES.
WE HAVE --
TO SO IF IF YOU'RE IF A
COMMUNITY IS SAYING WE HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THE SITE AND THEN
PARTNER WITH US AND HELP US FIND
AN ALTERNATIVE SITE.
AND BECAUSE WE WE CAN'T CONTINUE
THE COURSE OR THE TRAJECTORY
THAT WERE ON AND SO AT AT I
DON'T THINK IT'S AND WE FOCUS A
LOT ON AND OPPOSITION IN PEOPLE
WHO SAY NO.
AND I WILL SAY UNITED WAY DID A
STUDY --
LAST YEAR AND ASKED THE QUESTION
TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
IT WOULD YOU.
WOULD YOU BE SUPPORTIVE OF A
SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECT BUILT
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD NOT JUST
YOUR TOWN AND NOT JUST YOUR
COMMUNITY BUT IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND THEY FOUND THAT 70% OF THE
PEOPLE ANSWERED THAT QUESTION
THAT THEY WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE --
AND THAT IS THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT ONCE YOU'RE YOU YOU
YOU YOU ARE FIRST OF A PROBLEM
AS AS IT SEEMS TO SOUND A AS A
FOR YOU HAVE A IN A IN A FUNDING.
BUT THE RESIDENTS THE OPPOSITION
IS THAT THE HOLDER.
FIGHTING IS A CHALLENGE I I ALSO
JUST LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE DOING WE'RE
DESIGNING A HOMELESS AND HOUSING
SERVICE SYSTEM IN AN ENVIRONMENT
OF A LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS THE AS THE UMBRELLA
ENVIRONMENT ON EVERYTHING WE ARE
DOING FOR SAYING CITING PSH
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING IS WITH
AN ENVIRONMENT OF AT A VERY
SIGNIFICANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SHORTAGE.
CITY WIDE COUNTY WIDE AND
STATEWIDE --
SO.
I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT ASPECTS HERE WE TO
HELP KEEP KEEPING KEEP PEOPLE
FROM FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS
AT NINETY THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
HOMELESS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
LAST YEAR THAT'S THE HIGHEST
NUMBER EVER AND SO WE'VE TAKEN A
LOOK AT THAT AND FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- SO
CITING STANDING UP PROJECTS
DOING THIS ENVIRONMENT OF A LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING I'M
KEEPING PEOPLE HOUSE TO OUR
HOUSE PRECARIOUSLY OR OR
UNSTABLE HOUSED AND SO
PREVENTING THE INFLOW AND
SPENDING THE INFLOWS ALSO.
A KEY CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON AS WELL.
CHIU STORY AND I HAVE A TOO MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT IT'S AS OUR
ARE A TRY TO ASK WHETHER THIS IS
GOING TO BE A LOCAL DECISION ON
WAS STATE LEVEL --
ONE OF THE PROFESSORS SO WHO
LIVED IN NOT ON CHINA FOR A LONG
TIME AND THAT HE HAD THE SOME.
YOU KNOW OF CONTACTS WITH THE
BUSINESS PEOPLE AND THE LEARNING
OF THE ISSUES A HOMELESSNESS --
SITUATION IN AMERICA AND JUST --
YOU KNOW CRISIS SITUATION.
AND NOT HE WAS CONTACTED AND
THAT IN RETURN IN A AND THE
SINCE THEN WHAT KIND OF TALK HAS
BEEN.
THE IN ALL HAD ONE DEVELOPED
INTO ON THE SHOW BUT THE BASIC
IDEA WAS THAT THE A PRIVATE
COMPANY IT WOULD BE PUBLIC
PRIVATE THOUGH --
A JOINT.
COLLABORATION TO ATTACK THIS POP
UP.
AND IT.
IN A HARD TO BELIEVE I WAS AT
THE 70% OF THE COST OF THE
GOVERNMENT THE SPENDING.
AND THE STEEL THEY CAN.
WIPE OUT THE ENTIRE HOMELESS IN
THIS OF A SITUATION AND PROVIDE
THE OR THE HOUSING THAT.
THEIR HEALTH ISSUES EDUCATION IS
AND JOB TRAINING EVERYTHING.
IS THERE ANY --
REASON --
WHY NOT THE WIFE YOU ARE WILLING
TO COLLABORATE DOUBLE WOULD SEE --
SUCH OF A PRIVATE ENTITIES.
AND THEY LEFT THEM --
SOLVE THE PROBLEM YOU KEEP FOR
YOU AUTHORIZED SAID THEY ARE --
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE ISSUE
WITH A DAISY PRESENTED TO US
THAT THE DAY WATER --
HAVE TO BE HELP PERMITTED UP BY
YOU JOINING WITH THE HOUSING CAN
BE DEVELOPED AND THEN AGAIN WITH
THE COMMUNITY INVOLVED MONTH
ATTACK.
THAT THE SITE.
IN ENTIRE DISTRICT A DISTRICT BY
DISTRICT A IF YOU GO THROUGH THE
PROPER.
OF PROCESS SO CONTACT WITH THE
BUSINESS PERSON.
IN ALL ASSOCIATING THAT UP ARE
OF CHINESE BASSOON MEN CAN SOLVE
THEM AMERICAN PROBLEM NO BUT THE
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEM -- AND
THEN I'LL BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THAT THE EVIDENCE.
THANK YOU YES WE WE WELCOME THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE BUSINESS
SECTOR [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I JUST HAVE
TO HEARING THAT DISCUSSION I
THINK.
IN OUR UNDERSTANDING IN CHINA IT
IS POSSIBLE TO BUILD A LOT
FASTER BUT THERE IS NOT.
THE SAME DEMOCRATIC LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT ALLOW FOR
LOCAL CONTROL WHICH I KNOW IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU.
AND MANY OTHERS IN IN THAT AND I
THINK THAT IS A FACTOR AND THEN
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
HOMES FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO --
WHO ALMOST BY DEFINITION DON'T
HAVE THE INCOME? TO FORT MARKET
RATE OR OTHER TYPES OF OF
HOUSING SO THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS WORK IF YOU HAVE
THOSE AND CONSTRAINTS AND THAT'S
WHY.
IT'S BEEN SO IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE IN RECENT YEARS TO INVEST
IN WORKING WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES --
IN THE DOLLARS THAT WE NEED --
FOR AT LEAST PUBLIC PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS IF THERE ARE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS ARE OUT
THERE --
I'VE NOT.
KNOWN AS APPROACH ME THIS THE
SHELTERS THE NAVIGATION CENTERS
AND THE SUPPORT HOUSING THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE THIS FORWARD BUT
THIS IS AN ONGOING CONVERSATION --
ONE THANK THE PANELISTS FOR YOUR
GREAT FEEDBACK AND A LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED WORKED.
AND I WANNA CALL UP THE FINAL
PANEL.
WE'VE ASKED A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS TO HELP US IDENTIFY
AND HIGHLIGHT GAPS IN THE
RESPONSE OF VERY STRESSED
ACTIONS LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS --
LIKE DIVIDE UP FROM THE CONRAD
HILTON FOUNDATION BILL.
CAN FROM CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING SHARE REPORT.
FROM HOUSING CALIFORNIA CHRIS
MARTIN AND FROM THE CALIFORNIA
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
FRANK MECCA [inaudible]
AND ONCE YOU FIND YOUR NAME
CARDS IF YOU COULD PROCEED IN
THE ORDER IN WHICH WE LISTED YOU
IN OUR HEARING AGENDA.
STARTING WITH MISTER PICK.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO ASK US TO SPEAK
TODAY.
OTHER CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION WITH A
FOCUS ON SOLVING HOMELESSNESS --
AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY IN ALMOST
EVERY MAJOR CATEGORY HAD REPORTS
DATA CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE
NATION IN THE NUMBER AND
VULNERABILITY OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
MY HOPE IS THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
BECOME A LEADER IN TURNING
AROUND THIS MORAL CRISIS. TO DO
SO WE SHOULD FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS SOLVABLE
WITH HOUSING WITHOUT LIMITS ON
LENGTH OF STAY ARE PERMANENT
HOUSING.
AND WAS SERVICES TO CONNECT
PEOPLE TO HOUSING AND KEEP THEM
STABLY HOUSE.
LEADERSHIP CEMEX DETERMINE WHAT
THE STATE NEEDS --
THAT WE HAVE DATA ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T RELY ON THESE DATA WHEN
INVESTING.
WE FAIL TO PRIORITIZE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC PATTERNS OF
HOMELESSNESS YOUTH SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND CHILD WELFARE INVOLVE
FAMILIES PEOPLE ON PAROLE AN
OLDER ADULTS EVEN THOUGH DATA
SHOWS MANY AMONG THESE
POPULATIONS ARE COSTLY.
AS ONE EXAMPLE WE HAVE 35% OF
THE NATION'S CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS POPULATIONS --
BUT WE HAVE ONE ONLY ONE SMALL
PROGRAM CREATED THROUGH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE AB SEVENTY FOUR
THAT SPECIFICALLY TARGETS
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE FAR FEWER RESOURCES FOR
YOUTH.
DEDICATED AND TARGETED RESOURCES
HAVE WORK TO REDUCE VETERANS AND
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND PROGRAM SHOULD
PRIORITIZE THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITH THE GOAL OF
REDUCING THEIR NUMBERS.
WE SHOULD ALSO ASSESS THE
AVAILABILITY OF SUPPORT OF
HOUSING RAPID RE HOUSING --
VOUCHERS AND SHELTER BEDS AND
QUICK HOW QUICKLY THESE
RESOURCES TURNOVER AND WHERE
PEOPLE GO WHEN THEY LEAVE.
WITH THESE DATA WE WOULD HAVE
MUCH ROOM I HAVE BETTER --
ACCURATE PICTURE OF THE GAPS.
CALIFORNIA IS NOW LEADING IN
CAPITAL FUNDING TO CREATE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
BETWEEN PROPOSITIONS ONE INTO
AND WITH THE HOPE OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH CAPITAL FOR
DEVELOPERS --
CAPACITY.
CAPITAL IS NOT HOWEVER THE ONLY
TYPE OF FUNDING NEEDED TO CREATE
MORE SUPPORT HOUSING.
BECAUSE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY ENOUGH RENT FOR DEVELOPER TO
OPERATE A BUILDING WE ALSO NEED
TO PAY FOR OPERATING COSTS FOR
UTILITIES MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS.
DEVELOPERS HAVE TYPICALLY RELIED
ON HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS ARE
SECTION EIGHT FOR THIS PURPOSE
BUT WE WON'T HAVE NEARLY ENOUGH
OF THOSE RESOURCES. TO OPERATE
BUILDING STATE PROGRAMS --
ARE BEING ARE GOING TO BE
CREATING. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC OR FREQUENT
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO NEED
FUNDING FOR SERVICES FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING TENANTS JERMAINE
STATELY HOUSE.
MEDI CAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT PROVIDE FUNDING BUT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE INSUFFICIENT
TO OFFER THE INTENT SERVICES
SUPPORT OF HOUSING TENANTS NEED.
WE ALSO CANNOT HOPE TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS BY BUILDING ALONE
IT TAKES YEARS AND SOME
COMMUNITIES LACK THE DEVELOPER
CAPACITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CAPITAL FUNDING.
SO I WOULD SAY OUR BIGGEST GAP
IS INCOME FUNDING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TO GET OF PEOPLE
HOUSED WITH PRIVATE MARKET
LANDLORDS ALONG WITH PASSING NEW
LAWS PROHIBITING SOURCE OF
INCOME DISCRIMINATION.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY --
THE FRESNO HOUSING AUTHORITY AND
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
ALL USE RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
MOVE THOUSANDS FROM STREETS TO
HOMES.
CREATING MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS ALSO CRITICAL TO SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS AS MOST PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS DON'T
NEED SUPPORT OF HOUSING THEY
SIMPLY NEED AN AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO LIVE TAX OF HOMELESSNESS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MOST
HOMELESS PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIZES.
EVEN FOR HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH
INCOMES THAT 30% OF AN AREAS
MEDIAN INCOME CANNOT AFFORD THAT
HOUSING.
CALIFORNIA COULD REQUIRE ARE
PROJECTS RECEIVING STATE FUNDING
TO INCLUDE A PERCENTAGE OR
NUMBER OF UNITS THAT WOULD
TARGET SPECIFICALLY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR SET
ASIDE THOSE UNITS.
WE COULD --
TIE FUNDING FOR RAPID RE HOUSING
TO THESE AFFORDABLE UNITS TO
HELP THOSE HOUSEHOLDS PAY RENT.
THE STATE COULD ALSO PROVIDE --
OPERATING SUBSIDIES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
FOR THIS PURPOSE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO LEAD IN
CHANGING SYSTEMS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO HOMELESSNESS --
SYSTEMS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
HOMELESSNESS AND BEAR THE
BIGGEST COSTS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CHILD WELFARE AND OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS.
SHOULD ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
SOLUTION FOR WAYS.
THERE ARE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES HAS MADE STRIDES
IN FUNDING SERVICES TO HELP
PEOPLE OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN
HOUSING.
ARE MEDI CAL SYSTEM HAS A LONG
WAY TO GO AND MAKING ACCESS TO
SERVICES SEAMLESS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND IN OF INTEGRATING THOSE
SERVICES WITH THE HOUSING.
OUR PRO PRAGUE PROGRAMS TEND TO
ADD BARRIERS RATHER THAN REMOVE
THEM AND GETTING PEOPLE --
WERE ON PAROLE HOUSE EVEN THOUGH
FOR ALL THESE ARE BOTH MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY EXIT
PRISM AND MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
SET OF EIGHT WHEN THEY'RE
HOMELESS.
THESE FOCUS SHOULD --
THIS PROGRAM SHOULD BE REFORM TO
ADOPT HOUSING FIRST APPROACHES.
CALIFORNIA CAN ALSO LEAD AND
RESPONSE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CALLS FOR SHELTER FUNDING.
A SHELTER ONLY STRATEGY WON'T
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS IN FACT
PEOPLE ARE STILL CONSIDERED
HOMELESS WHEN IN SHELTERS AND
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS NEVER ACCESS
SHELTERS.
IS SHELL TO RESIDENTS CANNOT
ACCESS EXIT TO PERMANENT HOUSING
AS MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL.
THEY WILL CERTAINLY CYCLE BACK
TO THE STREETS AND FOR THIS
REASON WHILE WE DO AGREE THAT
THE STATE SHOULD ALLOW --
FOR AND FUNDING FOR INTERMENT OF
ENGINES LIKE SHELTERS MOTEL
BOUNCERS NAVIGATION CENTERS AND
RESPITE CARE.
THIS FUNDING SHOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED BY SERVICES AND
HOUSING TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
VIABLE FOR PATHWAYS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
FINALLY INTERIM INTERVENTIONS
SHOULD BE LOW BARRIER I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH --
WETNESS NICHE AND JOB MENTIONED
EARLIER --
TO SUM UP THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S
TAKEN STRIDES TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED LEADERSHIP.
ON A NUMBER OF WAYS.
FIRST --
CHANGE THE DIALOGUE FROM WHAT WE
CAN GETS WHAT'S NEEDED TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS AND THIS REQUIRES A
NEEDS ANALYSIS.
INVESTMENT SHOULD FOCUS ON
FILLING GAPS IN GETTING PEOPLE
PERMANENTLY HOUSE LIKE FUNDING
FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE OPERATING
AND SERVICES.
WE SHOULD FIND WAYS TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACCESSIBLE TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE SHOULD CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN STATE SYSTEMS AND OUR
LOCAL HOMELESS SYSTEM AND FOSTER
A FOSTER COLLABORATION LOCALLY.
FINALLY WE SHOULD FOCUS OUR
RESOURCES ON ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
ESCAPE THE STREETS PERMANENTLY.
INPUT PARAMETERS AROUND
TEMPORARY INTERVENTIONS THAT
KEEP PEOPLE HOMELESS AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO BE HERE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT BAKER.
CAN OF CAR HELD FOUNDATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING --
THE INVITATION TO SPEAK HERE
THIS JOINT HEARING.
I AM DIRECTOR DOMESTIC PROGRAMS
AT THE CONRAD ON HELP FOUNDATION
WE'RE GLOBAL FOUNDATION
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES
FOUND IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR BY
CONRAD HILTON WHO STARTED THE
HILTON HOTELS --
AMONG OUR DOMESTIC PROGRAMS ARE
HOMELESSNESS A BIG AREA OF FOCUS
OF OURS BUT ALSO WE HAVE
INITIATIVE ON TRANSITIONS FOSTER
YOUTH YOUTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICES
PREVENTION. ONE OF THE LONGEST
STANDING --
PHILANTHROPIC AND LARGEST
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDERS ON
HOMELESSNESS ALL TOGETHER WITH
INVESTED HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
ACROSS THE US.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM LOS
ANGELES.
I ALSO SERVE ON THE BOARD OF THE
FUNDERS TOGETHER TO END
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY PHILANTHROPIC FUNDERS
WORKING ON HOMELESSNESS.
TOGETHER THE MEMBERS CONTRIBUTE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TOWARDS ENDING
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS OF THE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY MEMBERS
FIFTY SIX ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
SIMPLY PUT WE BELIEVE THAT
PHILANTHROPY HAS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN EFFORTS TO END AND
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN'T DO IT
ALONE OUT.
THERE WAS A COMMENT EARLIER
ABOUT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS ALL SPEAK TO SOME
OF THOSE AND AS SPEAKING FROM
PHILANTHROPY BUT GOVERNMENT IS A
KEY PARTNER FOR US.
ALL ALONG WITH ARE NOT COMMITTEE
NONPROFIT PARTNERS.
WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY TO HELP
OUR NEIGHBORS WHO SEVEN ASKED TO
SHARE SOME PERSPECTIVES ON
LESSONS LEARNED FROM
PHILANTHROPY AND AND OUR
FOUNDATION ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND? TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF ORGANIZED ABOUT
THREE LESSONS WHICH YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THAT I THINK
ARE.
ARE ARE BEAR REPEATING FIRST AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE KNOW --
HAS HAS BEEN REFERENCED SEVERAL
TIMES TODAY THAT THE SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS IS HOUSING.
DATING EXPERIENCE SHOW THAT
HOUSING FIRST APPROACH SUPPORT
OF HOUSING.
OR RAPID RE HOUSING MUST BE THE
SET AT THE CENTER OF ANY
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TENDING
HOMELESSNESS --
EMERGENCY SHELTER NEEDS TO BE
PART AS PART OF A CRISIS
RESPONSE SYSTEM TO MAKE
HOMELESSNESS RARE BRIEF AND NON
RECURRING.
BUT IN ITSELF IT'S NOT A
SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS HAS
BEEN ROUGH AS HAS BEEN
REFERENCED EARLIER.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ARE
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT SUPPORTS TO
HELP ME PEOPLE ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
HOMELESSNESS BUT IN AND OF
THEMSELVES ARE NOT COMPLETE
SOLUTIONS.
EITHER.
ONLY PROVIDING ACCESS TO PERMIT
HOUSING WITH NECESSARY SUPPORTS
CAN TRULY AND HOMELESSNESS.
OUR GRANTEES FIND THAT OVER WELL
OVER 90% OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
PLACED IN A PERMITS PART OF
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE REMAIN HOUSE
A YEAR OR MORE.
LATER SUPPORT SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WORKS.
WE FIND ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
BOTH SINGLE SITE HOUSING MEANING
DEVELOPMENTS AND OFTEN NEW
DEVELOPMENTS.
ARE VERY NICE DEVELOPMENTS OF OF
HOUSING AND ALSO SCATTERED SAID.
SO EXCEPT EXISTING HOUSING IS A
RENTAL SUBSIDIES WE OFTEN GET
ASKED WHICH IS BETTER A SINGLE
SITE TO BE BUILDING NEW HOUSING
SHOULD WE BE USING THE EXISTING
HOUSING MARKET.
THE ANSWER IS YES WE NEED BOTH --
AND WE NEED MORE.
AS PEOPLE COME WITH VARIOUS
NEEDS -- AND
COMMUNITIES COME WITH VARIOUS
OPPORTUNITIES AND BARRIERS WHICH
WE'VE HEARD.
BUT THE SIMPLE FACT IS WE NEED
MORE HOUSING.
AVAILABLE TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HOMELESS STE OIL.
AND THRIVE.
A SECOND LESSON WE LEARNED IS
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS A CROSS
SECTOR PROBLEM.
AND IT THEREFORE REQUIRES CROSS
SECTOR SOLUTIONS.
BECAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS ARE MANY
JOB LOSS EVICTIONS HEALTH CRISES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCARCERATION.
CHILL WHAT WELL FOR INVOLVEMENT.
THE SYSTEMS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
HOMELESS TO AND BEAR THE BRUNT
OF HOMELESSNESS MUST BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
YOU'RE JOINT HEARING TODAY AS
EVIDENCE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THIS.
HOW SYSTEMS OUR HOSPITALS ARE
INCREASINGLY RECOGNIZING THAT
HOUSING IS HEALTHCARE?
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THE KAISER
PERMANENTE FOR EXAMPLE RECENTLY
MADE A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND MANY
OTHER HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
HOSPITAL TO MAKE AN SIMILAR
EFFORTS INVESTING IN HOUSING AS
A SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
LIKEWISE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS INCREASINGLY SEEING
AND RECOGNIZING THAT AND IMPACT
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN BREAKING THE
STREETS TO JAIL CYCLE IS A
STABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME WHEN
PEOPLE RE ENTERING THE COMMITTEE
TO HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE.
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO GO BACK
TO JAIL PRISON. ONE SUCCESSFUL
EFFORT WE'VE BEEN A PART OF IN
THESE FRANCIS LA'S FLEXIBLE
HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL AS A FACT
SHEET IN YOUR MATERIALS.
THE FOUNDATION HELP SEE THIS
POOL WITH FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE POOL HAS BECOME A
CENTERPIECE OF THE COUNTIES
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
LET IT LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE EVERY YEAR.
IT STARTED WITH IT PART OF
HEALTH SERVICES BUT HAS GROWN
INCLUDE MENTAL HEALTH AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE COUNTY.
AS IT WAS REFERENCED EARLIER THE
THE REPORT AND EVALUATION BY THE
RAND CORPORATION.
FOUNDER THAT THE FLEX OF HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL PRODUCED A NET
SAVINGS OF ABOUT 20%. FOR EVERY
ONE DOLLAR INVESTED THE PROGRAM
THE COUNTY STATE ONE DOLLAR
TWENTY CENTS BY REDUCING HEALTH
THE SERVICE COSTS SO NOW NOT
ONLY SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
EFFECTIVE HELPING PEOPLE
STABILIZER BECOME HEALTHY IT IS
COST EFFECTIVE.
THE THIRD AND FINAL LESSON NOW
HOW TO HIGHLIGHT AND IT'S BEEN
REFERENCED ALREADY IS
COLLABORATION IS KEY. TEN YEARS
AGO WHEN FOUNDATION STARTED THIS
CURRENT MISSION OF ON
HOMELESSNESS WE TALKED WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LEADERSHIP.
AND LOS ANGELES WAS SEEN AS IT
IT NICELY AND I COURTED ORDEN
COORDINATED MASS AND HOW IT
ADDRESSED HOMELESSNESS NOT VERY
MUCH COORDINATION.
TODAY WE STILL HAVE BIG
CHALLENGES AS WE'VE DISCUSSED
BUT WE'RE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
STRONG PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT SHARE SIMILAR
VALUES.
AND A CO INVESTING IN THE SAME
STRATEGIES AND GOALS. ONE
IMPORTANT FACTOR GRAY THIS
APARTMENT IS HOME FOR GOOD
EFFORT WHICH CRISTINA MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THIS IS A TABLE WHERE --
UNITED WAY THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HELP CREATE A PLACE
WHERE BUSINESS LEADERS
PHILANTHROPY.
ELECTED OFFICIALS --
PUBLIC OFFICIALS HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMITTEES OR
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO COME
TOGETHER. TO WORK TOWARD A
COMMON GOAL OF ENDING
HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE A FUNDERS COLLABORATIVE
MANAGED BY UNITED WAY WHERE
PHILANTHROPIC AND PUBLIC SECTOR
FUNDERS.
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE
FUNDING AN ANNUAL REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS AND THERE'S A FACT
SHEET IN YOUR BUT YOURS AS WELL.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS THE
PUNDITS COLLABORATIVE HAS
BROUGHT TOGETHER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS.
WITH A ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS AND CITY AND COUNTY
RESOURCE.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS
IMPORTANT BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT
AS THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
COORDINATED AND WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER AND MAKING DECISIONS
TOGETHER WORKING TOWARDS THE
SAME GOAL.
WITH THE AMOUNT OF NEW CITY AND
COUNTY FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
REFERENCED --
ALMOST FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
THE NEXT TEN YEARS WE'RE SEEING
A GOOD PROBLEM ORGANIZATIONS ARE.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BUT
SOMETIMES THEY'RE OVERWHELMED.
AND SO THE FUNDERS COLLABORATIVE
HAS BEEN FOCUSING HELPING THE
BILL THE CAPACITY OF OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROVIDERS
WHOSE BUDGETS HAVE LITERALLY
TRIPLED.
THEY'VE HAD A TRIPLE THE SIZE OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES --
IN THEIR BUDGETS SO ARE ARE
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS
ARE HELPING BUILD THEIR CAPACITY.
TO TAKE ON THOSE RESOURCES SO
THEY CAN GET THE MONEY OUT AND
HELP MORE IMPORTANTLY HOUSE MORE
PEOPLE.
I AND THEN I DID WANT TO MENTION
THERE IS ANOTHER QUESTION I CAN
BE OPPOSITION AND AND CRISTINA
ALREADY REFERENCED EVERYONE IN.
WHICH IS A CAMPAIGN THAT
PHILANTHROPY SUPPORTS THROUGH
UNITED WAY BRED A LOS ANGELES
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CHECK IT OUT.
EVERYONE IN LA DOT ORG IS A
GREAT COMMUNITY EFFORT THAT
INCLUDES COMMUNITY EVENTS CAMINO
ORGANIZING TO BUILD SUPPORT FOR
THE SOLUTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO GET AHEAD OF THEM SO WE'RE
NOT PLAYING DEFENSE ALL THE TIME
AND WE ARE.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
EFFORT.
RECENT START SAY POLICIES
PROPOSITIONS AND LEGISLATION ARE
VITAL TO OUR COLLECTIVE EFFORTS
ON HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUCH TO BUILD ON FLANNERY'S
PLACE TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT INVESTING
PERMITS SOLUTIONS. TO ONE OF THE
GREAT MORAL ISSUES OF OUR DAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD.
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS --
THE CRITICAL HUMANITARIAN ISSUE
FOR OUR STATE AS WELL AS A
CRITICAL MORAL ISSUE AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED EARLIER AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRISIS.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER MARTIN
I'M A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON
HOMELESSNESS FOR HOUSING
CALIFORNIA I AM --
ONE OF ONLY TWO FULL TIME STATE
ADVOCATES WHO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY
ON ENDING HOMELESSNESS FOR ALL
POPULATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA THE OTHER BEING
SHARON REPORT RIGHT HERE. FOR
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS A
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY OR
ORGANIZATION WITH THE MISSION TO
ENSURE THAT NO ONE IS HOMELESS
AND EVERYONE HAS A SAFE STABLE
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE FOR ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT. ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED MANY TIMES TODAY THE
MOST IN THE NATION.
OF THOSE. SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
ARE ADULTS WITH NO ACCOMPANYING
FAMILY NO CHRONIC CONDITION AND
OFTEN NO EFFECTIVE PROGRAM TO
HELP THEM FIND A PERMANENT HOME.
ARE SINGLE INDIVIDUAL HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ABOUT TWICE THE NATIONAL RATE.
FOR IS A LARGE NUMBER BUT THIS
IS NOT AN IMPOSSIBLE NUMBER.
AND I'M GONNA TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT AN INNOVATIVE EVIDENCE
BASE SOLUTION TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND OTHER SIR
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS.
AND IT'S BEEN REFERENCED A
COUPLE TIMES ALREADY --
IT'S CALLED THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY. FOR FOR I PRESENT THIS
STATEWIDE SOLUTION AFTER SEVERAL
MONTHS OF RESEARCH AND
COLLECTION OF BEST PRACTICES AND
NEEDS.
THIS PAST FALL HOUSING
CALIFORNIA MET WITH LEADER IT'S
NICE IN FIVE DIFFERENT REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
SAN FRANCISCO.
SACRAMENTO FRESNO LOS ANGELES
AND SAN DIEGO.
AT EACH OF THESE CONVENIENCE WE
DISCUSS LOCAL BARRIERS TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS AND HOW THE STATE
COULD ASSIST IN EFFORTS FOR ONE
OF THE MOST COMMON RESPONSES WAS
THAT OUR STATE HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS COULD BE MORE
COORDINATED AND EFFECTIVE.
IN FACT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
FUNDED EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AT SIX DIFFERENT STATE
DEPARTMENTS.
EACH WITH DIFFERENT GOALS AND
POPULATION TARGETS FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESS SERVICES.
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LESS FILL MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS REQUIRING DIFFERENT
CRITERIA THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
DEADLINES WITH NO CROSS AGENCY
OR CROSS DEPARTMENTAL
COLLABORATION.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALSO
NOT USING EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES.
THE STATE COULD COMBINE SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROVEN TO
DECREASE HOMELESSNESS INTO ONE
STATEWIDE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL.
THIS RECOMMENDED SOLUTION BILLS
OFF THE SUCCESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT TODAY OF PLACES
THAT HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED A
FLEXIBLE LIKE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AS BILL DISCUSS.
FOR THIS FLEXIBLE COULD
CONSOLIDATE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
INTO A QUOTE ON QUOTE ONE STOP
SHOP. FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
NON PROFITS TO ACCESS VIA ONE
STREAMLINED APPLICATION.
THE FLEXIBLE WOULD ACCOMPLISH
ALL OF THE FOLLOWING.
I WOULD IMPLEMENT THE EVIDENCE
BASED MODEL OF HOUSING FIRST
STATEWIDE.
IT COULD PULL TOGETHER PRIVATE
LOCAL AND STATE INVESTMENT.
AND FACILITATE COLLABORATION
AMONG LOCAL --
MULTIPLE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS FOR THIS
FUNDING POOL IS INTENDED TO BE
FLEXIBLE IN EVERY SENSE OF THE
WORD PROVIDING GRANTS FOR ENDING
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH RENTAL
ASSISTANCE.
OPERATING SUBSIDIES SERVICES
SYSTEMS IMPROVEMENTS AND
TEMPORARY RELIEF. FOR EXAMPLE IN
ADDITION TO RENT SUBSIDIES THE
LA FLEXIBLE FUNDS A RANGE OF
CLIENT ASSISTANCE.
LIKE MOVING COSTS FURNITURE
PURITY DEPOSITS AND LANDLORD
INCENTIVES LIKE SIGNING BONUSES
AND VACANT UNIT UNIT HOLDS FOR
THESE ARE JUST AS ESSENTIAL AS
THE RENT SUBSIDY ITSELF. TO KELP
CALIFORNIANS FIND AND KEEP HOMES.
AN EFFECTIVE FLEXIBLE WITH THESE
SERVICES REQUIRES A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND LOCAL
COORDINATION TO THINGS THAT ARE
GOVERNOR OUTLINED IN HIS BUDGET
AS GOALS TO HELP AND
HOMELESSNESS.
SUCH PARTNERSHIPS AND
COORDINATION ARE CRUCIAL IF WE
ARE TO TRULY MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING SINGLE
ADULTS FAMILIES CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
PEOPLE EXITING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AN OLDER ADULTS.
THOUGH THERE ARE OVER FOUR
THOUSAND SUCCESSFUL STORIES
THANKS TO THE LOS ANGELES
FLEXIBLE AND LIKE TO SHARE.
ONE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN LA
RESIDENT.
EUGENE LAWSON WAS REFERRED TO
THE FLEXIBLE FUNDED PROGRAM TO A
FLEXIBLE FUNDED OUR PROGRAM RUN
BY SERVICE PROVIDER BILLION
CORNERS.
CALLED BREAKING BARRIERS.
EUGENE A BEEN A LONG LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE CULINARY STUDENT
TRYING TO OVERCOME AN ADDICTION
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE SUPPORTS
NECESSARY AND ENDED UP LOSING
HIS APARTMENT.
THROUGH A CASE MANAGER EUGENE
WAS ENROLLED IN BREAKING
BARRIERS AND WITHIN A FEW MONTHS
OF BEING STABLY HOUSE WITH THE
PROGRAM EUGENE FELL BACK INTO
ADDICTION.
THIS TIME HOWEVER.
HIS EXPERIENCE WAS DIFFERENT.
AS A PARTICIPANT OF BREAKING
BARRIERS HOUSING FIRST PROGRAM
WAS SERVICES.
EUGENE HAD THE SUPPORT AND
HOUSING STABILITY HE HAD LACKED
IN THE PAST.
IN A MOMENT OF HOPELESSNESS
EUGENE CALL HIS BREAKING
SUPPORT.
HE WAS IMMEDIATELY ADMITTED TO A
REHAB PROGRAM WHILE BEING ABLE
TO KEEP HIS APARTMENT.
AT THE COMPLETION OF THIS
PROGRAM EUGENE STILL HAD A PLACE
TO CALL HOME A SAFE PLACE WHERE
HE COULD FOCUS ON HIS HEALING
AND SCHOOLING.
FOR TODAY EUGENE IS THE HEAD
CHEF AT KAVA A SUCCESSFUL
MEDITERRANEAN RESTAURANT IN LOS
ANGELES.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM EUGENE.
IF I DIDN'T HAVE A STABLE LIVING
SAGE SITUATION I PROBABLY WOULD
ENDED UP BACK ON DRUGS AND IN
JAIL AGAIN.
EUGENE IS ONE OF OVER FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALONG.
SINCE THE START OF THEIR
FLEXIBLE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN THIS NUMBER EXCEEDS THE
COUNTIES AMBITIOUS GOAL OF
HOUSING TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED IN
ITS FIRST FOUR YEARS AND ARE
AVERAGING TWO HUNDRED NEW UNITS
SECURED PER MONTH. FOR IMAGINE
THE POSSIBILITIES FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA NEIGHBORS LIVING ON
THE STREETS OR IN CARS IN
TEMPORARY SHELTERS TODAY WHO
COULD BE SERVED IF THE STATE
HELP THE SCALE THIS PROGRAM UP.
THE NET COST SAVINGS AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES TODAY
ACCORDING TO A RAND STUDY OF THE
LOS ANGELES PROGRAM.
IS 20% IT'S NOT JUST HEARING
CRISIS BUT IT'S ALSO A PUBLIC
PRIVATE EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT.
WE ALL KNOW THIS THE ONLY
SOLUTION TO AND HOMELESSNESS IS
A HOME.
THE STATE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
END HOMELESSNESS FOR THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVELY THAN IT IS NOW WITH
A FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL.
AND I AM EXCITED TODAY TO
ANNOUNCE.
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
WILL BE AUTHORING LEGISLATION TO
CREATE THIS FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL PROGRAM FOR THANK
YOU AGAIN CHAIRS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE HOPE THAT YOU
ALL WILL SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION
WHEN IT IS HEARD IN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN.
MR MECCA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MISTER
CHAIR I AM FRANK MAC OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND I'M PARTICULARLY GRATIFIED.
TO BE HERE BECAUSE TO MY
RECOLLECTION THIS IS THE FIRST
SUCH JOINT HEARING.
AT LEAST IN MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF A CB DA.
AND I THINK THAT JUST RECOGNIZES
YOUR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF OUR SORT
OF MAIN POINT HERE TODAY AND
THAT IS.
THE INTERSECTION IN
COLLABORATION BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEMS HOUSING
SYSTEMS AND HUMAN SERVICES
SYSTEMS ARE CRITICAL FOR THE
SUCCESS OF ALL.
AND WHAT.
MY MEMBERS THE HUMAN SERVICES
DIRECTORS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
INCREASINGLY EXPERIENCED.
IN THE LAST DECADE OR SO.
ON IS AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR
POPULATIONS WHICH IS UNDERMINING
OUR SUCCESS. TO GET THE OUTCOMES
THAT YOU WANT TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES SYSTEMS WHETHER IT'S
APPARENT ON CAL WORKS WHO JOB I
CAN'T FIND A STABLE PLACE TO
LIVE.
WHETHER IT'S APPARENT IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WHOSE RESOLVE
ALL THE ISSUES NECESSARY TO BE
RESOLVED.
AND CAN'T BE REUNIFIED WITH
THEIR CHILD BUT FOR THE FACT
THAT THEY CAN'T FIND A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE WHETHER
IT'S THE ELDER ABUSE VICTIM WHO
WE REMOVED FROM AN ABUSIVE
CARETAKER.
STABLE I'VE THEIR SITUATION BUT
CAN'T FIND A PLACE TO LIVE WERE
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH --
WHOSE NAVIGATING A WORLD BUT
LARGELY BY THEMSELVES AND HAVING
DIFFICULTY --
OBTAINING HOUSING [inaudible]
AND SO -- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A FEW POINTS FOR YOU THIS
MORNING BATTING CLEAN UP.
THE FIRST IS THAT --
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR CLIENTS
IS IN A MULTI FACETED BUT IT'S
REALLY DRIVEN BY TWO PRIMARY
FACTORS.
AND THAT'S A STAGNATING
STAGNATING WAGES AND PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE BENEFITS AND
SKYROCKETING RENTS.
THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT ROCKET SCIENCE BUT WE
SAW FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE
RECESSION WHEN.
CAL ARTS GRANTS WERE CUT IN
IMMEDIATE SPIKE AND HOMELESSNESS
AMONG CARRACKS FAMILIES.
THAT WAS COTERMINOUS ALMOST
EXACTLY TO THE POINT WHEN THE
STATE CUT CAL WORKS GRANTS AND
IMMEDIATELY WE HAD MORE --
HOMELESS FAMILIES --
AND SO THE WAGES BENEFITS AND
RISING RENTS AND HOMELESSNESS --
IS UNMISTAKABLE.
SO -- ONE
MESSAGE I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE
WITH YOU TODAY'S ANTI POVERTY
STRATEGIES ARE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION STRATEGIES.
AND FROM OUR EXPERIENCE AMONG
THE MOST IF NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION STRATEGIES YOU CAN
ENGAGE IN.
WE APPRECIATE MORE THAN
APPRECIATE WE SO --
ARE GRATEFUL FOR WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST GOVERNOR
IN THE CURRENT GOVERNOR OF DONE
TO RAISE WELFARE GRANTS SO THAT
NO CHILD LIVES IN DEEP POVERTY.
A VAST THE CREATION OF A STATE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AND AN
ALMOST DOUBLING OF THAT CREDIT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE INCREASE IN THE MINIMUM WAGE
THESE ARE ALL CRITICAL
INITIATIVES --
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO TRY TO KEEP
PACE WITH THEM BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR RENT RENT AND IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YET DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THESE INCREASES ARE HISTORIC --
BY BY HISTORICAL COMPARISONS WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND
ONE WAY TO ILLUSTRATE THAT.
IS TO COMPARE THAT MAXIMUM
GRANTS AND CAL WORKS TO THE HUD
FAIR MARKET RENT SO IF YOU LOOK
AT MAXIMUM GRANT FOR A FAMILY OF
THREE AND COMPARE IT TO THE HARD
FAIR MARKET RENT. FOR A TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT THE CALYX
GRANT WOULD PAY 432% OF THAT
FAIR MARKET RENT.
NOW YOU ALL MIGHT SAY WELL
THAT'S SAN FRANCISCO THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT AN OUT WIRE.
IN SAN BERNADINO THE GRANT WOULD
ON THAT CAL WORKS GRANT WOULD
ONLY PAY FOR THREE QUARTERS OF
THE FAIR MARKET RENT.
IN LA AND SAN DIEGO IT'S A
LITTLE LESS THAN HALF.
AND RURAL AREAS BOTH IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE NORTH PART
OF THE STATE DON'T ESCAPE THIS
PHENOMENON AS WELL.
AND FRESNO MADERA HUMBOLDT --
THE CAL WORKS GRANT COULD NOT
PAY FOR THE FAIR MARKET RENT IT
WOULD BE LESS THAN 85%.
AND SO ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO THINK ABOUT ANTI POVERTY
STRATEGIES AS HOMELESSNESS
STRATEGIES --
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING.
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF IN BETTING
HOMELESSNESS.
INTERVENTION RESOURCES WITH IN
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS
MY COLLEAGUE ALLEY SITE AND
DISCUSS THE SO I WON'T GO INTO.
RE DESCRIBING THEM ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY GET THE
SERVICE SAYS TO A COW WORKS MOM.
TO A FAMILY IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM TO A TRANSITION H. FOSTER
YOUTH -- IS
OFF AND WHAT WHAT CREATE SUCCESS
FOR US LISTS --
AND WOOD WOULD REMAIN WOULD
REMAIN HOMELESS --
THER'S SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGES
TO EMBEDDING THESE HOMELESSNESS
RESOURCES WITH IN.
THE TOOLBOX OF HUMAN SERVICES --
PROGRAM --
IN PART BECAUSE WE HAVE ACCESS
TO UNIQUELY VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE --
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND OTHER WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE FIRST.
BENEFICIARIES OF THE CALYX
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM SHE'S IN
YOLO COUNTY SHE WAS SHE WAS
LIVING IN HER CAR WITH HER THREE
CHILDREN WHO ARE GOING TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY --
SHE WAS ESCAPING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SHE WAS ON THE RUN --
SHE FOUND THE COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY DAY CONNECTED
HER IN YOLO COUNTY THEY
CONNECTED HER WITH THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAM TO PROTECT HER
FROM HER ABUSER THEY CONNECTED
HER WITH MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
TO TO DEAL WITH THE TRAUMA OF
HER ABUSE THEY CONNECTED HER
WITH CHILD CARE AND EMPLOYMENT --
SERVICES TO BE ABLE TO PREPARE
FOR EMPLOYMENT SHE COULDN'T FIND
A PLACE TO LIVE.
AND IT WAS INHIBITING HER
ABILITY TO TO COMPLETE HER
SUCCESS.
ALMOST AT THE SAME TIME THAT SHE
WAS GOING THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE THE STATE LAUNCHED A
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM.
AND IT WAS THE FINAL PIECE OF
SERVICES THAT ALLOWED HER. TO TO
LEAVE THE ROLES AND SHE'S NOW
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED AND OFF THE
THE HUMAN SERVICES ROLES.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S HAPPENED
IN THE CREATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS IT IT'S BROUGHT THE
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES INTO
LOCAL HOMELESSNESS NETWORKS.
MY LAST BOARD MEETING I ASKED MY
MEMBERS HOW MANY OF YOU ARE
MEANING FULLY ENGAGED IN YOUR
LOCAL CONTINUE OF CARE.
IT WAS ALMOST ALL OF THEM.
IF I ASKED THAT QUESTION TEN
YEARS AGO WOULD BE.
TO SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
AND SO THE WORLD ARE COMING
TOGETHER AND AND GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING BECAUSE THOSE WORLDS
ARE COMING TOGETHER.
THE NUMBER ONE BARRIER WE FACE --
BY COULD ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU
ASKED A PRIOR WITNESS CHAIRMAN
CHIU IS A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUPPLY.
SERVICES ARE ALL CRITICAL BUT
WHAT WE'RE BUMPING UP AGAINST IS
IS BEING ABLE TO FIND --
LANDLORDS --
THAT WILL RENT A DECENT PLACE A
PRICE THAT OUR CLIENTS CAN
AFFORD.
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT THE ARRAY
I'M TELLING YOU FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES WE ARE BUMPING UP
AGAINST THE SUPPLY PROBLEM AS
THE KEY BARRIER. TO BEING ABLE
TO EXPAND THE SUCCESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO QUICKLY GOING.
INTO SOME AREAS OF OF SOLUTIONS
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE ANTI
POVERTY PROGRAMS.
EXPANSIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT --
MAKE SURE WE ADD COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE CALYX PROGRAM
IN THE E. I. T. C. INTO AS A
SIZES BE.
SO THOSE PROGRAMS DON'T LOSE
PACE --
AGAINST INFLATION.
I THINK WE NEED TO MAINS
MAINTAIN SUPPORT EVALUATE IN THE
WAY THAT MY COLLEAGUE --
MISS SUDDEN TALKED ABOUT THESE
HUMAN SERVICES SPECIFIC
HOMELESSNESS INTERVENTIONS --
AND BRING THEM TO SCALE --
THERE THEY DO NOT SERVE THE
ENTIRE POTENTIAL POPULATION THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM
IS THE PROGRAM FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. TWELVE COUNTIES GOT
FUNDED --
OUT OF TWENTY THREE THAT APPLIED --
THAT PROGRAM IS ABOUT TO EXPIRE
AND COUNTIES ARE ABOUT TO START
CLOSING DOWN INTAKE AND SO WILL
ASK THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS TO RE
AUTHORIZE --
THAT BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM I WOULD LIKE TO TO
CONCUR WITH MS REPORT I THINK
THE STATE HAS TO INVEST IN LONG
TERM RENTAL SUBSIDIES.
WE HAVE MANY CLIENTS THAT WE
HELP WHOSE WHOSE ONLY BARRIER.
TO STAYING HOUSED IS THE GAP
BETWEEN WHAT THEY MAKE.
AND HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO LIVE.
AND WHAT THEY MAKE IS THE MOST
THAT THEY CAN THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN ARE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED --
AND SO IT SEEMS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
US -- TO
FIGURE HOW WE COULD STEM THE
TIDE.
AGAINST HOMELESSNESS UNTIL WE
CAN DEAL WITH THE SUPPLY ISSUE
WITHOUT CREATING EXPANDED --
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
AND I THINK.
ONCE WE DO THAT.
WE ALSO HAVE TO ADDRESS
DISCRIMINATION ON THE COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES EVERYDAY
EXPERIENCE THE DIFFICULTY
FINDING LANDLORDS WHO MAY HAVE A
UNIT BUT ARE UNWILLING TO RENT
TO OUR CLIENTS WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER.
WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE THEIR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE THEIR SUBSIDY IN SOME
WAY COMES FROM GOVERNMENT.
AND SO WE WOULD CONCUR WITH THAT
PRIOR WITNESSES --
THAT RECOMMENDED ADDING SOURCE
OF INCOME --
TO THE TENANT PROTECTIONS --
AND FINALLY I THINK WE NEED TO
SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME
FOCUSING ON THE NEEDS OF
TRANSITION H. FOSTER YOUTH WHO
ARE NAVIGATING THIS WORLD.
AND MANY CASES WITH VERY LITTLE
SUPPORT SOMETIMES WITH SUBSIDIES
BUT NOT THE HELP NAVIGATING A
SYSTEM THAT IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE WITH
RESOURCES NEVER MIND PEOPLE.
WHO'VE GROWN UP --
WITHOUT THAT PARENTAL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU LET'S SAID BRING IT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS --
I'LL KICK IT OFF WITH ONE
QUESTION TO MISTER MECCA --
I WAS VERY STRUCK BY YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT THE LINK BETWEEN A
DROP AND CAL WORKS.
ASSISTANCE AND AND HOMELESSNESS
AND IT I WANT TO JUST PUBLICLY
TO MY CHAIR AND POTENTIALLY --
STAFF AS WELL AS THOSE OF YOU
WHO WORK ON THESE ISSUES WHICH
IS OFTENTIMES OF ANTI POVERTY
STRATEGIES WE INTUITIVELY KNOW
THE IMPACT ON HOMELESSNESS.
ART BUT THE DEBATE WE HAVE HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE IS USUALLY A
FUNCTION OF HOW MUCH BUDGET WE
HAVE.
AND HOW GENEROUS WERE FEELING IN
ANY PARTICULAR YEAR RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON WHAT THE IMPACT OF A
DOLLAR NOT SPENT IN AN AREA IS
GOING TO HAVE IN OTHER AREAS SO --
WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE MISS REPORT
A FEW YEARS AGO HAD ASKED MY
OFFICE TO INTRODUCE A BILL.
THAT HAS BECOME THE HOUSING FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WHICH
ADDRESSES THE REALITY THAT IF
YOU'RE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ON
THE STREETS.
YOUR HEALTH CARE COST YOUR
IMPACT ON THE EMERGENCY ROOMS ON
IT JAIL HEALTH SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES LET'S SAY
IT'S SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR A CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
PERSON.
AND IT ONLY COST US SAY NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO PUT A
SUPPORT OF HOUSING ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS. TO AVOID SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF COSTS WHAT I
HAVE WONDERED IS FOR MANY OF THE
SOCIAL SERVICE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WITHIN.
MEN OF CHAIRS COMMITTEE THAT SHE
IS FIGHTING.
FOR HOW CAN WE PUT THE
INTERSECTION ALLEY TOGETHER HOW
DO WE PULL THAT DATA OUT SO THAT
WE KNOW THAT IF WE WERE TO
INCREASE FUNDING TO THEIR FOR TO
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
THAT COULD HELP US.
SAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF EXPENSES WHEN IT
COMES TO HOMELESSNESS SO I WANT
TO SORT OF PUT THAT OUT AS A AS
A CONCEPT AS A POTENTIALLY
CHALLENGE FOR FOR STAFF AND
ADVOCATES TO THINK ABOUT.
BUT WOULD LOVE TO TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION OF HOW WE HOW
WE SHOW.
ALL OF THOSE LINKS AND AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE SPEND AS AS AS
WELL AS WE CAN AS EFFICIENTLY AS
WE CAN AS WELLS AS HUMANELY AS
WE CAN.
WITHOUT I KNOW --
MS QUIRK SILVA HAS SOME COMMENTS --
ON THE HOUSING THAT MODEL WHERE
YOU MAY BRING AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS.
I KNOW ORANGE COUNTY IS LOOKING
TOWARDS A MODEL --
TO BUILD A MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY BUT ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
KAISER AND CAL OPTIMA PUT N
SOME DOLLARS I THINK THAT.
ACTUALLY COMES OUT OF THE
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY ARE --
RECEIVING SO MANY CHRONICALLY
ILL PATIENTS COMING INTO THEIR
EMERGENCY ROOMS THAT THEY'RE
REALIZING THAT THIS IN FACT IS A
MODEL THAT IF SUPPORTED WOULD
GIVE THEM SOME RELIEF AT THE
HOSPITALS --
BUT THAT BEING SAID I WANTED TO
ASK IN AGAIN WHOEVER CAN ANSWER
THIS ON THE SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING WHICH I KNOW IS A DONE
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS.
A PROPOSAL TO REDUCE THE SECTION
EIGHT HOUSING --
ALLOTMENT OR TO THAT END HAS
THAT ACTUALLY OCCURRED AND WHAT
IS THAT LOOK LIKE FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RECEIVING A TAKE A STAB
AT THAT --
SO THAT HAS BEEN A A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL --
IT IS NOT YET PASSED --
AND THERE ARE SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND WHETHER WORK
REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE REQUIRED
SHOULD BE ADDED TO RECEIVE
SECTION EIGHT SO THOSE TWO
THINGS WOULD.
SIGNIFICANTLY --
THIS PLACE WE THINK A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE RECEIVING VALUE
NOW.
SO IN CALIFORNIA IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT WE COULD DO ABOUT
THEM.
I MEAN YOU COULD CERTAINLY AND
WE WOULD RECOMMEND SEPARATE AND
APART FROM WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO CREATE --%
STATE FUNDED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND THEN YOU
IT WOULD BE UP TO YOU TO BE ABLE
TO SET WITH THOSE.
BUT THE GENEROSITY OF THAT
SUPPORT IS.
AND THEN ONE ONE LAST QUESTION
ON THE MODEL WHERE WE ARE
LOOKING AT NOW OF COURSE HOUSING
FIRST.
WITH SUPPORT FROM EMERGENCY
HOUSING.
RAPID RESPONSE IN OTHER WAYS TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS
VOUCHERS THINGS LIKE THAT WE
HAVEN'T HEARD A LOT ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE SENSE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL WOULD NOT BE ABLE --
TO MANAGE ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
HOUSING FIRST.
EMERGENCY SHELTER THEY ALSO WILL
NOT DO WELL --
ARE WE LOOKING AT ANY I AS FAR
IS UP A MENTAL HEALTH --
SOME TYPE OF HOUSING I KNOW WE
WENT THROUGH THIS DECADES AGO
BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE --
INDIVIDUALS WHERE THE EMERGENCY
MODEL AND AT THE HOUSING ENOUGH
ALONE DOES NOT WORK ARE THERE
ANY MODELS OUT THERE. TO ME I
THINK THE THE MODEL OF SUPPORT
OF HOUSING --
IT IS JUST THAT WHERE EVEN IF
IT'S HOUSING FIRST YOU ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BECOME STABILIZED --
AND AND MAKE THOSE SERVICES
AVAILABLE THAT'S WITH A
PARTNERSHIP --
FOR EXAMPLE IN LA AND OTHER
PLACES WHERE YOU HAVE THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND THE MOUNT TELL
DEPARTMENT.
THEY'RE WORKING TOGETHER
PROVIDING THE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED THAT WE WE
CERTAINLY AND I'VE MET LOTS OF
THESE PEOPLE WHO.
STRUGGLED FOR YEARS ON THE
STREETS --
DUE TO MASS HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER --
HAVING A PLACE UPON A PLACE TO
LIVE THERE STABILIZE THE GOT THE
HELP AND NOW ARE.
THRIVING WORKING CONTRIBUTING TO
HEALTH FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR
THAT S..
AND NO PLACE LIKE HOME IF I
COULD JUST MENTION --
NO PLACE LIKE HOME IS
PROPOSITION TWO THAT WAS JUST
RECENTLY PASSED BY VOTERS.
WILL CREATE --
REVENUE BOND TO BOND AGAINST
SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES ACT DOLLARS TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS AND WILL.
PROVIDE SERVICES IN HOUSING FOR
THOSE FOR THAT POPULATION.
IN IF I MIGHT.
ALSO TO MR CHOOSE POINT --
THE STATE CREATED A MEDICAID --
SADDAM MEDICAID WAIVER FOR THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE.
PILOT PROGRAM TO TRY TO GET OUT
THE USE OF MEDICAID DOLLARS --
TO HELP HOMELESS PEOPLE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE IDEA THAT
WE'RE SPENDING A LOT MORE MONEY
EARNED MONEY IN OTHER SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO HOUSING THE
ONE THAT WAIVER THAT WE WERE
GRANTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS THAT WE COULD NOT
PAY FOR THE HOUSING --
WITH THE MEDICAID DOLLARS AND SO
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL.
ADDS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I
BELIEVE TO THE WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS WHICH MAKES IT THE WHOLE
WHOLE PERSON.
CARE PILOT AND I THINK THERE ARE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK AT
HOW THAT HOW THOSE PILOTS WILL
WORK WHEN WE CAN ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE HOUSING AS WELL AS
THE OTHER.
SUPPORT OF SERVICES [inaudible]
I'M SURE.
WHEN WE THINK OF CREATIVE WAYS
OF SOLVING SOME OF OUR ISSUES --
THAT'S WHAT WANT ONE OF THOSE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WAS GIVEN TO ME
DURING OUR DREAM BIG I. E. WE
HAVE OUR MILLENNIALS TALK ABOUT
SOLUTIONS.
THE TALK ABOUT THE BIG PROBLEMS
AND THEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE
BARRIERS THAT WE ALL HAVE
BECAUSE SO WE'VE ALREADY TRIED
THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY
WITHIN THEMBI'S WE THINK OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S WRONG.
BUT THE MULLIN MEALS ARE YOU'D
GET TOGETHER AND THEY SAID THEY
LOOK AT THESE BIG SOLUTIONS AND
THEY HAVE NO BARRIERS ARE SAY IN
ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS.
THAT THEY HAD TO HOMELESSNESS --
SAID LET'S DO WHAT AND I BELIEVE
IT'S HAWAII DOES.
WITH A DOCTOR CAN PRESCRIBE.
HOUSING.
AS PART OF THE TREATMENT FOR
THAT PERSON.
AND SO WHAT WOULD WE LOOK AT
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE THAT WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A THERE ARE
OTHER BARRIERS RELATED TO THAT.
BUT I THINK THAT BEING CREATIVE
I THINK IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
I THINK THE WORK THAT YOU ALL DO
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE TELLING US ABOUT THE
GAP.
THAT WE HAVE BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE
SOLUTIONS AND I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR YOU READY PRESCRIBE SOME
HOUSING.
I HAVE.
HAD READY BUT I'D PROBABLY
PURSUE SEPARATE AND APART --
WANTED TO SPEAK TO YOU MISTER
MARTIN AND ASK ABOUT THE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS WHO YOU HAD
REACHED OUT SPECIFICALLY TO IN
FRESNO -- OF
THE I'M QUITE INTERESTED IN THE
PROPOSAL THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
UIRK SILVA IS GOING TO PROPOSE
AND WOULD LOVE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE IF I CAN.
JOIN YOU IN THAT VENTURE BUT
WANTS TO REACH AND DISCUSS WITH
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS
WELL AND I'M JUST I'M WONDERING
WHO SPECIFICALLY IT WAS. ONE
FRESNO --
ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR THE PERSON
HELP COORDINATE THAT IS HERE
TODAY SELF --
SO SHE HELPED HOST THAT --
CONVENING SPECIFICALLY --
WE HAVE A LOT OF COUNT BECAUSE
FRESNO HAS A A LARGE GEOGRAPHIC
AREA THAT SURROUNDS IT THAT'S A
FAIRLY RURAL WE HAD A LOT OF
VARIOUS COUNTY OFFICIALS --
COME TO THAT ONE I'M A LOT OF
THIS UC'S FOR THAT AREA CAME --
AND CA FEW DEVELOPERS AS WELL SO
SEND A MAJOR LARGER ENTITIES
THAT WE MAY WANTS TO INCORPORATE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS THE SIERRA
HEALTH FOUNDATION.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAY ALLOW US
TO BRING IN SOME PLAN TO BE
DOLLARS AS WELL SO --
WILL WANTS TO REACH OUT TO MISS
SMITH AND TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
ON THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
YEAH LATER ABOUT THE ONE OF
THESE SUGGESTIONS ARE AMONG MANY
MISTER MARTIN YOU IS SUCH A
STATE THAT AND THEY'RE ALSO --
HE WAS NOT QUITE SURE.
THAT THAT IS SO THE IDEA OF A
CENTRAL A STATE WIDE THE
COORDINATING AGENCY ONE STOP
SHOP -- IS
THAT WHAT YOU ARE PROPOSING WORE
A A SAID THE UNDER WALKING.
YEAH I THINK THE THE IDEA WOULD
DO WITH THE FLEXIBLE AS TO BE
THAT KIND OF THAT --
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE
CENTRALIZED RESOURCES --
AND WE WERE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
KIND OF COMBINING FOR VARIOUS
POPULATIONS AS OPPOSED TO THE
KIND OF RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE HAVE
BOUTIQUE.
PROGRAMS --
THROUGHOUT STATE GOVERNMENT --
AND AND SO WE'RE LOOKING TO KIND
OF CENTRALIZED THINGS --
THAT'S NOT TO SAY EVERY PROGRAM
WOULD BE UNDER THIS UMBRELLA --
BUT IT IT IS TO LOOK AT SOME
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS AND MAKING
SURE THEY'RE ALL UNDER ONE
CENTRALIZED RESOURCE.
AND WE ARE DEALING WITH A VERY --
WHICH ISSUE THE AND ALL.
HOUSING AND THE HUMAN SERVICES --
AND OR LOCAL OR STATE THAT
EVERYTHING BUT THE AS I SAID IN
THE BEGINNING YOU KNOW COMMENT I
THINK WE NEED.
TO LOOK INTO THE POSSIBILITY OF
A STATE WIDE.
ON TO THAT ENOUGH GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE A TASK FORCE TO YOU KNOW.
TO IN A ONE AGENCY DOESN'T KNOW
YOU KNOW WHAT THE OTHER ONE THE
STORIES THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
GAP.
AND LAG COORDINATION.
GREAT AND I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE WE WE DO HAVE A STATE
HOMELESS ACCORDING TO COUNSEL
AND I DO KNOW THAT --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS PROPOSED
THE POSITION OF A HOMELESS CZAR
TO BRING ALL THIS TOGETHER SO
LOOKING FORWARD.
TO THAT NEWS IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ARE UNLESS THERE ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I WANT TO THANK THE
THIRD PANEL AND I'D LIKE TO SAY
TO ALL THE PANELISTS.
WOULD REALLY LOVE IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO US BECAUSE YOUR CUSTOMERS
WERE SO RICH AND WE WANT TO BE
ABLE -- TO
THOROUGHLY DIGESTED BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ON I WANT TO ASK MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IT IS TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT HOW MANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO SAY WORKS
PUBLIC COMMENT GREAT --
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT I
KNOW -- BOTH
THE DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
CAUCUSES HAVE MEETINGS AT THIS
TIME SO DO EXPECT MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WILL NEED TO GO FOR
THAT -- AT
BUT IF I COULD ASK IF ANYONE
WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STEP UP TO
THE MICROPHONE I THINK WE WILL
UNFORTUNATELY NEED TO LIMIT
COMMENT TO THIRTY SECONDS IF WE
CAN BUT OF COURSE.
IF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO US WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
REVIEW THAT AND WITH THAT FOR
SPEAKER.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THANK YOU FOR A VERY
INFORMATIVE HEARING.
I'M WE DEFINITELY WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR ALL THE RESOURCES BEING
BROUGHT TO BEAR AND THE CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS LAST YEAR.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
THIS YEAR GAPS IN TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTIES TO
LEVERAGE THEIR EXPERIENCING
CONNECTING PEOPLE SERVICES I DO
WANT TO JUST REITERATE TWO
THEMES FROM EARLIER TESTIMONY I
WAS REALLY STRUCK BY THE COMMENT
BY THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS.
ABOUT HOW ALL THE PIECES ARE
PRESENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
THE PROBLEM HAS REALLY BEEN THE
FLOW AND THE ALIGNMENT AND SO I
THINK THAT CONCEPT OF
COORDINATION AMONG LOCAL
ENTITIES.
REALLY NEEDS TO GUIDE FUTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AN END APOLOGIES FOR
THE LATE HOUR --
IF WE COULD ASK FOLKS TO REALLY
TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
THIRTY SECONDS BUT KNOWING THAT
WE VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE YOUR
TESTIMONY IF YOU CAN --
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE A LOT OF
IDEAS THAT ARE OUT THERE THERE
WERE NOT DISCUSSED TODAY WE
WANNA MAKE SURE WE GET THEM AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU KEVIN
AS THE COALITION CALIFORNIA
ROUGH RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THE CALVET STRESS WE ARE THE
SAME LEVEL THAT THERE WERE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND THAT'S
A BECAUSE OF HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
THE TWO TYPES OF HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ONE OF THE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT
IS AN APARTMENT.
THAT EVERYBODY CAN GET ONE OF
THE OF THE HOUSE HOW HOUSING
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM.
HAD POSSIBLY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
SERVE SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE THE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT
IS AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
SEARCHED A FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAS
ABOUT THE FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE THINK WE NEED.
TO OF THE WAREHOUSE AND COMMENTS
ABOUT SPECIFIC GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NIMBIS WE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY.
I'M JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEES AND THE LEGISLATURE
IN GENERAL FOR THEIR THE ON THE
ISSUE OF HOUSING JOINING US HE'S
ACTS COMMENTS HOPING THAT YOU
KNOW DOES IT TO SEE THIS MOVE
FORWARD AS A AS A JOINTLY
CONSIDERED ISSUE.
THANKS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER IN THE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR
DISASSOCIATION I WOULD JUST LIKE --
TO ECHO SOME OF THE SUN AND IT'S
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
THAT THROUGH THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT WITH NO PLACE LIKE
HOME WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS COMING
DOWN THE PIPELINE THROUGH H. CD
THIS YEAR.
AND THE COUNTIES ARE WORKING
HARD ON THE APPLICATIONS TO
BUILD THESE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND THEY WERE EXCITED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
SPEED UP THE ALLOCATIONS OF
THESE FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU I'M
SUPPORTING THEIR WORK TO PREVENT
AND END HOMELESSNESS AMONG THAT
ACCOMPANIED YOUTH AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING TODAY
AND IN LIGHT OF TIME I'LL SUBMIT
A COPY OF A ROAD MAP THAT WE
HAVE. FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE SOLUTIONS
AROUND YOU AND NOTE THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
YOU SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING.
AND THEY USE THE SPECIAL BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE ARE NOT
JUST INCORPORATED INTO LIKE
ADULTS SHELTERS BECAUSE THEY
NEED SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S NOT THE SAFEST PLACE FOR
THEM WHEN THEY'RE INCORPORATED.
AN WITH ADULTS AND WE WANT THEM
TO BE SERVED WE WANT THEM TO GET
SUPPORT.
AND WE NEED SPECIFIC YOUTH
PROGRAMS AND NOT JUST IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION THINKING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OVER THE LAST ELEVEN
YEARS WE HAVE DECREASED ARE
HOMELESSNESS NUMBER BY 60% --
WE'VE DONE THAT BY UTILIZING A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL FUNDING --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE HELP OF
OUR DELEGATION THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IN YOUR
FOCUS ON HOMELESSNESS ISSUES AND
WE HOPE THAT IT CONTINUES.
MY NAME IS THOMAS OF REASON --
WITH THIS FUNDING --
HELPS FAMILIES LIKE MYSELF --
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME MY KIDS
ARE IN FOSTER CARE AND WITH THE
FUNDING THAT.
ON THE FAMILIES GET HELPED HIM A
LOT AND I LIKE.
TO THANK YOU AND HOPE I MAKE IT
FUNNY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS RAN MARTIN
HERE WE HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION MISTER CHAIR WILL BE
SURPRISED AT MY COMMENTS HAVE TO
DO WITH THE PROBLEM THE
ESCALATING.
RENT PRICES AND HOW THAT'S
AFFECTING HOMELESSNESS AND WHILE
THEY'RE CERTAINLY SOLUTIONS IN
THE ON THE MONEY SIDE OF THINGS
IN TERMS OF RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE WE ALSO HAVE
POLICY ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED --
THAT WILL KEEP THOSE RUNS UNDER
CONTROL SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING SHOVED OUT OF THERE OUT OF
THEIR HOMES OR PREVENTED FROM
GETTING INTO HOME.
BECAUSE THE RENTS ARE TOO HIGH
MAKE IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI THERE MY NAME'S MICHELLE GOT
FREEDOM APPARENT PARTNER WITH
YOUR COUNTY CHILD WELFARE I'VE
BEEN A KEY PLAYER IN UTILIZING
BE A FACE MANY FOR MY FAMILIES.
WE SUCCESSFULLY HOUSE OVER
THIRTY FIVE FAMILIES AND OUR
FIRST YEAR ALONE --
WITHOUT THIS BE A FACE DOLLARS
AND THEY WERE NEVER EVERY
UNIFIED AND I WOULD LOVE.
TO BE AWARDED ANOTHER GRANT THEM
THIS COMING YEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
JEEP KAMALA I'M A SENIOR ANALYST
WITH HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY NON THE
CHILD WELFARE LEAGUE FOR THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM I
JUST WANTED TO COME HERE AND LET
YOU KNOW THAT IS HAD A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON OUR FAMILIES WERE.
FAIR WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HOUSE
TEN FAMILIES AND THAT'S
EQUIPMNT ALIVE FIFTEEN CHILDREN
AND THAT'S BEEN A ON GOING BARE
WITH OUR FAMILIES.
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO HOPE THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S CONTINUED
FUNDING AND EFFORTS. TO INCREASE
THIS PROGRAM --
AS AS YOU HEARD THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL
YOU'VE DONE.
Q. ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEN ON PUBLIC COMMENT IS NOW
CLOSED I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND AT THIS HEARING ARE AND LET
FOLKS KNOW THAT IF YOU DO GET
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO US BY THE
END OF THE DAY OUR STAFF WILL
HELP TO CIRCULATE THAT.
TOO UP MEMBERS OF OF BOTH
COMMITTEES AS WELL AS PUBLIC --
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO BE A VERY
VERY TOP PRIORITY FOR OUR
COMMITTEE --
IN ADDITION WORK THAT WE ARE
GONNA BE DOING THIS YEAR TO
THINK ABOUT HOW.
TO INCREASE LEVELS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HOW TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION AT ALL LEVELS
AFFORDABILITY HOW TO PROTECT
TENANTS AND OTHERS FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS IN THE FIRST PLACE --
WE HAVE OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR
WITH AT FOR US BUT LOOKING FOR
TO WORKING WITH --
MICHAEL FROM THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE.
TO BUILD SUPPORT FOR SOLUTIONS
SO THAT HOPEFULLY SOME DAY THE
MORAL QUESTION OF TWENTY
NINETEEN IS ONE THAT WE CAN SAY
WAS -- WAS A
TOPIC THAT WE WORKED HARD TO
ADDRESS AND AND HOPEFULLY
ELIMINATE.
AND WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OF MY CULTURE MANAGER.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MY CHAIR FROM
HOUSING.
THE TO COMMITTEES MUST WORK
TOGETHER THE THE ISSUES HERE
AFFECT US IN WAYS THAT ONLY
THESE TWO COMMITTEES.
PROBABLY BECAUSE WE ARE THE
CHAIRS CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS
ISSUE AND I AGREE WITH YOU I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS AND I THANK
ALL OF YOU WHO'VE PRESENTED
THOSE OF YOU WITH COMMENTED
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS NOW
CLOSED